>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> John Cole: Well,
good morning everyone.
Good morning and welcome
to the Library of Congress
for the first time
for several of you.
And welcome back to those of you
who are able to join us last night.
I'm John Cole.
I'm the Director of the Center
for the Book in the Library
of Congress an organization was
created by Dr. Daniel Boorstin back
in 1977 to reach out on behalf
of the Library of Congress
to promote books and reading
and to promote the study
and encourage the study
of books and reading.
To that menu since 1977,
we've added literacy
which was not discussed
much in 1977.
Another major topic that
where there's difference
but similarity was the
threat in 1977 of technology.
Everyone was worried but the
technology we were worried
about was television and Dr.
Boorstin created the center,
in part, I learned after
accepting his offer
to become the founding director.
He had an idea and that was to
start using commercial television
to promote books and reading.
And we were able to
do that through--
for 10 years through a project
with CBS television
called Read More About It.
And we put those from
reading messages at the ends
of major CBS programs and
start with the programs.
And if you enjoyed the program,
the Library of Congress suggests
these books and we have books
that came across the screen that the
message was go to your local library
or bookstore, not the
Library of Congress.
Go to your library or
bookstore, they will be happy
to help you read more about it.
And from that grew one of our
reading promotion networks
with not only television
and technology involved.
But booksellers and librarians
and gradually we are Center
for the Book will have its 40th
anniversary next year in 2017.
But the project that brings us
together is a special project
that came to the Center for the
Book through David Rubenstein,
a philanthropist who's doing
some many wonderful things
for our country but in Washington,
DC in terms of helping
support government institutions
that have a relationship to American
history, largely and that appeal
to Mr. Rubenstein in
terms of his interest.
And we did not know when Mr.
Rubenstein first started giving help
to the National Book Festival
which is another major Center
for the Book endeavor,
now in its 16th year
that Mr. Rubenstein had
this interest in literacy.
And that came a little
later and he is the one
who initiated this project
and he's funding it.
And I'm so pleased to have
you here and to be able
to explain a little bit about the
framework that's brought us here.
We have aboard, the
Literacy of Advisory Board
to help us during the 5-year
pilot grant from Mr. Rubenstein.
And he has encouraged us to think
about the future in the hopes
that this will be extended and
maybe developed in a permanent way
that might be endowed, but that
the first 5 years would be almost a
period of experimentation in trying
to embrace awareness of the problem
of literacy and by doing award
work but also by symposium
and by other means that are kind of
generic to this Center for the Book.
We also have affiliates
in every state.
So everyone of your states has a
partner with us to promote books,
reading, literacy, and
libraries in the state.
So, this is the second
symposium held by the literacy--
advisory of our literacy
program and we're so proud
to have Nemours as
a partner in this.
The first symposium was literacy and
poetry and we learned about a number
of organizations in poetry that
have common interest with us
and have been able to bring several
of them into our network of reading
and literacy promotion partners
and Laura Bailet from Nemours is
on our board and she was someone
who when we had our first
board meeting was talking
about what we're talking
about today.
How important literacy is to health
and in many ways, and this was news
to other members of the board,
and we immediately put this
on the agenda for a future symposium
and we're here today and I thank you
for your participation
and I will, I'm afraid,
tell you a little bit more about the
overall endeavor as we move ahead.
But now, I am going to move
ahead and follow our program.
We-- I would like to
introduce, however,
a special guest Dr. Louis
Sullivan who has joined us today.
He was unable to join us yesterday.
I met Dr. Sullivan for the
first time just a few weeks ago
when we had him as a
speaker about his new book
at the Library of Congress,
his memoir.
And he pointed out and I
stand up straight when he said
so that the Georgia
Center for the Book has--
was featuring his book on his
website as part of their program
of putting up on the website
books every Georgian should read.
And this is a rotating
list of course.
But nonetheless, it still is
headlined by Dr. Sullivan's memoir.
He was the secretary of health
and human services during the
administration of George H. W. Bush
and is the chairman of the boar
of the National Health
Museum in Atlanta and what?
He talked about a lot was
being the first president
of the More House School
of Medicine.
He also is the head of
the deep Washington,
DC based Sullivan Alliance
to transform America's
health professionals
and he's going to be
with us all day.
I'd like him just to stand
and be acknowledged please.
[ Applause ]
Last night, we had a wonderful
keynote address by Dr. David Bailey
and I know that a number of
you were not able to join us.
But we're very fortunate
that he is today going
to be the introducer
of the keynote today.
But I just wanted to thank him
publicly for getting us off
to such a good start because
his talk, no surprise,
really was a wonderful
keynote that focused on how
and why reading proficiency
and literacy are
such strong indicators of-- actually
of overall health through adulthood
and that is what we're trying
to bring together as we do
in these symposia are fields
and learn about other fields
from the perspective of literacy
to see how we not only
conform new alliances.
But perhaps look ahead together
for new ways of solving some
of the problems that
we were faced with.
And last night, Dr. Bailey
nicely lined up the alignments
of various worlds that we occupy
and literacy and in education
and in health and pointed to this
is an opportunity for us to think
about coming together in ways that
would affect policy and to try
to keep the broadest possible
perspective on this on behalf
of our society rather than what we
all tend to do and we're all guilty
of this is spending so much time
on our specialties and trying
to prove ourselves and
prove our organizations
that we often forget
the broader picture.
So this is an attempt to talk about
and learn about and do something
about the broader picture.
Dr. Bailey is the president
of Nemours Foundation,
which he became president in 2006.
He is leading light and we--
the whole world of health with many
honors and for those I know a few
of my friends are here
today who don't know
about Nemours is an integrated
children's health system
with two hospitals in the
Delaware Valley in Florida
and it serves children from
across the United States
and internationally.
Nemours also operates 45 primary,
specialty and urgent care clinics
in 4 states and is responsible
for the website Kids Health,
which we have all learned
about through Laura in our work
on the Literacy Advisory Board.
And I am very pleased to
present Dr. David Bailey
who is the distinguished
introducer of a--
our distinguished keynoter
for the morning.
David Bailey.
[ Applause ]
>> David Bailey: Well, good morning.
I am Dave Bailey.
And I would just like to add my
welcome to Dr. Cole's to this summit
on literacy, health,
and new perspectives.
You know, the Library of
Congress staff, Dr. Cole,
have been extraordinarily
kind and accommodating.
They arranged the great weather.
The only thing they forgot was
to get cherry blossoms blooming.
>> And the trains.
>> The train-- Yeah, the
trains are another thing.
Yeah, we're delighted
that you've all joined us
for this I think very important
symposium and the connections
between literacy and health.
In this morning, I really have the
distinct honor and personal pleasure
to introduce our first speaker,
keynote speaker, Dr. Sandra Hassink.
Dr. Hassink is a pediatrician's
pediatrician.
She is consummate physician
and she's what we know
as a triple threat.
A superb clinician, a esteemed
researcher, and admired educator.
And it's been my great fortune to
be able to associated with Sandy
over several years at
the Nemours Alfred I.
duPont Hospital for Children.
Dr. Hassink is the
Immediate Past President
of the American Academy
of Pediatrics.
An organization composed of 64,000
pediatricians and an organization
that has an aggressive child health
policy agenda both nationally
and internationally.
Sandy has testified for congress on
childhood obesity, food security,
and hunger focusing on supporting
the foundations of child health.
She has dedicated her entire
professional career to caring
and advocating for children
with obesity and is the director
of The American Academy
of Pediatrics Institutes
for Healthy Childhood Weight.
Under her direction, the institute
is focused on translating research
into practice for pediatric
health care providers,
families and children.
Dr. Hassink founded the
weight management clinic
at Nemours Alfred I.
duPont Hospital for
Children in 1988.
She has lectured widely on this
topic and has published many books.
Among them, "A Parent's
Guide to Childhood Obesity",
"Pediatric Obesity,
Prevention, Intervention
and Treatment Strategies for Primary
Care", and "The Clinical Guide
to Pediatric Weight Management".
And if all of this weren't
enough, Dr. Hassink has served
on the Institute of Medicines
committee on accelerating progress
on obesity prevention
and was an author
on the expert recommendations
for obesity.
And probably a reason she's been
able to get through all of this
and maintain such a calm exterior
and that she holds a master's
of science in pastoral
care and counseling.
Please help me welcome Dr. Hassink.
[ Applause ]
>> Sandra Hassink:
So David, thank you.
I wasn't sure exactly
who you were speaking
about for a moment, but
thank you very much.
So as Dr. Bailey said, I spent this
several years as president elect,
president, now past present
of the academy speaking wildly
around the country
and internationally,
and speaking about the
foundations of child's health.
And I love this quote by Louis
Pasteur that I think typifies how we
as pediatricians and how we really
feel all of us about children.
"When I approach a child he
inspires in me two sentiments;
tenderness for what he is, and
respect for what he may become."
And I think that holds
the hopes of all of us
that in the moment we can
respond to the needs of the child
in that very moment that we
all are encountering the child
and their family.
But we hold the hopes for
the future of that child.
And we know without a
doubt that what we do
in this moment is significant
for that moment but significant
for the child's future
and I hope to illustrate
that as we move through this talk.
So I always start my talks by
asking how are the children?
How are the children doing?
And you can look at this
through many lenses and I picked
out a few things to look at
just nationally how we're doing.
And you know this varies
widely state to state,
but our diet quality only 50%
of children are now meeting federal
standards, diet quality standards,
18% of our children have obesity,
30% nationally have overweight
and obesity, and 9% of our
children have activity limitations
from some other chronic condition.
When we look at emotional
and behavioral health,
we see the parents are reporting
significant serious emotional
and behavioral problems
in 5% of their children.
And our adolescence, 8% of them,
12 to 17 have had a major
depressive episode in the last year.
I think we need to just
pause a moment on that one.
10% of our children have asthma and
52% of our children, ages 3 to 4,
are not enrolled in
quality or any preschool.
And I think you'll see today how
literacy interweaves itself among
all these childhood problems.
And almost half of our children,
0 to 6, lived 200% are below
of the poverty level with
11% of our children living
under 50% for the poverty level.
So, when we think about the
foundations of child health,
I've been using a framework
from the Harvard center
for the developing child
because I want to be able
to have a conversation about
every child in this country
and what every child
in this country needs.
Because I think, as Dr.
Bailey, so rightly pointed
out that we often live
in our silos and live--
and look at the world through
the-- our own particular lenses.
And I think we need to broaden
this conversation and now think
about what every child needs.
Every child needs sound
and appropriate nutrition.
That means that if we combine food
and security, hunger, obesity,
and overweight, 50% of
our children are suffering
from a nutritional hardship.
Every child needs stable response
of nurturing relationships at home,
early childcare and education at
school and in their community.
And every child needs safe
supported physical, chemical,
and built environments and you'll
see how literacy weaves itself
through these foundation
elements of child health.
And so at this conversation
in this country right now,
should be about what
every child needs
and how we all together can
build those foundations.
So the academy of pediatrics
has it's strategic plan
and about 10 years ago we renamed
our strategic plan the Agenda
for Children.
And you'll see in this circle
some of our guiding principles,
Medical Home, Health Equity, our
own Profession of Pediatrics.
You'll see pillars, Access,
Quality, and Finance,
which really mean the
ability of children
to access health and health care.
But those elements in the middle
really are a pivot for us.
So 10 years ago, you might have seen
oral health, immunizations, tobacco,
very important child
health topics on this list.
But what you see now are
Epigenetics, Early Brain
and Child Development,
Poverty and Child Health.
And we just released our
poverty statement this month.
We are now looking carefully
at the foundational elements
that build health for children.
And I think it's a very important
pivot for us to have taken.
And it's out of our anxiety
that children are not receiving
these foundational elements
that build good health.
So our agenda now speaks to the
socioecologic framework of children
because you build health
everywhere for children.
You build it in the
home with your families.
You build it in the community.
You build it with infrastructure.
You build it with literacy.
You build it all together
for children.
And so you can see the
socioecological model,
just some elements that are
important to child health
and they really run the
gamut from school nutrition
which I've been speaking
about extensively this year
to injury prevention, taking
care of the mother infant dyad,
taking care of the
intrauterine environment.
You can see them there and
how it calls us to work
in a cross-sectoral fashion.
So, why are we speaking today
about health and literacy?
Well, we know as physicians
low health literacy--
low literacy is associated
with low health literacy.
And so, more than 90
million US adults at least
in 2003 lack the literacy needed
to effectively negotiate
the health care system.
So those of you who have high
literacy, know how difficult it is
to negotiate the health care system.
It can be sort of a laboring
thing process of paper work
and phone calls and appointments.
And if you have basic or only basic
literacy, you are significantly
at risk for not being able to
get the healthcare you need.
And you can see that if you look
at below basic and basic literacy,
basic literacy is searching a short
simple text to find out what you
as a patient might be allowed
to drink before a medical test,
signing a form, adding the
amounts on the bank deposit slip,
finding a pamphlet for jurors,
using a TV guide to find out what's
on the program, comparing
ticket prices.
So if you don't have these
skills above basic skills,
you simply can't negotiate
the health care system
with any efficacy.
And then we write a lot of things
in the health care
profession for patients.
We write a lot of patient education.
But you can see here the percentage
of the population of each state
that has below a 5th grade level of
literacy, the darkest red is the 30%
or greater, the orange is 20%
to 30, 15 to 20 in the green,
and 10 to 15 in the blue.
And you know that many patients
can't literally read the information
that we're putting out.
So I was in one of our clinics in
North Wilmington and we were handing
out an obesity paper that's
said 520, fruits and vegetables,
exercise, juice, and TV
had very simple information
and what was happening is we
were finding those pamphlets
in the trash can in
the waiting room.
People simply couldn't process that.
And we had tried to be very
careful about the language we used.
So we decided then we have to
model the behavior we wanted,
but this is a huge handicap
for our adults and our adults
or the parents of our
young children.
So low literacy and related
low health literacy and parents
of young children increases
developmental risk
because they can't access what
they need to support their children
and something very mundane
in the health care system
but incredibly important.
They can't negotiate medication
dosing or adhering to routines
or goals or-- are preop
preparation or goal setting
around the chronic illness.
They can't adhere to that
because they don't have
the health literacy skills.
And then the perpetuation of this
really perpetuates the cycles
of poverty, poor health and
dependency across the life course.
So it's really important for us.
Adults with limited health literacy,
and you'll hear this probably over
and over today, have
diminished diseased knowledge.
They don't use preventive
services at the same rates.
They have increased
hospitalizations,
poor health status, poor
control of chronic illness,
and you know we have an epidemic
of chronic illness in this country.
Globally, we would call this
noncommunicable disease,
lifestyle-related diseases,
and the ability
to control chronic illness
is crucial to your ability
to prevent early death
and severe morbidity and,
of course, and mortality.
So reading a routine for a
person with type 2 diabetes
and managing insulin dosing is
actually quite a complex set
of interactions that have to
occur and can occur in adults
with limited health literacy.
So in 2014, we put out a statement
at the academy on literacy promotion
and just highlight some of
the things that you all know
that greater than 1 and 3 US
children start kindergarten
without the language skills
needed to learn to read.
Reading proficiency by third grade
is the most important predictor
of high school and career success.
And 2/3 of children each year,
80% of whom live in poverty fail
to develop reading proficiency
by the end of third grade.
Saw a father in my
office and he was--
actually was a grandfather
raising his grandson
and his grandson wasn't
learning to read in school
and he had begged the school to hold
him back so he could learn to read.
But the school had-- your own
promotion criteria and were set
on promoting the young man.
So I have the situation of a
grandfather pleading with the school
and pleading essentially
with me for some help
in helping his grandson
learn to read because he knew
if he got farther into school
without learning to read
that was a sentence for him and it
was a sentence about not being able
to complete high school, not
being able to get a good job,
not being able to execute on the
dreams the grandfather had for him.
So, we talked about early
childcare and education.
This is the early learning
unmet need in our country.
And you see the maps, the light pink
here is a 0 to 25%, the dark is 76
to 100% and it's a map that looks
a little different than some maps.
So, when we look at these
maps of the United States,
the health disparities and the
disparities in accessing solutions
to health problems
often look the same.
This looks a little different
but we had a lot of 4-year-olds
that don't have about
preschool education.
And this is sort of
an interesting map
about the change in
preschool enrollment.
So some preschool enrollments
have gone down in the orange,
some have gone up in the dark blue.
We don't have a uniform
approach to this.
So merely by being born in
your county, in your town,
in your state really sets your
health trajectory for the rest
of your life because these
disparities are reproduced
on every health measure
that we can find.
So no one state is doing
perfectly on everything but I think
that that leads to our
saying that the zip code it--
maybe your most important health
indicator as a young child.
So, where does literacy start?
Well, we look at young children.
This is a slide courtesy of Pam
High from presentation to us
at our national meeting that
language environment of children
at home is highly variable
and really tracks
with socioeconomic status often.
So the vocabulary at age 3
and the parent words per hour,
you can see how that track.
So the ability to be in
a high word environment
or not will set your word
gap by kindergarten entry.
So, there have been studies
that show the kind of talk
that happens in families.
So some families talk a
lot to their children,
some families talk very little.
Business talk gets things done.
Brush your teeth.
Sit at the table.
Finish your vegetables.
Don't say I said that.
But nonbusiness talk is sort
of that chitchat, the mother
or father leaning over the child
and just having a conversation,
talking about what's
in their environment,
talking about a book for instance.
Business talk was constant
across families
but it was this nonbusiness talk,
this sort of relational talk
that really made the
difference and you'll see here.
So the talk of the families had
more praise than prohibitions.
The more silent families
more prohibitions than praise
because if you're doing a lot
of task-oriented talk,
that's what happens.
At 3 years, the IQ correlated
with nonbusiness talk.
And at third grade,
the receptive language.
So even very, very early on and
this is what makes early reading
and early relational attention
to those early relationship is
so important for our young children
because long before they can
read your laying the groundwork
for literacy and reading.
So talkativeness predicted
IQ and vocabulary.
I want to talk a little bit
about literacy and poverty
because as I told you,
half of our child--
almost half of our children live
200% or below the poverty level.
Children from low income
family have fewer words
in early childhood know
fewer word by 3 years,
have fewer literacy
resources which--
within their home and you'll hear
a lot more about that less likely
to be read regularly and more likely
to experience early childhood
adversity and toxic stress
and we'll talk about that.
And these are our poverty
rates in these countries.
So this is the dark red are
the 20 to 30 Percent of poverty
and you can see courtesy of the
2008 recession what has happened
to child poverty in this country.
And so children are sort of
the first affected and the last
to be lifted out of poverty.
So I want to talk a
little bit now about some
of the science that's emerging about
what happens in early childhood
and the impact for later
health trajectories.
And many of you are familiar
with Vince Felitti study
on Adverse Childhood Experiences.
And Dr. Felitti was a physician
at Kaiser Permanente and study
over 17,000 adults and many
of whom had chronic
illnesses including obesity
and he merely asked them what
happened to you as a child?
So he asked them about abuse,
emotional, physical and sexual,
household dysfunction,
mother treated violently,
household mental illness, divorce,
incarcerated household member,
and later about emotional
and physical neglect.
And in this study, these were
the percentages of adults
who reported having experienced one
of these adverse events
in their childhood.
And I would say if
you'd look at this,
you would say this is pretty high.
Physical abuse, 29%.
Mother treated violently, 27%.
This is pretty and is
disturbing in and of itself.
But what happened when he looked
at their current health status,
he realized that the
current health status
of these adults had
a graded relationship
to the adverse experiences
they experienced in childhood.
So if you experience more of these
adverse events, you're more likely
to have chronic heart disease,
cancer, chronic lung disease,
skeletal fractures,
and liver disease.
If you experience more
adverse childhood events,
you would have more risk factors
for chronic disease, smoking,
alcoholism, promiscuity,
obesity, substance abuse.
These ACEs, this Adverse Childhood
Experiences were associated
with general health and social
functioning, poor general health
and social functioning, poor
mental health, depression,
sleep disturbance, anxiety,
poor anger control, and
memory disturbances.
So this takes us right
back to where we started
which was what's happening to the
child as a child immediately is
so important and needs
to be attended to.
But what happens to that child
imbeds itself in our biology
and has lifelong health effects.
So this was a study of a
maternal report of ACEs
at a 5-year followup study and
these were fragile families at risk.
It was a fragile family
and child well-being study.
And these were mothers of children
age 5 reporting maltreatment
in their families.
Physical, sexual, psychological
abuse and neglect and I think
that you can look at this numbers
and say that's really disturbing.
How many of these children
had experienced this ACEs
household dysfunction?
And then, the children
that had no ACEs were 45%.
But over half the children
in this study had one
or more adverse childhood
experiences, 27%, 1; 2,
adverse childhood experiences
16%; 3, 8%; 4, 3%; and 5 ACEs 1%.
And so they connected these
adverse childhood experiences
to their experiences with literacy.
So children who had not yet
or not began to understand
and interpret a story or other
text that was read to them,
if you had one adverse experience,
you had a slightly higher odds ratio
of not being able to
understand and interpret a story.
If you had 3 or more, you
had an odds ratio or 2.2.
Not yet or beginning to easily
and quickly name all upper
and lower case letters.
You can see that the trajectory,
the trend for more ACEs
less ability to do that.
Not yet or beginning to read simple
books, you can see the trend.
Not yet or beginning to
demonstrate understanding of some
of the conventions of print.
So, we know that literacy is
interwoven here with the experiences
of childhood that can
either promote literacy,
prevent literacy, interfere
with literacy.
And we know that this is also
affecting children's brains.
So the first years of life
hold the most critical periods
for brain development.
This is the classic slide that
shows the synapses you have at birth
and then you develop a lot of them
at 6 and then they're pruned by 14.
And the pruning is
really the refinement
of the circuitry of the brain.
So-- And that refinement
is experience-based.
It doesn't happen the
same for every person.
Based on your experiences,
your brain is altering
your synaptic connection
and literally its anomaly.
So, the regions of the
brain that are most affected
by these toxic stress and adverse
childhood experiences are the
hippocampus, learning, memory,
discrimination of danger and safety.
The prefrontal cortex,
impulse control.
The amygdala, increase
in impulsive behavior
and that mediates fear and anxiety.
So these toxic experiences are
shaping the children's brain
development, shaping their exposure
to protect the factors like literacy
and the context from which the
child comes is so important.
So part of what we're asking
pediatricians now and all of us is
to not just deal with that
immediacy of what the situation is
when the child walks
into your clinic,
but ask what's happening
to that child?
What's the context of the child?
What's the state of family?
What's the state of
their experiences?
And we're trying to
build resilience.
And so the flip-side of this
is how do we build resilience
in our children and
you'll hear later
on this conference how
literacy is a promotion
in children is a powerful
skill, tool,
and pathway to build
resilience in children.
It's powerful.
It's something every parent can do.
And it involves building
relational support for the children.
It actually I think and maybe
Bob-- we don't know this, Bob.
But it forces-- I think it
reduces stress in the adult
to have these quiet
moments with children.
So I used to literally
prescribe time to my parents.
So I was in clinic.
We were trying to do a hard thing.
We were trying to really
shift lifestyles
to promote a healthy weight.
And any of you who've tried
do that that is very hard.
So I literally would prescribe 15
to 20 minutes a day for the parent
and they were not allowed
to do tasks
like you couldn't be 15 minutes
on the homework or 15 minutes on,
you know, what you're
going to wear tomorrow,
it had to be this engagement time.
You could read.
You can paint each
other's fingernails.
You could hair and the
children were delighted
and the parents were
often astounded.
First that I would ask
that they spend this time
and they started ask, well,
how can I get that 15 minutes?
And we figured that out and
then when they would come back,
they were astounded because
what happened with that time was
that they remembered the
joy of being a parent.
They remembered how fun
it was to engage to child.
The children of course
were delighted
because it was never a child
I never met that didn't want
to spend more time
with their parent.
And then-- So, I think that
this building resilience is not
rocket science.
But it often feels like
rocket science to families
when they're trying to carve
out this time, time to read,
time to be with their children from
very busy, highly stressful life
and you add on those ACEs that
not only are occurring now
but the parents experience,
you can see that this is--
that we need to be absolutely
supportive of our families here.
Increase sensitivity to the child's
needs and that relational time
that time with the child
increases that sensitivity.
And then when we spend the time to
address the problem in its immediacy
that the parents are having
so we can become solution
oriented for the parents.
So this is a handout that
I would often give parents.
And again, not rocket science
but often hard to imagine doing
when you're in a highly
stressful situation.
Share your feelings, play,
set consistent expectations,
protect the child from adult
concerns, encourage small goals,
try something new, keep
healthy, try something relaxing,
things we would all
sort of endorse and sort
of basic foundational elements
are often hard for parents
to do unless they're supported.
So our literacy promotion
recommendation
for pediatricians were
to promote literacy
at health supervision visits.
Really inform parents,
advice parents
that reading it loud can
enrich the relationships.
Counseling about what are
developmentally appropriate literacy
activities and provide books and
you'll hear more about that as well.
We also said make your
office literacy friendly.
Use posters and inform parents
about the importance of literacy.
Partner with advocates like we're
doing today to promote literacy.
Incorporate literacy in
our training programs.
Sports-- Support funding for
children's books and research.
So we call out our profession
to really do a 360-degree
support of literacy.
And we have some tools.
So we have bright futures that
has literacy and woven into it.
And also the ability
now the new addition
to detect these adverse childhood
experiences and build resiliency.
Promote Reach Out and Read,
which you'll hear about.
And many, many pediatricians
are doing this in their offices
and address these toxic experiences
that prevent the building
of resiliency, the building
of literacy in our families.
And this is just an interesting map
of the book deserts
in the United States.
And so you'll see that the
orange is percent of homes
with more than 100 books.
And 100 books is a lot.
For some of us, I don't think
100 books is a lot in my house
but it is a lot and
you'll see that they're--
very map reproduces itself, overlays
many of our maps of chronic illness
and health disparities
in this country.
So we have on our website
literacy building tools,
books building connection toolkit.
This is for professionals and
families and just to highlight that.
And then we talk about and
help pediatricians understand
and parents why books, what
a child can do with a book,
how parents can enjoy the
book, and when to share,
and how to weave literacy
into your house.
And so supporting evidence for
professionals because our docs
like to know why they're
doing it and then what--
ask about and what to do.
And then promoting the five
Rs; reading, rhyming, routines,
rewards, and relationships.
And you can see how integral
literacy and literacy promotion is
into building these really
foundational elements
of family relationships.
So, all families need to understand
and hear the important message
that literacy is important.
So-- And we said that in our policy.
But I was taking the red-eye to
Chicago and I jumped into a cab
and the driver and I were
chatting and he learned
that I was a pediatrician
and many of you
who are pediatricians
know this happens,
people find out you're
pediatrician and they really want
to tell you about their children.
And so he began telling me
about a 6-month old daughter
and he's working two jobs and he's
not at home with her very often
and he wanted to give her
the best possible life.
But he said, "I am working
to give her a better life
but I don't have a lot of time,"
and he was really lamenting that.
And he asked me, "What I should do?"
And I said, "Well, read to her."
And he looked puzzled.
And he said, "But she's
only 6 months old
like what are you crazy,
read to her?"
And I told him how
reading builds brains,
vocabularies changes behaviors,
sets up children for success.
And we wound up discussing early
child development, literacy
and learning, and the
cab ride from O'Hare
to our headquarters
at Elk Grove Village.
And he was amazed.
And he was grateful.
And he was grateful that he
could do something for her even
in the little time he had.
And we arrived at the hotel.
He couldn't stop thanking
me and shaking my hand.
He said, "I will read to her."
And he said, "There's
something I can do to help her
and help her have a better
future and I will do it."
So, I think we can underestimate the
importance of this for our children,
the importance of this for our
parents, the importance of this
for our families, and the importance
of this for building the foundations
of child health in our country.
So, thank you very much.
And I'm pleased to be here.
[ Applause ]
>> John Cole: Well, thank you very
much for that wonderful beginning,
followup to what we've
started last night.
I'm pleased that we can approach
this subject from so many points
of view and there are many
points of view to come.
I want to say just a word about
today's schedule and logistics.
We-- Last night, those of you who
are not able to join us, I'm sorry,
did not have a chance
to see the Library
of Congress' historic building,
the Jefferson Building
which opened in 1897.
Instead we're-- in
our newest building,
which opened in 1980,
the Madison building.
We're proud that all three of
our buildings across the street,
the second building,
we're not visiting
at all is called the Adams Building.
But we were created in 1800.
It was the first federal culture
institution and our three buildings
on this campus are named
for book loving presidents.
And Jefferson had a special role
in founding the Library of Congress
by selling at his-- at
cost really his library,
his comprehensive library to the
fledgling Library of Congress
in the Capitol after the
British had burned it in 1814.
And from the comprehensiveness
of his collection came the
comprehensiveness of the approach
of the Library of Congress which
meant we collect in all subjects
and we try to share resources.
We are in effect the
National Library even though
because we're legislative
branch and have congress
as our most important client,
we don't have the official
name National Library.
But that gives us feeling
that we can reach
out through educational
outreach and other activities
that cover many different
subjects and are national place
to bring together groups that
normally would not come together
and it's in that spirit in which
the Center for the Book was formed
and also in which we
are needing today.
Now down to the nitty-greedy.
The restrooms are just outside.
There is a lunch for the speakers
and their guests next door.
But members of the
public who will be coming
and going all day our
cafeteria is just a step away.
So it's close by.
All of our talks are in this room.
Is that-- That's right.
We are featuring panel
discussions that have been organized
with experts on the various
aspects and approaches to our topic.
We also will have a couple of
specialized sessions of one
with our Robie Harris
who will speak about--
an author who will speak about her
perspective, is a wonderful author
of books on our subjects.
The second one is something
we talked about and are going
to have a short presentation and the
general idea was the role of health
in a crisis in kind of a policy
crisis or a different kind
of national crisis and we are going
to have a short presentation
1:10 today by a specialist
from the World Bank about Ebola,
literacy in the Ebola crisis to try
to bring us up to date
on another way of looking
at what we're talking about.
And in our keynote this morning,
it's interesting, you know,
that we really are talking not
only about research for specialist
but in fact real life for cab
drivers and for providing advice.
And that was another point
that came out last night is
that first confrontation with an
adult about a very young child
and what time are you
spending together.
And Dr. Bailey made the point at
least to me in another conversation
that sometimes he knows immediately
or maybe with someone else last
that if there's no reaction at all,
you know there's work to be done.
And when someone thinks
about their youngest child
and that's an opening,
I think, for all of us.
Our second-- Let me see if I-- Now
when we-- We'll have a chance with--
We'll have a chance for
conversation depending on--
and I'm not going to
quiet anyone now.
We have the time to speak.
But at the very end of the
day, we'll see how it works
and we have some free time for
conversation and questions.
But I will encourage the chairs
to use that time now to the best
of their judgment whether you
want to take questions or not.
And we also will not spend
much time on biographies
because biographies are
in your handout along
with some general information
about our program about the Center
for the Book, but also about
the literacy awards program.
And you'll see those handsome--
we've now had three years of
literacy awards and I urge you
to take a look at the handouts
because we have developed a plan
that goes beyond the cash
awards which Reach Out and Read,
I should note was the first
winner of the Rubenstein award.
So maybe this is prophetic
that we are all coming together
with this particular focus.
It shows how we really are,
I believe, beginning to learn
from what we're doing and using
the literacy awards connections
with organizations as a way
for us and you if you're here
to see what how big
this world really is.
But we developed something
called best practices obviously.
And we-- it goes beyond
the three large cash awards
and these are recognitions
from the Library of Congress.
So far, it's just with
the certificate.
But we're hoping that as our program
evolves we can do more in helping
out some of the smaller
organizations
that are getting best
practices awards.
And beginning with our second year,
we really expanded, figured out what
to do with best practices.
And each time we've given
between 12 and 15 organizations
from around the world best practices
acknowledgments and been able
to bring them here to the library
to talk about their programs
and we are filming our
programming in the process,
developing our website which
one of this days when we crash--
not crash, went-- wrong verb--
when we penetrate the Library of
Congress' web services to the point
that we can move our
results up a little faster.
We'll be showing you some of our--
the website films from some winners.
And for us, it's a great
stimulation to have people
from other countries come and
just have their 10 or 15 minutes
of recognition and we film it and
we also have a page for each of them
in our last two annual books which
they can use to promote themselves.
So, this is an ongoing process
and you are now part of it
and we will move to our first panel.
The panel is Child and Adolescent
Health and Literacy Issues.
and the panel consist of Libby
Dogget who will be the chair.
Laura who is part of it.
Lindsay Carter and Dr. Needleman.
And I would like them to come up
and I will introduce Libby
a little bit but not much.
Come on up.
Everybody come up.
Libby will have the panel
members say a little bit
about their own backgrounds.
But Libby herself is with
the Department of Education.
She's an assistant-- Deputy
Assistant Secretary for Policy
and Early Learning in the Office of
Elementary and Secondary Education.
And we are all meeting-- some
of us are meeting each
other for the first time.
>> Libby Dogget: That's
right, we are.
>> Trying to figure
out who's sitting--
>> Libby Dogget: We actually met on
the phone because we are prepared.
So I think what we'll
do is I'm going
to introduce the panel a
little bit or the frame
of the panel although
Sandy did an incredible job
of really introducing
the whole topic
and it was just a beautiful
presentation.
So, thank you for your presentation.
But more importantly, thank you
for what the American Academy
of Pediatrics is doing
in this country.
They are making a difference.
[ Applause ]
>> Laura is going to help
with timekeeping for you.
>> Libby Dogget: OK.
So, one of our panelists
couldn't come but we promised
that we would make
sure that her message
on diversity in books
would be heard.
So, Ellen Oh was not
able to join us today.
I regret that because she would
have been incredible person.
She is an author as well as the CEO
of a group called We
Need Diverse Books.
And we do need more diverse book.
So, we will try to work her
message into what we're saying.
I'm delighted to be here.
It's such an honor.
I think the Library of Congress
is the most beautiful place
in the entire world and
the idea that we have
so many books available here
and electronically now and then
in libraries all across this
country is just pretty incredible.
We have a program at the
Department of Education called "Race
to the Top: Early Learning
Challenge."
And we have spent a billion
dollars funding 20 states.
And one of the states, Maryland,
has worked really diligently
to get families engaged in
their children's education
and to just establish
stronger partnerships.
And one of the things
they've done is
to actually introduce
families to the library.
And I think we all take
libraries for granted.
When I was a little
girl, my family--
my mother took us to
library every week
and beside her bed was always
a stock of books this high
and I don't know how she got
through them with four kids.
But she somehow at least
got through a lot of them
because she was always reading and
reading to us and so we all got used
to bringing home a stack of books.
But in Maryland, some
of the newer families,
the new immigrant families didn't
know that the library was free.
They hadn't used the library
because that they thought
that that incredible
resource was something
for others, people who could pay.
And so they had event
at the library,
made sure the families got a library
card and taught them how to use it
and I thought that
was such a great way
to make a difference
in families' lives.
I remember very well when the
first time I learn to read,
I grew up in a family that I
had no excuse for not reading.
Family that did very well.
I was raised to Marywell,
which a little--
fortunately, I did but I did
more than that hopefully.
But I didn't know how to read when
I get to first grade and I've gone
to kindergarten, I've
gone to preschool
at the church, Norton's Preschool.
But I had no idea how to
read and I remember sitting
in the reading group, have this
vision so clearly in my mind
and the teacher put a book, a little
book in front about eight of us
and asked if anybody
knew what TIP meant.
And there was of course a
beautiful cute picture of a dog
and my friend Mark Blumenthal who
is still a friend said, "Tip."
And I just looked at him like
he was the smartest person
in the world because I had no idea.
No one had ever taken
the time to teach me
to decode the letter and the sounds.
And I was in first grade and,
of course, once I've learned,
it was very easy but
it was so interesting
because learning to
read is not easy.
And some kids just
automatically get it.
But most children do not
and it is very difficult.
So we're going to have a change with
Laura to go into depth about that.
And then we've already heard about
how important it is to have books
and that that reading and the
relationship that develops
between the parents and the child
sitting close, talking about things,
slowing down is so
very, very important.
We know to do that.
We still aren't doing it.
It's just amazing to have--
we have Reach Out and Read.
We have RIF still.
We have all kinds of ways
to get children books.
But we're not doing a very good job
of getting those books
into the home yet.
But we have one great way to do it
and I'm glad to see it's expanding.
So Robert will tell us about that.
And then, I think it's interesting
that other countries are
using our great research
and are doing all kinds
of wonderful thing.
And so we're very fortunate to
have Lindsay from the Department
of Agriculture to help
us frame this not just
in the United States but globally.
And so she'll talk a little bit
about what we're doing
here and abroad.
Before I turn it over
to my incredible panel,
I want to just give you a little bit
of background about what's happened
in the last seven years in
early childhood education,
because that's what I do.
We have been fortunate
to have a president
who really did focus on this.
I can remember sitting
around the table in Austin,
Texas where I actually live
with some of my friends thinking
"Who can we get to champion
early childhood education?"
We didn't-- You know, there
was no city council person,
certainly not the mayor.
There was no member of
house or senate in Texas.
There was certainly no one
in congress, no senator.
We wouldn't have thought of the
president championing in this.
We did find a business
leader or the wife
of business leader Ronya
Kozmetsky whose husband was present
at the Business School
of University of Texas.
She was incredible advocate for us.
And we wouldn't have dreamed
of where we would be now.
I was sitting just across the way
at the Capitol a few years ago
watching the state of the union.
And I had been told that there was
going to be a special announcement
about early childhood education.
Little did I dream that
the president would set
such an incredible goal.
But we have the goal
of providing pre-K
for every 4-year-old
in this country.
We're not there yet.
But we keep-- the president keeps
coming back with it year after year.
We know that's not a silver bullet.
But we know that's doable
because Oklahoma is doing it,
because West Virginia is doing it.
Georgia, Vermont now is offering
pre-K for every 3 and 4-year-old.
So we know how to do this.
States are getting in line.
It's not a silver bullet.
We need to do pre-K
for 3 and 4-year olds.
We need to improve the whole
childcare system and make it
into an early learning
system where every setting
for children is a learning setting
and that's going to
take a lot of money.
But there is a proposal on the
table also to improve the quality
of childcare across our country.
And then, there's a wonderful
piece of the president's agenda
which talks to parents because
we know that every parent wants
to do the best possible
job for their children.
You never talk to a
parent who hasn't said,
"I want to do a better job."
I thought your story about the
taxi cab driver was so wonderful
because we all hear that
and every parent wants that.
They just don't know how.
And even our middle-income families
and upper-income families
are stressed now
because mothers are working
and fathers are working
and their lives are
so very complicated.
I have two young daughters
and I just marveled
at how they carve out
time for everything.
So, with the president's agenda,
we have money set or asked--
we're asking for a great increase
in the home visiting money.
It is come down through this
president where it's exciting
because we have home visiting now
which is really parent
coaching in every single state.
But we know it's only
reaching a small portion
of the families that need it.
It's all voluntary.
But you know what, every family's
asked, "Would you like some help?
Would you like coach or a mentor?"
They all-- Nearly always say yes.
So there is an agenda on the table.
We have people at the highest
levels now talking about it.
We had more recently in the
New York, really a competition
between the governor and the mayor
of New York City about who is going
to pay for the pre-K program.
We need more arguments
like that to raise this up.
I do think the American Academy
of Pediatric is really made--
been a great advocate for this.
Because it's not people
like me who are advocate
but it's really the business
leaders, the doctors, the--
actually, the flag officers,
generals, and the naval officers
who have come in and
have really made the case
that we need this not just for
the kids and for the parents.
We need this for our country and
for the future of our workforce.
So, it's been a great ride.
I hope we can continue the
momentum because there's--
we've just barely started.
The growth is way too small.
It's way too late.
These first five years
disappear like that.
For us, five years is nothing.
But five years, children are
already in kindergarten and then
in first grade and we've missed
an incredible opportunity.
So now, we're going to go in depth.
And we're going to
start off with Laura.
I mean with-- I'm sorry--
with Robert.
And he's going to tell us about
a great Reach Out and Read
which Sandy mentioned and
he'll tell us more about it.
And they're limited to three or
four minutes and they're going
to introduce the topic and
then we're going to just kind
of have a conversation among us but
we are reserving 20 minutes for you
to have a conversation with us.
So, write down your questions,
be thinking about this
because we really do want
to engage the audience.
And we have incredible experts here.
So, Robert.
>> Robert Needleman:
Thank you very much.
It's wonderful to be here seeing
old friends making new friends,
realizing that our vision is
shared and it's very powerful.
Now, I-- my heart is thinking
though, Sandy while you were talking
because I'm thinking she's saying
everything I was going to say.
And my only consolation
is as a pediatrician,
I know that learning is closely
connected with repetition.
So, this will give you an
opportunity to master some
of this material a little bit more.
And I have written my comments down
because I didn't want to go over.
I could easily talk
for the hour myself.
But this is to keep me in line.
So, Reach Out and Read is an
approach to pediatric primary care
that puts the connection
between health
and literacy, front and center.
We do this in several ways.
First, we create literacy-rich
waiting rooms.
In the best situation,
we have volunteers
who are reading with the children.
And more importantly, demonstrating
to the parents two things,
one that it's easy and two
that their children love it.
In the situation in which
Reach Out and Read developed
which was a large clinic serving a
low-income urban population Boston
City Hospital now Boston
Medical Center.
Parents regrettably would often
wait for an hour for their visits.
So instead of that hour being filled
with the kind of control speech
that you talked about,
it was an hour now filled
with observing their children
responding to books and somebody
who could present them
in a happy way.
And we discovered a form of
waiting room contagion which was
that as parents were watching one
person interacting with children
about books, other
kids would come along
and then the parents would hang
in the back would start picking
up the books and looking at
them with their children.
So pretty soon we created a milieu
in which literacy fused
the waiting room.
And we also noticed
that things got quieter
because the kids weren't
running around
and the parents weren't
yelling at them.
They were engaged.
We have a new developmentally and
culturally appropriate picture book
at every visit to the pediatrician,
every Well-Child visits
starting at six months of age.
That's important for
a lot of reasons; one,
is because the books cost money
and so we have to raise money.
Two, the more importantly, it's
not about giving books to families.
It's not about getting
books into the home.
There are many more efficient
ways to get books into home
than having a pediatrician
hand them about.
It's about having the book
in the clinic to use together
with the parent and the child.
And I'll say a little
bit more about that.
And specifically the most
important thing I think
that we do is we provide
individualized one-on-one guidance
to a parent with a child
about how that child
and parent are together using
literacy to creat connections,
to enrich their language,
and to establish an optimistic
outlook for the child.
So a great pediatrician told me
something at the very begging
of Reach Out and Read he said,
"You know, when I bring the book
into the room, we have
conversations with the parents
that we never had before.
And the conversation is about my
child growing up to be a learner."
And that was sort of a
world-changing perspective for us is
that we were tapping into a very,
very powerful strong current
within the parents of optimism
and hope and also fear.
Parents would not had good
experiences themselves
in the educational world,
those were our patients,
could see as your cab driver could
see there is something I can do
tremendously powerful.
Reach Out and Read reaches 4.4
million mainly low-income children.
It's about 25% of the low-income
children in the country.
That's awful.
I mean, it's wonderful, right, 25%.
It's awful.
What about the other
75% who receive care
at some 5500 clinics
around the country?
And we have affiliated programs now
in many other parts of the world.
Italy and Germany are
on board and some places
where books are being
used specifically
to help the most stressed
kids like the Philippines
where we've been involved
with kids who are affected
by the storms there and Haiti.
We embrace a wholistic view of
health which includes physical,
social, and emotional well-being.
And I won't go into more of that
because it's been talked about.
And importantly physicians,
pediatricians,
family doctors have a special
opportunity because of our contact
with parent at 10 regularly
scheduled Well-Child visits
because they're in the
room with us one-on-one
and because parents we know come to
us not only for advice about health
but also for advice about
their children's development
and what they can do.
Reach Out and Read rests on
a strong base of evidence.
We have 14 and now maybe
15 studies published
in the peer-reviewed literature
that demonstrates some
very important outcomes.
Most importantly parental
attitudes towards reading aloud,
including the judgment when
you asked parents in a sly way
that doesn't sort of
prejudice their answers.
The judgment that reading aloud
is one of the favorite things
that parents do with their child,
so a source of joy together.
And correspondingly
increases in the frequency
with which parents read aloud and
in the number of books in the home.
And then most importantly,
we've been able to document
through several studies,
five at last count,
improvements in children's
language development,
specifically vocabulary.
And that's because vocabulary
is both a direct result
of reading aloud that we know
that as parents read aloud
children's vocabulary increases the
number of words that
they're exposed to increases.
And it's also a very robust
predictor of later school success.
So that when we can show
experimentally that institution
of a Reach Out and Read program
increases children's vocabulary,
which has been shown, then we know
that we're setting those
children up for later success.
A new evidence, including a
marvelous report published
in pediatrics awhile
ago increasingly shows
that literacy acquisition,
listening to stories,
engaging with literature changes
the structure of the human brain,
specifically the parts of the brain
that are engaged in
listening to stories.
So when we talk about literacy
in health, we're really talking
about the health of a very
important organ, the brain.
And now increasingly
we're able to see
through technology how
literacy changes the brain.
No mystery there.
But it's quite clear that a healthy
brain is important if you're going
to become a literate and
successful member of society.
So, our intervention is specifically
health-related in the sense
that we have a target organ,
the brain, that we're changing.
And also, as you mention, Sandy,
very importantly, shared enjoyment
of stories strengthens
attachment and emotional health.
And I believe builds resilience.
So, recognizing this into a
connection between literacy
and health, Reach Out
and Read is an answer
to one very specific question.
What can doctors do?
What can doctors do concretely
everyday in their offices?
There are many things we can do.
We can advocate.
We can educate.
But what can we do everyday
in our office day in and day
out to move children towards greater
literacy and thereby greater health?
I just want to end-- I
probably talked long--
saying one thing about the name
Reach Out and Read, all right.
I would say it in this context.
It's a little in-joke for me.
The name was thought off by my
wife, who is a surgical pathologist.
And is she sees children
in her professional life,
that's little, tiny
pieces of children.
And she thought off the name
because we wanted a cool acronym
so it was R-O-A-R,
Reach Out and Read.
That only lasted until the
mayor of Boston informed us
that R-O-A-R also stood for
Restore Our Alienated Rights,
which is anti-Boston group in south.
So we became the first maybe only
literacy organization that's spells
its name wrong.
But it also turned out to
be prophetic in the sense
that we're learning that
reaching out is not only reaching
out to parents and connecting
with their aspirations
for their children, but
that this enterprise
for pediatricians requires us to
reach out to other professionals
who have other expertise
to business people,
to educators, to policy people.
The program really only works
when we cross boundaries.
Pediatricians cannot
and do not do it alone.
And giving pediatricians,
family doctors a tool
that they can use everyday
also encourages them
to look beyond the walls of
their clinic, because they need
to make common cause with
others in the community.
So in that sense, we're reaching
out as well and that's the reason
that I'm especially
delighted to be here
to have this discussion with you.
>> Libby Dogget: Thank you so much.
You know, we wouldn't have Reach Out
and Read if it weren't for Robert,
because he's one of the cofounder.
So, the fact that your wife
got the name, obviously,
tells us how imminently you were
involved in the beginning of that.
I think he's given us a challenge.
Only 75% of the kids don't have
this and we know how to do this.
This is doable.
I think the other challenge
that we all have is getting time
for pediatricians to do this.
Because I know I have a
son-in-law who's a pediatrician
and he is challenged and
my daughter did family--
it has family practice and,
you know, that challenge
of having the time to do it.
They both do it but
it's very difficult, so.
Thank you.
So, Laura is next and she's going
to take a little bit different tack
and talk a little bit
more about literacy
but you'll see how it
all comes together.
>> Laura Bailet: Good morning.
I'm Laura Bailet and I direct
the Nemours BrightStart program.
Nemours is an integrated
children's health system
and Nemours is recognized
reading failure
as a major child health
issue several years ago.
Given a really significant
health educational
and truly life consequences of poor
reading ability, Nemours identified
that it couldn't just sit on
the sidelines of this issue.
And this has been so
reinforced to me just
in the last 12 hours listening
to Dr. Bailey's wonderful
talk last night
and then Dr. Hassink this morning.
And these are two of our
physician leaders at Nemours.
Dr. Bailey is our President and CEO.
And their pediatricians and to hear
them talk about literacy issues
with such in-depth knowledge
and emphasizing all the ways
and how much that's important
for pediatric health care is
just stunning to me still.
And it just reminds me what an
honor and privilege it is to work
at an organization like Nemours that
really does value the whole child
and helping every child
maximize their potential.
So I just had to give that
commercial for Nemours.
It's stunning.
So, for the past 11 years,
Nemours BrightStart has developed
and researched new tools
for educators, parents,
and health care providers because
as we know all of those folks
in our community have
a big role to play.
And we want to help each of these
folks understand what it takes
for every child to
become a strong reader.
And Sandy did a great
job of reminding us.
We need to talk more about
what all children need.
And there's still is a
lot of misunderstanding
about what every child
needs to thrive.
We also focus a lot on how to
identify those children who maybe
at risk and what to do to catch them
up before they have
a chance to fail.
So we've developed educational tools
that through our research have been
proven highly successful in reducing
that reading readiness gap in these
vulnerable children before they even
get to kindergarten.
I wan to talk a little bit
about one of our current project
which is a website for
parents of children from birth
through 5 called
readingbrightstart.org.
On that website we've really taken
everything that we've learned
from our work with
thousands of children.
We've worked with children
our selves.
Parents and teachers direct
work with all of these people.
And put all of that
content into a website
with the goal empowering parents,
really putting them squarely
in the driver seat in preparing
their own child for reading success.
One of the best features
of our website is our
preschool reading screener
for 3 to 5-year-olds.
This is a simple check list
that helps the parent find
out if their child is on track
in their reading readiness
or maybe needs more help.
After the parent completes
the screener,
they receive a customized
action plan for there child.
All aspects of the
website are currently free
and we've optimized the site for
smartphone to make it as accessible
as possible to people
across the income spectrum.
So today, in this setting we're
releasing our very first national
reading readiness snapshot.
So through the website thousands
of parents from all 50 states
and Washington, DC have
completed that screener.
And thousands of them have
given us there permission
to use their child's data
for research purposes.
So we're sharing with you our very
first set of result as a springboard
to our goal ultimately of universal
reading readiness screening
for every 4-year-old in the country.
We have copies of our reading
readiness snapshot document
out on the table.
So, please grab one.
We're happy to discuss the result
and answer any questions
you have about that.
And we think this screener
as well as the website
as a whole can work really, really
well with programs like Reach Out
and Read and other
community initiatives
to strengthen early childhood
programs and resources.
Thank you.
>> Libby Dogget: Great.
We want to hear more about that
because I do want to
hear the results.
>> Laura Bailet: OK.
>> Libby Dogget: So where--
as I mentioned in my intro Lindsay
Carter is here from the USDA,
University-- US Department
of Agriculture.
So we have education and we talked
about health and we
have agriculture.
And they're doing amazing stuff.
We were really excited
when we were talking
and just hearing all
what's going on abroad.
So Lindsay, give us a little taste.
>> Lindsay Carter:
Thank you very much.
Yes, I'm here today from the
US Department of Agriculture.
And many of you maybe aware of
the National School Meals Program
and School Breakfast Programs
that we implement here in the US.
But over what-- that's with
the food and nutrition service.
But coming over to
another part of USDA,
we have the Foreign Agricultural
Service which has a mission
to improve agricultural trade
and reduce world hunger.
And one of the programs under
our agency is the McGovern-Dole,
full title, International
Food for Education
and Child Nutrition Program.
Which I think even in the
title alone really ties
in the health and then nutrition.
Our program began bin 2003
after being authorized
under the Farm Bill.
And our mission is to help promote
education, child development,
and food and security in some of
the world's poorest countries.
This is done through the use of US
agricultural commodities as well
as technical and financial
assistance to initiate, start,
and continue with school
meals programs.
And it's through this provision
of school meals that we look
for an initial increase
in school enrollment
and school attendance rates, which
is very visible visiting programs
in Malawi you suddenly see a lot
more children being sent to school
when their parents realize "Hey, our
kids are going to get a free meal."
And sometimes that is the only
meal that they receive in a day.
And we-- through programs as
well, we're improving enrollment,
increasing attendance rates,
and then also reducing
school dropout rates.
Our program is implemented by our
private voluntary organizations
and also international organizations
like the UN World Food Program.
Our program is running
from three to five years,
sometimes potential
for continuations.
And at present, we have 33
active agreements in 25 countries
across Latin America
and the Caribbean,
all parts of Africa
and Southeast Asia.
And what we find through
our programs is, well,
we saw initial increases
enrollments,
our program is doing a great job
about getting children into school.
It's when you got their
butts in the seats,
how do you start teaching
them to learn?
So in 2012, we developed
two results frameworks,
which include increase
literacy and increase the use
of health and dietary practices.
And this is through how
sort of school feeding leads
to at more children being
well fed, being at active
and attentive, ready to learn.
A hungry child is going--
is not going to have the
same learning capacity
as a child that is well fed.
Improve nutrition that comes from
providing a daily nutritious meal.
But we found that in order to
reach these goals we needed
to have complementary activities.
So, what we have a lot under
our program is an addition
to the providing a school meal.
We're bringing the parent-teacher
organizations together usually
to prepare the meal, to
serve the meal as well
as to support the school.
We'll introduce school
gardens which include a--
the FAO has developed the
school gardens curriculum.
This isn't for the children to be,
you know, out of the classroom,
but it's the opportunity for the
children to use the garden to be
out learning about
what's being grown.
I've seen school gardens where
they create the planting beds
in different shapes, so the
children can learn shapes.
There's a whole way of developing
a constructive curriculum.
We then talked about in order for
the children to get the nutrition
and the meal, building
routines, teaching handwashing,
making sure there's
access to safe water,
so that the school meals
can be safely prepared
and the overall health of
child is going to be supported.
We're also doing teacher
training and we're making sure
that there are books
in the classrooms.
For example, Room to
Learn is working in Laos
to make sure there
are school classrooms.
And a lot of these communities
there's usually a generation
of parents where a large
proportion of them are illiterate.
So, how do you bring them in?
Our program in Mali has
developed report cards,
which is landmark report
cards for illiterate parents.
That connects the parents
with the goal of the child
because we believe a parent doesn't
necessarily need to be literate
to understand the value of education
and want their child to be literate.
So, we have brought
all of those together.
We encourage our organizations to
build capacity at the national,
regional, and local level,
which usually involves developing
a national school feeding policy
and understanding what
is the benefits.
So we try a lot of-- there's a lack
data connecting really what is the
value of providing a school meal
to improve literacy and health
and nutrition of the
school age child
and how those two objectives
support one another.
So, we have-- we have
baseline, midterm,
and final evaluations
building a base of data as well
as taking our own initiatives
within our office
to develop systematic reviews
of what's already been studied
out there across the world.
And then build upon that, by
building our own learning agenda.
What do we need to know and what
pathways of attribution do we need
to learn so we can provide
this data to foreign government
to further support their
school meals programs
and there improve literacy.
And I think this is important.
The final note that
I want touch upon is,
here in the US our school
meals program is housed
within the Department
of Agriculture.
This isn't the case in many
of the countries that we work.
The school feeding
unit is usually housed
within the Ministry of Education.
So working on curriculum
development,
when we need to advocate for why
that should be a national school
feeding policy we're talking
to the education ministry.
So coordination with them and
recognizing the connection
of how school feeding can lead to
improvements in literacy and health.
But that touched upon today
especially the pediatricians
between the connection of literacy
and health and health and literacy.
And then my final thing is that--
my final point is the connections
that we need to making as far as
fought for coordination in order
to supplement these impacts.
Providing a school meal alone is
not going to improve literacy.
There need to be complementary
activities
and our office has benefitted from
the memorandum of understanding
with US Aids Office of
Education who have a goal one
to have improve the
literacy, early grade reading
of 100 million children worldwide.
Working with them, the
literacy experts will able
to improve the quality
of our program
and further providing
a school meal helps
to bring those children to school.
So thank you very much.
>> Libby Dogget: Thank you
Lindsey that was amazing.
Yes clap. [Applause] I
think it's incredible for us
to be reminded again
how important food is.
It is the very basic medicine.
I mean it's so basic and we
don't worry as much about that
because of the great school meal
programs although I think we worry
over the summer and over vacations
because some children even
in our country aren't getting
the nutrition they need.
That was incredible.
So we're going to go a little
bit more in-depth to be thinking
of your question because
you all are next.
But I want to go back to
you and talk a little bit
about intergenerational poverty.
I mean, you're working--
you're working with the parents
and the children and right
now there is a resurgence
on what we call two-gen programs.
Programs that don't just focus
on the children don't just focus
on the adults but focus on both
because we know they are important.
So, how does Reach Out
and Read fit into that?
>> Robert Needleman: Many years
ago I had a study underway
through Maternal and
Child Health Bureau
in which we enrolled several
hundred mothers of children coming
for their five month
Well-Child visit.
And part of what we did in the study
was we gave the mother very simple
reading test, the Wide Range
Achievement Test, which is nothing
but a list of words that you
have to read you get a score.
50% of our mothers in that
study were untestable.
Their scores were below
the bottom of the test.
So, the problem with
literacy is extreme.
Many of the graduates from
our public schools graduate
without the ability to read well.
My own take on it is that
having low literacy skills
as a parent contributes to a sense
of despair in terms of your ability
to help your child see a better way.
And at the same time, every time
you pick up a book you're reminded
of your own history of frustration
and discouragement
growing up in school.
So, one of the things that we try to
do in Reach Out and Read is be aware
of that and understand
that telling a parent
in that situation you should read
to your child is not
a benign thing to do.
It's actually very bad thing to do.
And that the message needs to be,
you can help your child love books
by having fun with your
child with the book.
Don't focus on words.
Make it fun and talk about the
pictures and enjoy it together.
So that-- we have a
problem in terminology.
We call it reading aloud.
But what we're really talking
about is not reading at all.
What we're talking about
is a joyful interaction
between parents and
children and books.
And to convey that to parents,
what we find is most
helpful is not really
to say very much at
all but to do it.
So, our methodology at least
what I think is most effective is
to watch the parent
looking at the book of child
for a very short period of time.
One can get a good sense of it
in a very quick interaction.
To notice when it looks
beautiful and be a witness
to that this is beautiful.
Or when it doesn't look
beautiful to be able
to right there demonstrate
how to do it.
And it is as simple as stepping and
saying, "Why don't we try this?"
And then you do something.
And it may be just
looking at a picture
and saying, "Hey, where is the boy?
What's he doing?
Where is the dog?
Can you show me the," right.
And you play that game for a minute.
And then when the child is
engaged and happy we say,
"This is what we mean when we talk
about reading, now you do it."
And then giving another parent a
chance to mimic what we've done.
So, that's a very concrete
approach to this question
of interrupting a transgenerational
transmission
of not only literacy is an
inability to read but literacy
as an unhappy relationship
with books.
And I think we can do that because
of the power of the relationship
between the doctor and the parent
where the relationship is one
of appreciation without
judgment and of collaboration.
We are in this together
to help your child
to be the most wonderful
person that can be.
So your quote from Dr.
Pasteur was exactly right.
That's exactly what we're about.
>> Libby Dogget: So Laura,
talk us more about the reading.
I mean it's difficult
to learn to read.
We know from Bob a lot of
families can't read and we have
to teach them how to read the
pictures and tell the stories
and use their words in other ways.
But how hard is it to learn
to read and what is that--
what's going on in the brain and
what does the research tell us?
>> Laura Bailet: Well, learning
to read is really a very
challenging task for the brain.
And I think we're reminded of that
with the statistic that Sandy showed
in one of her slides that by
the end of third grade 2/3
of American children-- we're
a very affluent country
on an international scale.
Two-thirds of them are
not proficient in reading.
That does that mean 2/3 of all
of our children are disabled
or that there's something
wrong with them.
What's wrong is that
they're not getting the kind
of instruction starting
early and you have
to help them become
proficient readers.
And one of things that the
basics that we have sort
of forgotten is how challenging
a task this is for the brain.
You know, reading occurs very late
in the course of human development
and you know I think a lot when
I'm at the Library of Congress
about Gothenburg and I once
heard a brilliant neuroscientist,
Dr. Gordon Sherman say, "You know
what really cause dyslexia was
Gothenburg because when he
invented the printing press all
of a sudden the masses are sort
of expected to be able to read,
whereas before it was only
the elite few that could read.
But now that everybody has
the opportunity to read,
the expectation goes up, well,
then everybody should read
and it's not a natural
easy thing for the brain."
And so I think there's
a lot to that.
But we still have this prevailing
myth that children do learn
to read naturally if they just
sort of have books around them
and a reasonably supportive
environment.
Now children do learn
to talk in this way
but most children don't
learn to read in this way.
For most children learning to
read in English takes about three
to four years of intentional
systematic high quality instruction.
If you're Italian it
only takes about one
to two years to learn to read.
If you're Chinese it
takes about 10 years.
So it definitely varies
depending on the complexity
of the written language system.
And even many educators
don't fully understand this.
Learning to read requires several
parts of the brain which are built
to do something else to learn a
new skill and then synchronize
with these other brain areas.
They're also learning
something new at the same time.
So it's pretty darn complicated and
we really shouldn't be surprised
that so many children
struggle with it.
Now I do want to emphasize
that success
with reading instruction is
really predicated on a lot
of high quality talking, reading,
singing and playing that parents
and other caregivers will do with
young children starting from birth.
So that is absolutely
necessary and lays
down that solid brain foundation
so that the child is ready and able
to benefit from that
high quality instruction.
So it takes both sides of that and
the earlier that we start providing
that evidence-based developmentally
appropriate reading instruction the
stronger the reading outcomes.
I do want to go back to a point
that Libby actually mentioned.
I can't believe she said it.
But another really important--
because we didn't talk
about it in advance
and I already had this
typed, you can look.
Another really important point
about reading is that it tends
to be viewed as a proxy
for intelligence.
So it works like this, if you're a
good reader you must be very smart.
And that's exactly what
Libby said that kid
who know the word tip she
said he must be very smart!
>> Libby Dogget: He
was and he still is.
>> Laura Bailet: That's--
And he still is.
But you're no slack and you
weren't reading that word, so.
But if you're not a
good reader maybe it's
because you're just not very smart.
And this is the message that
struggling readers receive over
and over and begin
telling themselves.
And those of you who work with
adults with low literacy skills,
you know what I'm talking about.
I can't tell you how often I have
heard from children, teenagers,
and adults that they think they
are not smart no matter what other
evidence there is that they are
incredibly bright and talented.
And once they start to think
that they're not smart,
it's like it become sort of
seared into their psyche.
And they just can't
stop believing that.
And it has so profound an
impact on their confidence,
on their willingness
to ask questions
in institutional situations or with
authority figures like a doctor.
They are terrified to
read with their children
because they think they
can't do it well enough.
And that if they don't know a word
or make a mistake that's the
worst thing that can happen.
We spend a lot of time
and effort on our website
and in our direct interaction
with parents talking exactly
about what Robert said.
It's not about reading
every word on the page.
It's about engaging around
that book, having fun,
having a loving supportive
conversation.
That's what's important with the
babies not reading every word
on the page.
That's what really motivates us
at Nemours BrightStart
well stuff there.
>> Libby Dogget: So Lindsay, we've
talked to all about the intersection
of health and literacy and
you added really nutrition
because we know that's important
too and Hassink talked about it.
What if you learned from abroad
that we should know or heed?
>> Lindsay Carter: It's-- Across
all programs depending on the other,
there's a lot of differences.
But sometimes I'm struck
by when I'm in the field
when I hear very similarities,
a lot of sort of qualitative
discussions I have with a parents
or a community member really
drives home and be like,
I'm pretty sure I could be
having this conversation
with the parent in the US.
A lot of it having to do with--
we taught a lot about early
childhood development.
Hearing teachers Burkina
Faso where childcare
and early childhood development
is certainly not common feature.
But we do part of that.
Our activities there is we do
support early childcare centers
and provide training to caregivers.
And hearing the parents there
and the teachers talking
about these children they arrived
and they already know their letters
and they're ready to read.
In the community where many of
the households have notebooks,
whatsoever, but a well-supplied
early childcare center has the same
impact, very similar impact to
what it can have in Burkina Faso
to what it has in Oklahoma.
So there are lot of similarities
as well as some differences.
But what really strikes me
is the conversations today
as far what I've seen is literacy
is not restricted to the classroom.
It's what happens in a
pediatricians' offices,
what happens in a childcare,
what happens a lot in the home.
And when we talk-- working in
very remote and isolated locations
around the world, a school is
important because a school is
where a community can
come together in a place
where they may not
be a health clinic
but there is usually
a primary school.
So I think it's important
to remember that a school
and education system is a
resource of the community
where it can be a location
but it's not those--
the boundaries of the school
go beyond the school gate.
So that's really how [inaudible]
of providing a school meal
and addressing nutrition
heath and literacy
that sort of our entry point.
But we really try and
develop programs
that go beyond the school
gate and that engages with--
engaging with parents and doing
nutrition trainings and working--
if there's a preschool
working with a preschool.
And developing that sort of
sustainability and really trying
to save a community which I
think is probably true in the US.
And I'll just use this
as another places.
We found that the school
is incredibly useful
on these very remote and isolated
locations as also an entry point
for providing certain aspects
of health education
and health services.
And I didn't get a chance to
mention during my introduction.
But another part of the
ability of a child to take
in the nutritional
quality is something
like providing de-worming campaigns.
So that's actually a way that a
Ministry of Education may coordinate
with a Ministry of Health as far
as if there's a national de-worming
campaign having that entry point
into a community not be through the
health center that doesn't exist
but being through to school.
And by providing nutrition and
education and health education
to a child is kind of a twofold
effect because you both--
you reach the parents and also
you're reaching the future parents
through the children.
>> Libby Dogget: Great.
Thank you.
Laura?
>> Laura Bailet: Can I share with
the audience a little bit of--
a conversation that
the three of us had
as we all met first thing
this morning and Lindsay
that was the point that you made
that sometimes inadvertently,
a literacy program or a
feeding program because of time
and resource constraints end
up one supplants the other.
And it may be inadvertent or you--
you know, organizations may know
that this is going to happen but
feel like, "Well, we can't do both,
so we're going to have to
pick one over the other."
And I think in some ways that
happens a lot in this country, too,
where we sort to have
the "Tyranny of the OR."
We think we can do
this or we can do this.
But there's no way we
can do both together.
And I think that's where, you know,
some creative thinking and thinking
across traditional boundaries and
silos could really help us do both
in a very resource-efficient
and time-efficient.
Well, I don't know if you--
either of you we all talked about.
>> Robert Needleman: Well,
I think that the key insight is you
can't be healthy if you can't read.
And you probably can't
read if you're not healthy.
So the OR proposition is
a nonstarter and we need
to just be really clear about that.
>> Libby Dogget: I think
it brings us back around,
actually what Dr. Hassink was saying
which is zip code and community
and how important all the
services are in that community
and how we need to really
work to bring it all together
and make sure that it's efficient.
That there's not duplication
but that we're reaching
all the families.
So I have one more question then
we're going to throw out open
to the audience and
this for any of you.
Given that, that we need
to breakdown these silos
and that we need to
do AND instead of OR.
What advice do you have?
>> Lindsay Carter: Research.
It's understanding
the school feeding.
It's the hardest thing as far as
we can collect to all the data
but especially even though there
have been few random control trials
when we work in schools, when you're
providing a school meal to a child,
having-- developing random control
trials that already helps us draw
that f attribution is difficult
at best and we need more data
and research in order
to tell our story
of seeing not only the
intended impacts but some
of the unintended impacts and making
sure we're designing the best set
of-- the best package of
interventions to reach our goal.
>> Robert Needleman: So,
if your answer is research.
My answer is bookkeeping.
In particular because our
focus is on very children,
very young children tend to be
served through the health system
and older children tend to be
served through the education system.
And it makes very difficult
to do a cost-benefit analysis
if the cost are being
born in one system
and the benefits are
being realized in another.
So we need to do some creative
bookkeeping where we recognized
that investments that may flow
through a doctor's
office might have payoffs
that show up later in school.
>> Libby Dogget: I love it.
Laura you want to come in?
>> Laura Bailet: Sure.
I think both of these
are so important
and I think also how we talk about
issues of literacy and health,
just how we frame the issues and the
terms that we used have such impact
on the structures that we set
up, so it's really struck again
by what Lindsay said, you
know, in the united States,
the school nutrition program is
housed in Department of Agriculture.
Whereas in many countries oversees,
it's housed in the
Department of Education.
And the very fact that
it's an agriculture ports--
and I'm not saying that's
bad or that's wrong.
But there's historical
precedence and decision making
that have implications down the road
that we may not have recognized.
And so by put-- by
having it in agriculture,
in some people's mind we think of
that as strictly a food program
and a farming issue and
not an educational issue.
And so to be aware of how the
structural barriers prevent us
thinking differently, which then
prevents us from acting differently.
And I think blended funding streams
where, you know, or recognition
that dollar spent in one system may
have their greatest dollar savings
long term in a very
different system but that--
that that is good,
that that's not bad.
And how do we have that sort of
joint accounting monetarily and also
in terms of the broader goals of
what we're trying to accomplish.
And I keep coming back
to what Sandy said.
We've sort of taken our
eyes off the fundamentals
and what does every
child fundamentally need.
And they need food and nutrition
and they need to learn to read.
I mean those should
be fundamental things
that no matter what else
is happening nationwide,
we don't take our eye off that ball.
And I think that's happened a lot.
>> Libby Dogget: So you could
see we have an excellent panel.
It's your turn now and
what questions you have?
What's raised and will
go to the very back.
>> Laura Bailet: Yehey.
I love the hands going up.
>> Libby Dogget: And tell
us your name and where you
from just so we have a contact.
>> Sandra Charles: Sure.
Good morning.
I'm Dr. Sandra Charles.
I'm actually the physician here
at the library running the
Occupational Health Program.
>> Laura: Bailet: Oh great.
>> Sandra Charles: And
you're coming at it
from the child literacy
point of view.
We try to come out from
the health and literacy
for the adults who
are our employees.
But I'm really fascinated by this
because I couldn't agree more
with the whole the premise of
getting not only to the nutrition
but the literacy combined.
And to that end, the responses to
that last question where we talked
about we need more
research and data.
I would say you have enough of that
to try, start the collaboration
between the USDA programs and the
eduction programs and try to get
that out there where people
are making the connection.
So put what you already
have out into the community.
I guess that sort of like
the practical application
of the research that you've done.
So make it more out in the
community and I think that we will--
I'm sitting here thinking of all
kinds of possibilities in terms
of programs that people could start.
And I actually have a
child, a daughter who's--
she aspires to be where you're in
terms of pediatrics and dealing
with the childhood problems of
literacy and health and nutrition.
And so I'm been hearing this for
sometime from her and I just think
that you have enough to start
making the collaborations
and implementing some
of the programs.
And one of the things we've start
to do here is starting a
family health and wellness day.
We encourage employees to bring
their families in and introduce them
to different health
and wellness things
and I think this is a real key
component that we could incorporate.
And commend Dr. Cole because
ever since I've been here,
you know, start with the reading.
It's fundamental and it's come
a long way and it is fundamental
to both health and wellness.
Thank you.
>> Libby Dogget: Thank you.
Anyone want to comment?
>> Laura Bailet: I'll
just say stick around.
We have an adult panel
right after lunch, so.
[ Inaudible Remark ]
OK.
>> Libby Dogget: Robie,
the floor is yours.
>> Robie Harris.
Hi. Can I ask one question--
>> Libby Dogget: Stand up
and tell them who you are.
>> Robie Harris: All right.
I'm Robie Harris [inaudible].
Oh.
[ Multiple Speakers ]
-- show the people out there.
I'm just sorry that Ellen
Oh can't be here today.
The founder and a marvelous
children's book author run around
and just wondered, started with
other, mostly librarians but people
with children's book field, we
need diverse books for children.
And I just wondered if the panel
could maybe comment on the issue
of diversity and how you see it
fitting in what you have to say.
>> Robert Needleman: I'll start.
>> Libby Dogget: Thank
you very much.
>> Robert Needleman: So in the
course of the work in the clinic,
especially for older children.
My clinic because of funding
issues relays on donated books.
And so the books that we
have for children 6, 7, 8,
9 are whatever we can get.
And very few of those books are
Afrocentric books and very many
of our patients are
African-American.
And so I'll ask parents when
their child is, you know,
holding that book and being
very excited about it,
"Do you know about
Afrocentric books, do have any?"
And for most of the
parent they don't.
And it really is a problem because
the message to a young child
who has a beautiful book that has
people in it who are not identified
with that kid is that these books
are written for somebody else
about a world that
is not your world.
And the shame of it is is
that there are many, many,
many wonderful Afrocentric
stories and books
that our parents don't
know about them a lot.
And so, you know, if I can wave
my magic wand and get a budget
to do it, I'd be buying a
bunch of those of books.
I would make sure that I have
[inaudible] beautiful daughters.
I would make sure that I
have the people could fly.
have Ezra Jack Keats' books.
You know, the "Snowy Day" in winter
and "Whistle for Willie" in summer
in perfusion so that every kid
with darker skin in my clinic
who identifies as African-American
could have some books like that.
I make sure that I
have some biographies
of great African-American leaders
that the little kids who I see
who filled, you know, sort
of disenfranchise can read
about Malcom X who was
sometimes angry, you know,
just like they're sometimes angry.
But he took and he made
it pretty powerful.
So just to echo, we need
it and we need to be aware
of it we need to fund it.
>> Libby Dogget: Thank
you for reminding us that.
I think it's important.
Do you want to mention something?
>> Lindsay Carter: I think
this is a wonderful question
because it's a challenge that we
face with the McGovern-Dole program.
But we're trying very hard with our
implementing partners to address
because not only are
we trying to make sure
that we have appropriate books
in an international context.
And this helped by our colleagues
at the USA Office of Eduction
and Laura alluded of how
difficult it is to learn
to read is we're trying with
a lot of these countries
where there's usually
a colonial language.
And then there's a mother tongue.
So often children are being
asked to learn to read
in a language they
haven't even learned
or spoken until the age of five.
So trying to-- usually we're
having to actually seek
out to be very creative and being
able to produce both textbook
and fictional books
for the community
in a language that is understood.
And there's some very creative ways
that our projects are doing the most
as far as finding a
affordable and ego-resource.
My favorite is in some West African
countries, Peace Corps volunteers
who are working with a program
to help and produce books
because they know the
local language.
They've learned it.
They can read and write it and
they're producing these books
that can go out in communities
and then tying and in
with the health aspect
making sure that the message
of this book is not only
enticing to children
but making sure it address
issues such as handwashing,
improved nutrition, working
with others in the community.
So I think there's the
language that we choose as well
as how the books look, making
sure they're exciting its--
and accessibility issues.
But there are lots of creative ways
that we can make these
resources available.
>> Libby Dogget: And we want the
diverse books for all children
because I don't want my
Anglo kids to not just see--
>> Lindsay Carter: Right.
>> Libby Dogget: -- themselves.
I want them see others.
Dr. Sullivan.
>> Laura Bailet: And can I just
say one other thing though.
>> Libby Dogget: Sorry Laura.
>> Laura Bailet: I
think it's important
to remember diversity is there's
so many types of diversity.
So there's diversity
of race and ethnicity.
There's linguistic diversity.
There's also health diversity.
And Robie is going to do a talk
on her books where she writes
about children with
different health issues.
But books are a fantastic way
for children teenagers and adults
to see themselves if they
have a health condition
or a learning challenge
through characters in a book
and to broaden their
world perspective.
See a world that-- without
limits instead of the limitations
and the helplessness
that they often feel
when they have a health
or a learning condition.
And stories just can
open a person's eyes
to broader, a broader world view.
And if nothing else books are a
great companion for sick days.
And we don't want to forget
about the joy of reading
and actually an author ambassador,
former one for the Library
of Congress, Kate DiCamillo
who wrote the story
"Because of Winn-Dixie".
She talks about as a young
child, she was sick a lot
and books are what
kept her saying it,
open the world of possibilities
to her.
So I don't want to forget that.
Sorry Dr. Sullivan.
>> Libby Dogget: So books are
windows and they're mirrors.
Way to see out, way to see yourself.
Dr. Sullivan, we're
so glad you're here.
>> Laura Bailet: Yes.
>> Libby Dogget: We're all honored.
>> Louis Sullivan: Thank you.
First of all this is
really an excellent panel
and I'm very pleased to be here.
And one of the reasons I'm here is
because of the well-established
known relationship between level
of education literacy and health.
And I maintain that
while we really have
as a nation had tremendous
development
of our scientific knowledge
and new therapies et cetera.
We really haven't done as
much or as well as we should
on improving health
literacy and health behavior.
Well, I'm please that that's
getting some recognition.
Having said that, I
have several questions
or comment I'd like to make.
First, I have specific
question for Dr. Hassink.
I'm curious is to what
happen to that grandfather
who wanted his grandson held
back, because it sounded
as if that didn't happen.
And I meant the system was not
responsive here and it bothers me
because often we find that rules and
our regulations or bureaucracy get
in the way of good decision
making and that really is one
of the issues that I worry about.
The other comment I
want to make is this
with tremendous programs
that you have.
I'm bothered by the fact
that we don't, as a country,
support education strongly
as we should.
Everyone knows that we
are really in a new era
that we really are moving
towards an educate--
system where those who have good
education are going to do well,
those who do not really
falling by the wayside,
part of the income gap
that we refer to now.
So, the question I have is
with the programs that we have,
what's being done to really let the
public know and generate support
for them so that our legislators in
our states or in our school systems
or in the congress
really support them.
Because the paradox is we have
these tremendous programs.
But yet we have a real problem
really getting the kind of support
for our education systems.
So I'd be interested in knowing
what have your experiences has been
or what are your thoughts,
how can we really take these
tremendous programs that you have
and generate the kind
of support that we need
so that they will really
be promulgated
around the country as they should?
>> Libby Dogget: So, Dr.
Hassink is going to help us.
>> Sandra Hassink: Well, but--
>> This was on?
>> Sandra Hassink: I don't
know if I can help you.
But the grandfather was not
able to get his son held back
because his was not
a behavior problem.
And did what-- you know, was a quiet
little boy who sort of was there
in class and we tried and
didn't have any other feature
that would have allowed
us to advocate except
that he couldn't read
and we couldn't do it.
We couldn't solve that problem
for the grandfather, so.
>> Libby Dogget: So,
anyone who want to address
that complicated difficult question?
>> Robert Needleman:
I am speechless.
>> Libby Dogget: We need
everybody here to help us
because this is not
going to happen easily.
I think in other countries
they do it because of--
it's a moral obligation
to take care of your kids.
But somehow in United
States we've got
to proved that's it cost effective,
that we're going to save money
and even though know, even for
something as simple as preschool,
there are people that say
that the results fade,
it doesn't make a difference,
and we're trouble selling it.
So, it is an uphill battle
here in United States
and we need everybody here
to speak out repeatedly
and your voice would be a
particularly helpful one.
>> Louis Sullivan: Well, thanks
I really would not hesitate to do
that in every opportunity.
And one other comment for Dr.
Needleman, with lack of diversity,
ethnic diversity of your books and
the need for them, I wonder you're
in Cleveland, I'm sure you
know Reverend Otis Moss.
And the Cleveland urbanely I
know for years has been one
of the strongest urbanely
chapters around the country.
So, I guess my question is have
you raised this question with some
of the black leadership in your
community because these are people
who really ought to
be responsive to that.
And you could tell
them that I sent you.
Reverend Moss happens to be
a Morehouse college graduate.
So, I know him.
He was two years behind
me in college.
>> Libby Dogget: So,
we have a quick answer
and then actually we're out of time.
So I'm going to let
the panel wrap but--
>> Robert Needleman: I will be glad
to convey your message
to the reverend.
There is a very small health
center in the Fairfax neighborhood
of Cleveland called the Otis
Moss University Health Center
and they support us
fantastically by allowing
as to store our books
in their basement.
Just to clarify the Reach Out
and Read program as organized
through our national
center and is supported
in our local chapters does
raise lots and lots of money
to purchase culturally
appropriate ethnically diverse books
for our target audience
which is children
from birth to age essentially six.
That's the sweet spot for us because
that's when we see kids frequently.
And we think that's
when the foundations
of literacy are laid down.
So, on the good side, I would
say, that we do have a wealth
of beautiful culturally appropriate
books, largely through generation--
generosity too of Scholastic
which makes these available to us
at great discounts and also
supports their generation.
So that's the good side.
And the bad side is we're
limited by our budgets to books
that are not terribly expensive.
And so the books that we can provide
at every Well-Child visit retail
for somewhere between
five and six bucks.
And to our nonprofits
cost us somewhere
between two and three bucks.
But that prices those
kids out of a lot
of the very best literature
that's out there for children.
So, when I was raising my
kid, I didn't only get books
that cost five and six bucks.
>> Libby Dogget: Right.
>> Robert Needleman: So, there's a
great disparity and injustice even
as we try to do our best.
We could do a whole lot
more to make the full range
of beautiful literature available
to the full range of our kids.
>> Libby Dogget: So, I told them
they could have one last word.
Anyone want to last word?
>> Laura Bailet: I just want to
thank everyone for being here.
I think in response to your question
of how can this feed
better publicized.
I think by being here today and
then going out and messaging
and continuing to work together
will start plant some seeds
and funding is always an issue.
But thank you all and
hopefully you learn a lot today
that you can message about.
>> Libby Dogget: Thank you panel.
Thank you audience.
Thank you all for being here.
>> John Cole: Thank you.
Thank you.
I'd like to thank you everyone
and just make one more--
before we take a little break,
very short break before
we hear from Robie.
On the diverse books issue,
tomorrow here at the Library
of Congress we will giving the--
hosting an event at which
the first diversity award
in children's books will
be given by an award
by the American Library Association.
And this is moment of know, OK,
Karen is going to correct me.
>> Karen Baicker: We
Need Diverse Books.
>> John Cole: We Need Diverse
Books is the name of the group
which is carrying on
in this whole area
and the first awards will
be given and it's going
to be called the Walter Award
in honor of Walter Dean Myers
who is our National Ambassador
for Young People's Literature.
And Walter sadly passed away
soon after his two-year term.
Kate DiCamillo followed
Walter and our new of--
our new Gene Yang is our
new National Ambassador.
But tomorrow, it's a public event.
It's at 10 o'clock in the
room where we were last night.
It's in room 119 and you would all
be welcome to come and learn more
about we-- give me the phrase
again, We Need Diverse Books
which is the name of the group.
So this is very a theme of
what we're doing and thank you
for bringing it up indirectly
and directly to everyone here.
I thought Robie we're going to
take a five minute break and start
with Robie and when you comeback
the restrooms are right next door.
Please be back in five minutes and
we'll continue with the program.
Thank you for the wonderful
morning and first panel.
Well, we have special author's
perspective on our topics today.
And from the beginning
we had the notion
of having an author's perspective
and we have been exceptionally lucky
to have Robie Harris here who
is known for, to many of you,
as a very prolific and
thoughtful writer and author
about books relating to
families, childbirth, sexuality.
She, in fact, has been
at this for so long.
And some of her books are
having anniversary editions
and there is a brochure for both
"It's Perfectly Normal" and "It's
So Amazing" 20th anniversary
of "It's Perfectly Normal",
15th anniversary of
"It's So Amazing".
And those brochures plus a display
of a number of her books are
on the table in the back.
When we spoke on the phone
which is the first time we met
to talk a little bit
about her presentation,
I was struck how she
emphasized that in the research
for her books she often started by
whatever the topic talking to kids
and talking to children
about the topic
that she was about to write about.
And I thought, "Well, may
we call this a perspective
from the childhood?"
And she said, "No, it's going to
be my perspective, but I want you
to know that I do my
background research, you know,
with the real thing
with the children."
And when I've seen the range
of the books that she's put out
and heard her speak a little bit
about these I know
we're in for a treat.
Let's welcome Robie Harris.
[ Applause ]
>>John Cole: I'll take my notes.
Sorry.
>> Robie Harris: So I'm
feeling a little speechless.
And for those who know me
well I'm really not just
because so much has
been said already,
which has been so wonderful.
So I want to join Dr. Needlman
in the repetition model here
and John you mentioned
that I might be able to go
on just a little bit longer.
OK. So, I have permission
to do that.
So it's an absolute privilege to
be here, at the Center for the Book
at the Library of Congress.
And to be able to thank you John
Cole and I've written at my words,
too, so that I won't too, too long.
The founding and current director
of the senate for the book
for your critical support and the
center support for the work all
of us do in the world of children's
books and children's health.
I want to thank Dr. Bailey, for
last night, for your leadership
in the world of child health,
the BrightStar Program,
and your wonderful words,
"Everything we do must be
for the child" and I quote here.
"If it's not, then we need to
reconsider why we are doing it."
And also Dr. Hassink for
your leadership in the field
of pediatrics, for
mentioning the ACEs study
and literacy this morning,
which I think is very important.
Critical work on childhood
obesity and the link between health
and literacy and it goes
on and on the toolkit.
And all of you in the audience,
you know, I'm behind my computer
and then let me out every once
in awhile to do-- to speak.
But you're on the front lines.
And all of you for your leadership
in the field of pediatrics,
your critical work on childhood
and to all of you in the audience
to care about or give care day-in
day-out to our nation's children
from infancy through adolescence,
and actually prenatally
because that certainly is a
part of health, to help them
and their family to stay healthy.
So I gave John Cole a
title which is up there
"Read Well, Be Well, Stay Well".
And I'm going to continue
to look at the question
which I also sent to Dr. Cole.
What real can children's books
play in helping kids of all ages
and their families stay
physically and emotionally healthy?
I'm a children's book author.
I have a strong interest and
background in child development.
And I think children
are so wonderful.
I can't stop watching
them, listening to them,
hearing their words,
watch their play,
watch them when they get angry,
watch them when they get upset,
get worried, concerned, and so on.
So-- But in order to creat the books
I write I still find it extremely
healthy-- helpful, not
only to talk with kids.
And I have conversations
with the kids.
I don't sit them down and I
don't have a tape recorder
and interview, you know.
We just sit and talk about a topic.
But I also find it extremely
helpful to consult with librarians,
teachers, scientist, health care,
mental health child development
professionals, and also with parents
who often know their
children the best.
I do this to make sure that the
non-fictions books I write have the
most up-to-date, age-appropriate,
medically
and scientifically
accurate information.
And we do this every time
we go back to reprint
on my non-fiction books every time.
And if some big change came through,
my publisher for those books,
Candlewick Press has said, "Yes, we
will go back to reprint right away,"
because kids have the
right to have the latest
and most accurate information.
And I do this also so that the
picture books stories I write
reflect with honesty and that's
very important word for me, honesty.
The powerful and yet
perfectly normal emotions,
that most young children
experience day-in day-out
because I think we all in this
room believe if we're not honest
for there kids, then we
lose them in a conversation,
of a book that just doesn't being
honest in what they know in life,
they turn away from the book.
The books I write, the
words I write are my way
of having a conversation
with children.
And they include-- you know,
but what I chose to write
that includes the values
that I have.
So they are my way of
having a conversation
with children about staying healthy.
And as I said earlier that
includes their physical
and their emotional health which
everyone in this room we all know.
We're so interconnected.
I've been told that the books I
write and this is all anecdotal,
spark many questions from children.
And it's true for many
children's book authors.
So I'm really speaking for
all of us, as a gang together.
So it's not just my books.
So they often lead to conversations
between a child and a parent
or caregiver or another trusted
adult in that child's life.
And that these books that I'm
talking about this morning and--
not only provide access to
information for a child,
but also for that child's parents.
Information that kids
need and have are right,
and I say that really loud,
"Have a right to have".
So, that they're be
able to stay healthy
and eventually make healthy
decisions for them selves,
not only for them selves
but for there friends.
Or the picture book story I
write sparks a responsive core
that is what I hope for
in a child that might help
that child stay emotionally
healthy and reaffirm
that the strong feelings
they have and I write
about in different books, all of
these feelings from love to anger
to joy to fear, jealousy,
sadness, lost, yes, even hate.
Our legitimate feelings
and more often
than that emotionally
healthy feelings.
And the book about hate is
really a book about love,
when those words just
pop out of your mouth
and then this little child in this
book, what does he want to do?
He wishes that moment he can stuff
them all back in, but it's too late.
Onward on to some of my books
as examples of some of the ways
in which children's book can
contribute to literacy, hopefully,
and potentially the other
healthy or healthier outcomes.
And just so have a chance as Dr.
Cole said there are books back there
that if you fee like it, you may
have time today, you can take a look
at and ask me any questions about.
Let me first note that for
parents and for there kids,
kids of all ages, and
especially for kids and parent
with low literacy skills,
hen the words in the children's book
are married to the art in the book
and I can't draw for
beans, I work with amazing,
brilliant, wonderful illustrators.
I'm so lucky.
And they bring a whole
new dimension,
but we work very closely together
that doesn't always
happen for other authors.
The art is another way to pass on
the information and could help kids
and teens and parents become
visually literate as well.
Since today so much
of the information,
they and we seek is a visual.
And we get it through
the visual world.
Together words and art in the book
often bring both kids and adults
like in-- engage both kids and
adults alike in multiple ways.
Now, I don't travel everywhere
with copies of my books, but I--
you can see an image on the screen.
I had 200 5-year-olds in a gym
outside of Illinois a year ago.
And I-- So that I think couldn't
see a book if I opened it.
And I-- what I loved about it and
you'll see this a little bit later,
is that, I had-- they
had a huge screen.
And so I had kids come up
and hold books and I said
"So what's the difference?"
And this child said "You can't
hug that" looking at the screen,
he said and he went like this.
You can hug a book.
And that to me-- and it was before--
the last book that
I was going to show.
It was before I showed
them the whole story
which is the last book
that you'll get to see.
That-- I think that tells
us something about books.
This book is-- that I'm
going to talk about.
It's perfectly normal and I have to
remember to do two things at once.
This is just a range of the
different kinds of books I write,
but here is the cover for it.
It's perfectly normal.
It's illustrated by
the amazing friend
and my dear friend Michael Emberley.
We worked hand and hand
together on these books--
on this book and on
many other books.
But this book is now, talking
about the international,
in more than 35 languages and
pirated in some countries.
A country now I can't remember.
In Eastern Europe there's-- do you
know the photographs by Ann Geddes
of a baby in an egg
shell, that's the cover
which is total not science.
He and I-- it's so crazy.
I have a copy of it.
Someone brought it back to me.
So-- And the art and text in
every book as I said are vetted
by kind specialist I've
mentioned a minute or so ago
and if need be are
updated every time one
of our books is reprinted,
which happens often.
You know one such example,
but there are tons of them.
You know them in the pediatric world
or the medical world, you know,
the HPV vaccine and now
was approved for boys then.
You know, we know not
enough kids are getting it,
am I correct, the pediatric world?
So that's in there
plus so much more.
I began knowing that I wanted to
write a comprehensive book though
but answer almost not every,
but almost every question kids
and teens would have
about sexuality.
I chose the title "It's Perfectly
Normal" because the truth is
that most, not all, things
about sexuality are normal.
Except of course those aberrant
things such as abuse, infection,
becoming pregnant, when one is
too young to take confident care
of a child, the list goes on.
But we all know this when the
topic engages kids they want
to know about the topic.
And most often so do their parents.
So here we have a book that
is about sex and human biology
for kids roughly 9, 10, and up.
And I would pause at the following.
When a preteen-- What preteen
or teen does not want to read
about the perfect combo,
sex and science.
In this case human
biology and, yes, health.
This is also a book about them
and what they are experiencing
as they begin and then go
through puberty and adolescence.
What pre teen or teenagers does not
want to read about one self, right?
A little egocentrism here.
I would also pause at the experience
for an adult who read such a book
with or before their child reads.
I always-- I give one
piece of advice.
I also tell everybody who I'm not.
I'm not a pediatrician.
I'm not health care provider.
Child's book author.
But I say one for-- to the
parents says what should I do,
what should I said?
Read it through any book on
this topic, not just mine.
Read it through first on your own,
you'll have a temporary leg
up on your child, right?
That's the only piece
of advice I give.
So a parent who reads a book with
or before their child read
this can help build literacy.
Not only for the kids
who are reading this book
but for their parents as well
who use a book such as this
to get information they may
find too difficult to deal with.
I understand that completely.
It's easier for me to talk
about other peoples children
when one talks about
mine are grown up now.
But when my kids we're young it's
harder to talk to your own children.
Very own children being a parent.
So but for parents as well
who use a books such as this
to get information they may find
too difficult to deal with or hard
to access and going back to trauma
or may have had a traumatic
experience in their own lives.
We're talking about
health and sexuality.
It's just-- It's too painful.
It's too traumatic.
And then they can go
to the rest of--
the health world to get
that information passed on.
We have told-- been told over
and over again that the words
in this book and other books I have
written and the art Michael created,
gives parents permission
to talk about.
And I hate these word
"tough" topics.
I talked about-- was
writing about tough topics.
These are the normal everyday topics
that every family deals with and,
yes, many of them are difficult.
And in this case given the words
parents, a language they can use
to talk with their kids
about sexual health.
This means that parents
are reading, too,
and modeling reading
for their kids as well.
A road to literacy.
I think I know what
this room would say.
Would we call it family literacy?
And it's also a way for parents
and kids to become or continue
to be emotionally attached to one
another through a shared experience
of reading the same book.
And by the way often they're not
reading it together at that age.
You know, child-- parent--
I say to parents--
they say, "What do you do?"
I can say that you have more
than one piece of advice.
I say, "You know, it's OK if your
child reads it on their own."
You just can say, "You read it.
You know, I care about you.
I love you.
I want you to stay healthy.
You might find this interesting
and of course the kids all they
say, "I know all this stuff.
I don't have to do it."
You know, parents leave them
back of the toilet or next
to the computer and its gone.
We've been told that.
So through a shared experience of
reading the same book that can lead
to talking together about so
many topics including parents
on family values.
Fostering this kind of
attachment between a parent
and one's child certainly
seems to me
to be an added positive
literacy outcome.
Our children's book librarians
and teachers and daycare providers
and so many more I
probably not listed,
also provide this day-in day-out by
having my books, but not just mine
and others in their
classrooms as Bob said,
"If they can afford it [inaudible]."
And their collections in an open
shelf, not in a hidden shelf
under lock and key that the
librarian keeps up up on top,
so-- and accessible to kids.
So here we go.
Here are some images from the
recently completed 20th anniversary
edition and I chose these.
I could have chosen a million.
So let's see.
So this is from the first
chapter called "What is Sex", OK.
Yes, these are cartoon characters.
I had a boy and a girl and
then I couldn't use a boy
and a girl because-- I mean,
girls would think one thing
and boys would think others and
not all the stuff about gender.
I mean, it gets just
very complicated.
So they might not know
the bird and bee are--
bird, the kid who wants
to know everything,
ask every question can't stop.
The bee thinks it's all gross
and disgusting except gets
fascinated by the science.
I was more of the bee than the bird.
So here is just a little
text from there.
This is the opening.
Sex is about a lot of things bodies
growing up, families, babies, love,
caring, curiosity,
feelings, respect,
responsibility, biology and health.
There are times when sickness and
danger can be from her sex, too.
Most kids wonder about and have
lots of questions about sex.
It's also perfectly normal
to want to know about sex.
You may wonder why it's a good idea
to learn some facts about bodies,
about growing up, about sex
and about sexual health.
It's important because these
facts can help you stay healthy,
take good care of yourself, and
make good decisions about yourself
as you are growing up and for the
rest of your life, besides learning
about these things can
be fascinating and fun.
So on to-- this was a change
in the chapter on straight,
gay, trans, bisexual, LBGT.
And this is just newer
art that was done.
And here are some texts.
Many people use the term LGBT, these
initials L for lesbian, G for gay,
B for bisexual, and T for
transgender, our way of referring
to people who are lesbian,
gay, bisexual, or transgender.
And then I give a definition
of transgender
which I'm not going
to go to now-- not.
I mean I'm happy to,
but we need to move on.
And then it goes on to the
end of the chapter to say
if a person has any questions
thought or concerns about his
or her sexual feeling or gender,
talking to someone you know
and trust, a parent, relative,
therapist, doctor, nurse, teacher,
or clergy member can be helpful.
No matter what some people may
think it's always important
for every person to remember and
treat all people with respect.
And it's important to know that a
person's daily life, making a home,
having friend and fun working
being in love, being single,
being a partner, being married,
raising children is mostly the same
whether he or she is straight, gay,
bisexual, or transgender.
OK. Oops. OK.
This, five years ago put it in
chapter, began about the internet.
Absolutely critical.
The chapter is "Become
Larger and Larger".
And Michael and I worked out
what-- I can't draw as I said.
But we work out what
we want the image to be
and then he does his brilliant work.
Once your words are on the
internet they're there forever
and you cannot get these words back.
Others who we do not want to see
these words may end up seeing them.
There is no way to guarantee what
you will have sent will be private.
And think about the
emotional implications.
And if you say online that someone
is fat or skinny or sexy or ugly
or beautiful or handsome.
What you said is never really
private once those words are
in the internet.
Saying-- And here we're talking
about the emotional health of kids.
Saying something mean or bullying
someone, or spreading any kind
of gossip, even sexy gossip or
about another person can make
that person feel really crummy
can hurt that person's feeling.
When someone does this online by
texting, posting, or e-mailing,
it called cyber bullying.
To cyber bully means to
mistreat another person.
Cyber bullying means
mistreating another person online,
to bully means to mistreat.
Cyber bullying means
doing it online.
And then here's just another
way to get information across.
And we certainly want to
pass these on the kids.
These are things that
were in the book.
Miss that I'm told.
Kids still think, right.
Here's a way to talk about that you
need a condom for protection, right?
And it's a smart thing to do.
So to call kids smart,
if you did this--
this is smart, something you can do.
OK. This was where they fit.
I think boys, men, as well as
women and girls, need to know this.
Sometimes people don't know it.
And this is just one piece
of contraception here.
And then this is what our look
like and I have a grandmother.
And this is the last chapter called
"Staying Healthy Responsible
Choices".
And I couldn't write this without
saying-- without ending like this.
Everyone makes mistakes and has
bad judgment once in a while.
I didn't want kids to think that,
you know, I am through the word
that I write saying, you know,
you don't have to do this,
and this, and this, and this.
I don't want to ask the audience
about what mistakes you may
have made during those years.
We won't do that.
And you probably will, too,
but most of the time you can
and will make responsible choices,
ones that are good for you,
right for you, and healthy
for you and your friends.
So that's-- it's perfectly normal.
OK. On to some of my-- here's
a quote I just want to post it.
And by the way, I've done
books that now go down to three
to five year olds on this topic.
One called "Who Has What?",
naming all the parts of the body.
Not just the wonderful song we
all love it, head, shoulders,
knees and toes but seems to me
maybe some parts are left out.
And the kids, too, they
know at a very young--
well, they don't immediately,
almost right, right, right,
infants, that's [inaudible].
So here's a quote from
Dr. Alicia Lieberman
and a gifted clinical
psychology at UCSF for the book--
for his quote I think it's the
emotional life of the toddler
about words young children and
about young children and I quote
"When a parent is able to
translate" and she says the infants
and toddlers and I have the
privilege of knowing Alicia.
And I talked to her about this.
I said, "How about children of all
ages are able to translate the words
of children of all--
able to translate children
of all ages experiences
in the words of understanding.
This helps contain the
child's negative feelings
and makes them bearable."
In this sense, this is her quote,
"Talking can represent relief
from amorphus feelings because
it puts some order into chaos."
I find these words "put order
into chaos" central to my writing
for children and particular writing
about the emotional
life of children.
I feel that children's books
can provide those words,
words that can help to
meliorate the perfectly normal
and terrifying feelings
that children often have.
And for most children can help make
fearful feelings bearable including
the traumas that we talked about.
And here, what I want to ask
you, it's OK to use R-O-A-R
and would Mayor Tom Menino of--
the late wonderful mayor of Boston.
So here's a little bit from
the incredible illustrator.
If you don't know his work, Chris
Raschka, he's a joy to work with.
So here we go.
OK. When lions roar
and monkeys screech,
when daddies yell,
when mommies holler.
There's a lot left out of here
of the pages of the [inaudible].
Chris understood that these
parents were not yelling
at the child as parents who yell.
And it's scary to hear a
child-- a parent out of control.
When daddies yell,
when mommies holler,
the scary is near,
the scary is here.
So I sit right down,
shut my eyes tight.
Go away I say, scary go away.
And then the quiet is back.
A flower blooms, an ant crawls by.
A mommy sings, a daddy dances.
The scary is gone,
and I go on my way.
Chris is brilliant [inaudible]
Nadine Bernard Wescott.
So I wanted to do a book on
healthy eating and nutrition.
And this is [inaudible]
Gus and Nelly
and their parents I
hope are in here.
This fall, here's another
initiative, somebody you may
or may not know about maybe you do.
First book and the Mario Batali
Foundation, he's the famous,
you know, New York City chef.
But I think in [inaudible] launched
their healthy kids collection.
And "What's So Yummy?"
was one of eight wonderful
books for young children
on healthy eating and exercise.
And it's perfectly [inaudible]
I'm proud to say was one of them.
And they did that as
their way of ensuring
that all children are well-read,
well-fed, and well-cared for
and to show kids the importance
of healthy eating and nutrition.
I'm just going to show
you a little bit on sugar.
I got a lot of help,
our wonderful people
over in the congress senator--
Congressman Rosa DeLauro on
the Agriculture Committee
which was chair, now I forget
when you're not ranking member now
of the Agriculture Committee,
put me together with a--
consulted on this book we talked
about sugar but also so many other.
It's fun to eat a sweet
like ice cream or a cookie
or a piece of cake, pie or candy.
Most sweets have a
lot of sugar in them.
But too much sugar is not good for
your teeth or the rest of your body.
So it's OK to eat some
sweet sometimes
but not too many and not too often.
And eating a sweet is almost
always a special treat
on birthdays and holidays.
Again, I don't want to put
the shame and guilt there.
And there's Gus, these cookies
are done, let's try one.
There's Nelly, these chocolate
chip cookies are so yummy it's time
to pack them all for our picnic.
And [inaudible] something, OK.
And there they are
and on their picnic.
And it's so it's fruits and
juices also have sugar in them.
A lot of fruit drinks and soda
even have more sugar added.
They have too much sugar in them.
So it's better for your body to eat
a piece of fruit and drink water
than have a drink of soda.
And there's a whole range of every
issue, water, you know, everything,
allergies, you got it in this book.
And here is my latest book which
is coming out again [inaudible],
which is coming out
two week-- a week.
And I wanted to thank
Ellen Oh again,
creator of "We Need Diverse Books"
for opening out the critical dialog
about children's book and diversity
and also the publishing world--
the children's publishing world.
They are doing a really fine job.
But we're working on all of
those of getting more people
in the publishing industry
who are people of color
and therefore more sensitivity of
the need for books that shows all
of us and what America
really looks like.
Michael Emberley and I am proud to
say did that and people stand up
and say thank you and we
don't know what to say.
We say, you know, it's just
what America looks like.
It's who we are.
Here we are with the title.
So this is Gus and Nelly again and
I actually sold this book way before
"We Need Diverse Books" began.
People say it and that
was fine, you know.
We just did it because of
"We Need Diverse Books".
But I applaud so much what they
are doing because children need
to find themselves not just
in the words but in the images
and it's kids of color
and as Libby said,
all of our kids need to find them.
So because it has to do with our
kids' emotional health, big time,
to find themselves, to validate
them and that you count, you matter.
And here's-- and I take on what
some people would call tough issues.
I talk about how you
talk to each other.
How a person walks or talks or
the clothes the person wears
or the color or shade
of their skin, hair,
or eyes can't tell you what
a person's really like.
These books are for 3s, 4s, 5s,
6s, and 7s, it's a big range.
The holidays a person celebrates
or the people in a person's family
or the food the person eats
can't tell you what a person's
really like.
That person may be a lot
like you in some ways
and different from
you in other ways.
You may have freckles,
another person may not.
That person may speak
Spanish, you may not.
You may use crutches wheelchair,
another person may not.
That person may like to sing, you
may like to tell jokes or both
of you may wear orange sneakers.
See if you can find two sets
of orange sneakers here,
or have the same backpacks--
see if you can find that--
or brown eyes or curly hair.
And then we spend weeks on end.
This is published by Candlewick
Press as with the books
in essential health
and "What's So Yummy?"
We spent ages just looking at the
diversity in this art which we did
with "It's Perfectly Normal".
And we have people of
everywhere looking at it and say,
you know, do we leave anybody out?
When you meet another kid for the
first time, you may want to play
with that person right away, or
you may not want to because he
or she is someone you have
never met or seen before.
You may feel furious or even
shy or nervous or surprise,
they're a little afraid of
someone you don't know yet
or who looks different from you.
Hey guys-- Hey, I'm Gus.
This jogger is so cool.
This juggler is so cool.
And if I go back just to
this one, now, he's saying,
"All I know about someone
new is what they look like."
And Gus says, "You may not even
know strawberry ice cream is their
favorite ice cream or chocolate."
If you do play with each other, you
might find out that something he
or she thinks is scarier
something you think is scarier.
You might find out that's something
you think is silly is something he
or she thinks is easily.
And before now-- know what
you're talking laughing
and having fun with each other.
It's possible, often happens.
Let's-- Bob you were talking
about the positive outcomes,
the resilience, but
the-- how kids see it.
So I really-- I did
a movie years ago.
Something with the
first Head Start--
one of the first Head Start
programs in the Nation of Filmes.
And we certainly talked
about these issues back then
and here we are still
needing to talk
about them today in this nation.
And I think particularly with what's
going on in our nation right now,
issues of race and diversity, our
young children feel it greatly.
And so if this is a way to talk,
maybe it'll help some families.
That's my hope.
So last book, published
by Scholastic.
Karen, you're from the
Scholastic, shout out to Scholastic
and [inaudible] was also
published at Scholastic
with my wonderful editor Ken Geist.
So, here's a story
about a pediatrician.
Many of you may know as the medical
director of Reach Out and Read is
that still Perri Klass's directly--
Perri Klass and the breakfast we
had together several years ago.
I have consulted with Perri
on many, many of my books.
And she would have been here today
but she's out of the country.
If she could have been
so she sends her best.
And Bob we want to give a shout
out to Reach Out and Read as one
of the founders in keeping it going.
And Brian Gallagher who's
here from Reach Out and Read.
At that breakfast Perri
asked me of Michael Emberley
and I would be willing to create a
new poster for Reach Out and Read
and we can go right to it.
Just sticking with this slide
it really take on all the issues
about diversity and I like
books that are a challenge,
but I think they're books that
I would have conversations.
My kids are grown up with now-- now.
But I would have had-- I did have
conversations with my kids about.
And as a grandparent I can
know what's happening today.
So, here we go, if we would do a
poster for Reach Out and Read--
so Perri and I were having breakfast
which was the way we mostly
meet talk about nutrition,
she also help with
"What's So Yummy?"
And I said, "Well, wait a
minute, why-- let's do a book.
Let me do a book."
And then I said, "I don't
want to do a book by comedia,
I want to do an actually
trade book,"
meaning that it would be a
book that I would do anyway
that will go into a bookstore.
But I will consult
with people on this
and this is a different
kind of take.
So I said,-- and I came up
with an idea at the table.
I have often come up with
an idea but then, oh my God,
you signed a contract and you have
to write it, none of this really.
So I-- so my immediate
response is why not a book?
It could be about a young child
who loses its favorite book
at the moment and can't
go to sleep without it.
I'd have that happened.
My kids have that happened.
And since this book came out I would
say 9 or 10 librarians have said
to me-- had librarians
at library say, you know,
I get to work at whatever time
I get to work, we open the door
and there are three or four people
maybe once a month, you know,
adults come in and say, I was just
reading x and I can't find the book
and do it and they're totally panic.
So it's not just kids.
OK. And so the book you love,
love, love, love the most it,
just to that moment, right,
because the next what you
love is coming up soon.
Before sleeping into bed
and you have to have is gone
and panic sets in,
"Maybe A Bear Ate It".
You know, maybe that's
what it happened.
I knew that Michael Emberley would
draw the most marvelous bear,
and he would say yes.
And luckily Scholastic published it.
Perri and I spoke the other day
about this book and we talked
about how picture book cannot
only help kids become literate
but as we talked about contributed
to even more kinds
of healthy outcomes.
Just for starters and "Maybe A
Bear Ate It", feeling that's OK
to be very upset over a loss.
And then I read a book
called "Goodbye Mousie"
which is a different loss
about a book about that--
a child who discovers
his mouse is dead.
He doesn't know it.
He thinks it's just sleeping.
But it's about death.
It's not about dying,
it's about death.
It's a picture for young
children over there.
Learning the bedtime routine such
as getting into bed with a book
and other bedtime routines is a
good thing and a sleep matters.
Giving a child a book
into a sense of agency,
the child in this book whose
character right here is--
you know, the child in this
book really does something
about finding his book.
So I can do that, too.
[Inaudible] I answer to such
questions as who did it?
Do you think a bear ate it?
Which can provide the
[inaudible] back and forth
between a bear and child?
Giving the chi-- giving the
children new vocabulary in the way
to understand the story, drift on
the story, you just read to them
and then make up their own
stories, or go onto another book
to ask questions to fantasize.
And as all of you to
spoken about so eloquently
to help parents have access
to information and kids.
So in the end books matter--
we're finishing up here to children
even more than we ever imagine
because they can be part of many
healthy outcomes for children
and children's families
and sharing a book
with a child can help
them become literate.
And I just wanted to say
thank you Sandra Hassink
for your [inaudible]
article, Literacy and Health.
It's a must read.
Sandra Hassink and Perri
are two of the co-authors.
It was really important
if you haven't read it.
I'm going to end by asking
you to pretend the right now,
you're about to hop on the bed and
maybe my talk is making you sleepy.
And if you can't find your
favorite book at the moment,
the book you love so much.
Well, here's a story about that that
I would love to read to you now.
This will take about one minute.
"Maybe A Bear Ate It".
Is it moving?
OK. So there we go.
You can read it.
Michael calls me up and he said,
"How could we do that this whale?"
And I said, "Well, that's the
way I'll, you know, swallowed."
But he could draw a shark and
terrible things really awful.
All these ridiculous
places there about be.
That's it.
>> John Cole: All right.
Robie thank you so much.
>> Robie Harris: Thank you.
>> John Cole: Good
afternoon everyone.
Time to stretch it again to try
to stay close to our schedule.
We're very pleased to have
some visitors this afternoon,
some students who are
interested in our--
the topic and we also have part
of the panels are still
meeting getting ready
for this afternoon's performance.
But we're going to start and this
was the special brief presentation I
told about where we are taking
a look at our overall topic
which is literacy and health and
how they relate or should relate
and taking another look at literacy,
health public policy project
of immediate concern and that is
the literacy in the Ebola crisis.
And we're fortunate to have a
speaker from the World Bank.
One of our board members Mike
Trucano is from the World Bank.
But Mike having a World
Bank member as a panel,
as a member of our advisory
board has great advantages.
But a disadvantage is he's
traveling a good deal of the time.
And he has asked and
Kaliope Azzi-Huck
who is a Senior Educations
Specialist
at the World Bank has agreed to
come and talk to us a little bit
and about literacy
in the Ebola crisis.
So let's give her a
little encouragement.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
You're all set.
>> Kaliope Azzi-Huck:
All right, great.
Thank you very much.
Hi everyone.
I promise I'd only talk
first about 10 minutes.
So I'm just going to
set myself a timer.
I'm Kali and I cover the education
portfolio for the World Bank.
I work on a number of countries
mostly slay throughout west
and central Africa
but I specifically cover
Sierra Leone portfolio
which is the one in question here.
So to delve right into it,
I just wanted to give you some
background on Sierra Leone.
It's nothing that you don't
know because it's been
in the news quite often
at the past year or so.
Small country, population
of 6 million
about 42% of people are literate.
So-- And that number-- sorry-- I
meant as high as 75 are not literate
in rural areas mostly women.
So they're out of school rate which
means kids who are still growing
up not literate is about
25% of school age children.
And their infant mortality
rate which given the subject
if today is relevant
it's about 117 in 1000.
In terms of human development impact
Sierra Leone has immense challenges.
It's ranked to 181st out
of a 188 countries in terms
of human development which means
social services, health education,
social protection are very, very
weak they don't have the systems
for it and they don't have
the infrastructure for it.
So when the Ebola hit in-- I think
it arrived in Sierra Leone in April
of 2014 and steadily climbed up.
Initially it covered the districts,
if you that bordered with Guinea
and Liberia and then it's spread.
And once it spread to the capital
Freetown then it just became an
immense problem and it just
climbed up and up as you know.
So the havoc that it unleashed is
on the population 14,000 people
were infected and about 4000 death.
I think just under that.
It faired a little better
than Guinea where, you know,
the death rate was much higher,
Guinea compared to the infection.
On the health I just wanted you
to give this fact it's a country
that already had weak
systems of 6 million people,
a 188 specialized doctors
and Ebola took 12 of them.
To give you an anecdote with
that did for the medical school,
the only one medical school in
Freetown is basically stopped it.
The doctors were also lecturers so
not only did you lose practitioners
but now you're losing a
generation of future practitioners.
So on the economy, the
GDP growth was cut by 50%.
I won't bore you with that
because it was obvious.
Everything came to a halt.
They were embarking on a
huge economic strategy,
iron ore was doing wells.
So they had invested
a lot in mining.
They had already had diamond mining
and the sector basically collapsed.
Two of the three major
companies packed up and went home
so people were left without jobs
and without any prospect for work.
On school children, for health
reasons schools were suppose
to start in September of
2014 and they did not.
And they remained closed
for eight months.
So children were left idle
and as a sort of aside element
of that teenage pregnancy
skyrocketed.
And this is something that we
as partners didn't know either
that a lot of young girls
actually are in school
and are de facto protected
from all these social issues.
It became an issue for these young
women who were at home, no income,
no sort of prospect of anything
and things became really,
really challenging.
So I'll talk about why
that became an issue
after school reopened
at the end of this.
And then on physical infrastructure
there just aren't roads.
So it's really difficult to get out
to people and to get the messages
out to people about what
needs to be done in order
to sort of combat the EVD.
So how the government responded?
There was a national curfew
that lasted for four months.
You basically would not
suppose to be out after 7
or 8 p.m. Restaurants
were not supposed
to be open unless you were a hotel
and therefore you needed
to feed your guest.
Traditional burial practices
were eventually outlawed
and initially there were discouraged
and then they basically said, "No,
so anyone passed away
you couldn't touch them.
You had to call."
And ambulances would come and
they would just take the body.
And it was regardless of how they
passed away they fell of the roof.
They-- You know, it didn't matter.
And you would then wait
for a call from someone
to say this body is cleared
and you can now bury it.
Or oftentimes they would just
bury it and give you a name
and said we'll deal with it later.
And that's what we're
dealing with now is a lot
of tribes have very unique
burial traditions and they have
to get the bodies back in order
to rebury them essentially.
So it's a matter or figuring
out what needs to be done there.
There was intense collaboration
among partners and government.
I think unique to the situation was
that there weren't a lot of people
in Sierra Leone to begin with.
So there were only four
of five donor partners
that were already engaged.
So we all kind of worked together.
The funds that were provided funded
medical supplies, that's obvious,
food to quarantined
communities, medical staff,
and local health workers' salaries.
Because UNICEF was on the
ground, UNICEF took the lead
in the implementation and the
coordination and the World Bank
and [inaudible] and
others basically we work
through them and with
the government.
So overcoming the crisis
given the lack of literacy
in the country, we used radios.
We procured radios, used radio
messages, used television messages.
We hosted talk shows.
Produced jingles anything that
would get the message out.
This-- Some of you may know this.
But your cellphones
in other countries,
actually all other countries except
the US has a radio transmitter.
So we were able to get out
to people with radio messages
as long they had a cellphone.
We also bought as donor partners
about 80,000 radios for household
that mostly for the rural areas.
We also brought CAST lessons.
And in those lessons it was
the core subjects as well
as psychosocial messages about
Ebola, about five times a week.
And these lessons ran
sort of on the hour
because the government wanted
the kids to get as much education
as they could during the closure.
So they initially had said,
"You will still be required
for to complete the academic year."
We also use image-based
media campaigns.
I think you've seen
these on the internet.
So instead of saying if you have
symptoms of vomiting or diarrhea,
we actually had cartoon images of
someone vomiting and the diarrhea.
And that was the most effective way
to get the message out especially
to those who couldn't read.
We used the communities.
There's a lot of social
mobilizations.
So basically it was the
trickle down effect.
We used the paramount chiefs.
It's a country of 149 chiefdoms.
So all of them came to town and
these are the elected official
so to speak but also
traditional leaders.
So they can read and write.
They came to Freetown and there
were workshops that they attended
and then they would go back and
carry up community mobilization.
And so that when that seem to be
only some what successful and it was
in December I believe and the
numbers were still climbing.
The government took
a drastic measure
of doing this [foreign language].
It's basically House-to-House
Ebola Talk.
And there was a national quarantine
where everyone was to stay home
for three days unless you were one
of the volunteers that were moving.
We used a lot of youth and they went
house-to-house with two objectives.
One was to identify if you
had sick people in the house
and bring them to treatment centers.
And two was to communicate
the message about Ebola.
And this I think was the
most affective way to do it.
It was a lot of manpower
and it was drastic.
But it seemed to then work
because the numbers began
to go down after that.
There was diligent contact tracing.
So as soon as someone was
discovered to be ill a team
of contact tracers would
go out into the community.
The community would
have to be quarantine,
so one of the major investments
that the donor partners did
was food for these communities.
I think you heard a lot of--
and at least we heard a
lot of anecdotal stories
about people trying to escape simply
because they had run out of food
and they needed to get out.
So, with these contact
tracers, there's also a lot
of messaging that was involved.
And then there was a dedicated
hotline that was involved.
If you suspect someone of
having Ebola or being sick
or if someone dies
there were hotlines.
And the hotlines were
well-funded and well sort
of oiled to move very fast.
So coming-- sorry.
So coming out of the Ebola crisis
because education is my background
so I could speak to you about
what we did to reopen schools.
One of the major concerns
was the safety of children.
Given the infrastructure and the
fact that children share everything
in the classroom including seats
and you have four to five seating
to a seat and Ebola is transmitted
by touch, all you needed was
for one kid to transmit it to
potentially an entire classroom.
So, there were working
groups established
that focused on everything.
There were protocols
that were developed
and received certification from WHO.
And then we implemented a system
of distributing wash buckets.
I don't know if I have-- somewhere
in here I have the photo of it.
It's basically a plastic
bucket with a little spigot
at the bottom that's
fused into another bucket
and you put a little
bleach and soap in it.
And every child have to wash
their hands coming into school.
We also procured tons
and tons of thermometers.
Every school received at least two
thermometers for 50 kid and then
for every other 50 kids I think
an addition of thermometer.
And kids had to be
tested every morning.
Communities, not the schools,
were tasked with recording
that a school is ready to be opened.
So we used social mobilization.
And if a community felt that school
was not cleaned it was not open,
they would report it
back to the ministry
and then we would engage the-- so
the Ministry of Health to make sure
that it gets cleaned
because the Ministry
of Health took care of
cleaning the schools.
We also used the radio to inform
parents that schools are safe
to reopen that they are
being sanitized the--
their children will
be ensured safety
that there are measures in place.
And then we trained at
least one teacher per school
to understand how to
deal with Ebola.
The reason I wanted to put to
say that we covered psychosocial
and technical areas is we wanted to
make sure that if a child is found
to just have a fever that they are
not stigmatize it's very likely they
have just put out in the field in
the sun until their parents came.
So, we wanted to make it understood
that there is a lot of compassion
that was necessary
given what was going on.
OK. What we did not do.
We did not evacuate
our international staff
and that helped significantly
because we still have the manpower.
On the bank side we did not
require the staff travel there
if they did not feel comfortable.
But if they were able to, everyone
was coming and going regularly.
We did not establish
isolation rooms in schools.
And this was important
because as we went
to reopen schools the government
received 4000 mattresses
that they wanted to put in schools
and the decision in the end was
that you can't build mini
treatment centers in these schools
and you can't give the impression
that this can be taken care
of at the school levels.
Someone who is expected
of having Ebola needs
to come off the premises
as quickly as possible.
We didn't open schools that have
been used as holding centers prior
to WHO certified sanitation
this was obvious.
So we need the Ministry of Health
to clean it and then someone
to say this is OK because
there was a lot of--
there was a lot more diligence than
just cleaning up of that school.
We didn't taking unisexual approach
and this is often what happens.
So I can only think about education.
In this case, we figured out
that health needs to step in.
Social protection, the Ministry of
Youth needs to provide the manpower
and education needs to come up with
the plan and deliver information.
We did not address the issue
pregnant girls from the start.
We knew that the pregnancies were
rising and as schools were announce
to be reopened on April
14th, the ministry announced
that pregnant girls could
not return to school
and they could not take the exams.
And the reasoning was that they
would give the wrong lesson
or there would be wrong role models
for the other girls in schools.
The donor partners and many felt
that this was punishing the girls
twice once for getting pregnant
and once for now losing out
on potentially education.
There was a lot of back and forth
and in the end what we now have is
a program for the pregnant girls
and those who gave birth
in the last eight month
to do alternative education.
And once they have their child and
they can catch up they can return
to school assuming that they have
not following too far behind.
It's a reasonable kind
of catch up effort.
But I think if we had
dealt with it early
on this wouldn't have been a bigger
issue now nine months down the road.
And that's the extent
of my presentation.
I put in some pictures that
you can see of the students
and the wash buckets that were--
students having their temperature
taken and the wash buckets.
OK. So that was 15 minutes.
[ Applause ]
>> John Cole: Kali
thank you very much.
This is insightful and
interesting and brings us kind
of into a different part of the
subjects and we appreciate it.
We have to move on to try to keep
up on our schedules so I'm going
to have Jeff come up and bring
his panel and we will get started.
And give Mike our best as well.
And our chair is Jeff Carter
whom many of you know.
Jeff is been deeply involve
in all aspects of literacy
but especially adult literacy
and he is the Executive Director
of the National Adult Education
Professional Development Consortium
and the National Council of State
Directors of Adult Education.
I know him best and he
had another role of his
and that is he is currently
president of the National Coalition
for Literacy, which is one of
the Center for the Books' reading
and literacy promotion partners.
So we've come full circle and
I'm turning it over to Jeff.
>> Jeff Carter: Thank you John.
Thank you John.
And thank you everyone
for coming out today.
This has been an incredibly
stimulating half-day so far.
I'm looking forward to
second half of the day.
As John mentioned I
have several titles.
If you work-- I said this
is to someone earlier.
If you work in adult literacy you
have usually have two or three jobs.
You know maybe a couple to pay you
and several volunteer
jobs at the same time.
I just want to sort
of set this panel up.
We're going to be talking
about adult literacy
and health during this panel.
And I thought it might be helpful
to just give you very briefly of--
some review of the
landscape of adult literacy
in this country right now.
Many of you I hope everyone actually
would find it shocking to know
that according to the
latest data that we have
from an international survey
conducted by OECD a few years ago,
they estimate that
approximately 36 million adults
in the United States have
low literacy or math skills.
Our federal system of adult
education talk a little bit what
that looks like serves
about 1.5 million people.
And in that survey that OECD
conducted, they ask people,
"Would you like to attend
an adult education class?"
And they estimated as much as
3 million people would love
to attend an adult education
but cannot access one.
There isn't one where they are.
And that probably is just--
that's probably a very undercount
of the actual demand
for these services.
So, that's the landscape
that we work in.
Let me tell you a little bit about
the kinds of programs that work
with adults and adult literacy.
They range from community-based
organizations,
volunteer-based organizations,
faith-based organizations,
schools including charter
schools and community colleges.
So it's a system that a lot
of people are not as familiar
with just compared to K through 12
or higher education because it is
so diverse and many of our
students of course are--
they come for all kinds of different
backgrounds and they're not
as easily identifiable or as visible
as in our other educational sectors.
I want to talk briefly about
why I think a discussion
around adult literacy and
health is so important in this--
in the context of our day-to-day.
And I was thinking about
this as I was listening
to the speakers this morning.
And one of the first statistics
that was mentioned earlier
was this issue that--
and, again, talking about
another staggering number that 48%
of our children are growing
up in low-income households.
So why are adults critical there?
Well, educational attainment
is directly correlated
with earnings power.
So when we educate our adults we
effectively can address the issue
of children growing in
low-income situations
because we empower those adults to
earn more and raise their incomes.
So that's one factor.
Of course, the other one,
parents are a critical influence
on a child literacy development.
And frankly, if we are going to
make a significant impact in terms
of health outcomes as we look at
the connection between literacy
and health, we can't ignore those.
There're too many of them, as
I mentioned 36 million adults.
If we put all our energy just in
the children we would disappointed
by the outcomes because we would
not be addressing the needs
of those 36 million adults.
And then lastly, and this has
been touched on a little bit,
I'm really glad to hear it.
I think we have moral
responsibility.
One thing that's really important
to remember about a lot of adults
who find themselves in the situation
is that that's related to factors
that have-- that are related
to issues about inequality
and historical vestiges
of discrimination.
Robert Needleman mentioned this.
This is a very strange
coincidence I hadn't thought about.
You mentioned how Reach Out and
Read had to change their acronym
because it was being used by an
organization that was protesting
in Boston during the
Boston crisis, ROAR.
I didn't thought about that
in years, I grew up in Boston.
And it mainly reflect the
first time I got involve
with adult literacy,
I was this tutor.
And I tutored a guy who was
every bit as smart as I was.
Everybody is engage and
curious and hard working--
probably more hardworking
than I was.
The difference between me and
him is that he grew in the city
that was practicing systematic
discrimination for people of color
and he did not receive
an adequate education.
And that's why he ended
up where he was.
So I've mention because I think
social justice and in equalities
and important part of this
discussion and I was glad
to hear some people touch on it
today and I think that's something
to think about as we
continue the discussion.
That said, I like to introduce
my panel, my esteemed panel.
To my left Robert Logan is
a member of the senior staff
of the US National Library of
Medicine and a professor emeritus
at the University of Missouri
Columbia School of Journalism.
I'm always worried but-- when
seniors staff I think that's--
I was weary of those title
because it makes you sound
old but you're not old, see.
>> Robert Logan: I
agree [inaudible].
>> Jeff Carter: Well.
To Steve's left-- I'm sorry.
To Robert's left is Steven Rush,
the Director of the
United Health Group--
Health Literacy Innovations
Program an enterprise-wide program
to help consumers understand and use
health and wellness communications,
and the former Director
of Physician Engagement
at UnitedHealthcare Health Service.
To his left, Michele Erikson,
is the Executive Director
of Wisconsin Literacy
which supports, develops,
and advocate for literacy
organizations
across the state of Wisconsin.
Her work with Wisconsin Literacy has
focused on health literacy and ways
to improve health outcome
and reduce health care cause
by educating both providers
and patients
on more effective ways
to communicate.
And we're going to
start with Robert Logan.
And we're sort of organized this is
that Robert is going give us the
10,000 foot, look at this issue.
And then we're going to have Steve
give us the 1000 foot issue--
foot perspective.
And then when we get to Michele,
she's going to give us the
perspective from the ground.
So with that said take
it away Robert.
>> Robert Logan: Thank you Jeff.
Thank you Jeff.
And I appreciate the
opportunity to be here.
Our lawyers say we
have to say in public.
We speak for ourselves.
We don't speak for the
National Institute of Health.
National Library of Medicine.
And I don't speak for the
US Department of Health
in Human Services either.
Or I also don't speak
for the National Academy
in Medicine Health Literacy
Roundtable that Steve
and I are very active in.
Steve I guess you could speak
for it if you wanted to.
I'm also the editor
of the first book
on comprehensive health
literacy international research
that I hope will be
publish in about 18 months.
And before I go on, thank you
Dr. Sullivan for your leadership.
The National Library of Medicine
would not be what its today had you
not been at the US Department
of Health and Human Services
at the time you were there.
Very nice to see you as always.
Let's-- This is the front entrance
of the National Library of Medicine.
Walk 9 miles that way
and you'll get there.
OK. It's part of the NIH campus.
Look at our unambitious mission.
That's a joke at the
bottom in the page.
NLM is PubMed.
OK. It's all I have to say.
I mean that's what we--
need more-- more I have to.
If you don't need-- If you
don't know what PubMed,
quietly don't let Dr.
Sullivan know that, OK.
And that we're also the
publisher of MedlinePlus.
Something that Dr. Sullivan
has been a long advocate of.
MedlinePlus is it trying to
provide health information
down to the level of consumer.
I'm not going to show that today.
But nevertheless, that is--
if you're not familiar with
that website all of you
who are interested
in those go there.
Please don't tell me that there
are not efforts to explain health
and medicine in a broad
comprehensive scale
in American public.
There are and they've been
there for about 20 years.
By the way, if you to MedlinePlus,
you'll see a lots of
links to Nemours.
In many of MedlinePlus sites
we link on various issues
to websites that Nemours has.
I'm going to talk briefly about
one topic how health literacy--
adult health literacy
differs from adult literacy
and educational attainment.
The second topic I would-- I've
decided, for the purpose of time
to discuss during the Q&A assuming
that Jeff ask me the right question.
On--
>> Jeff Carter: I might
surprise you.
>> Robert Logan: Who knows?
>> Jeff Carter: They
trusted me way too much.
>> Robert Logan: On the screen
is the Calgary charter definition
of health literacy.
As you read and I'm not
going to read for you.
As you read it, remember this,
that every single word you see
is the most expensive real estate
imaginable, OK.
People fought over
every syllable on this
for months before it was
actually published in 2012.
There are more than 50
definitions of health literacy.
This is just one.
But this is the only
one I know that was done
by interdisciplinary consensus
of people from around the world,
which is why I have
it up in the screen.
Here's my wonderful friend Ceci Doak
who was the pioneer
of health literacy.
This was taken several months ago.
Ceci and Len Doaks were health--
adult health educators in the 1970s.
And they discovered there was
surprisingly little research
about how to best explain
health and medicine to patients.
So they decided to
dedicate their career
to professionalizing adult health
literacy health education, research,
and practice which they later
named "health literacy."
They coined the term.
Here's some of the Doaks'
discoveries in the 1970s.
First, person with
below 8th grade reading
and other literacy skills
rarely understood health
and medical information.
So low adult education attainment
they believe was associated
with low adult literacy.
Low educational attainment and low
adult literacy also were associated
with less understanding
of health materials
and also health information
seeking, which is just as important.
The Doaks' other discoveries
in the 1970s that medical
and health information
were not presented.
So they could be read
by low literate person.
For example, the term
"avoid" the term
"prevention" alone were
meaningless to most
of the people that they used.
If you'd put the word "PRE"
that [inaudible] any word
immediately they said they argued
about two-thirds in the American
republic have no idea what you're
talking about.
To stop-- just think about
that right there, OK.
Medical jargon was an
obvious, very understanding.
Here's just three examples.
I'm sure we can come up with
several hundred among us, OK.
Routine medical jargon which was
well-intended was significant
barrier to understanding.
And they argue that clinical
materials need to better-matched
to patient's skills, something
that we still very much believe.
And they began--
planned intervention to
match materials with skills.
In the 1980s after
several years of many years
of practice the Doaks hit
an interesting confound
that well-educated literate adults,
I said well-educated literate adults
and young person, often
did not understand health
and medical term either.
Often they had as little interest
in learning or discovering how
to seek health information
as low literate persons.
They conclude the association among
educational attainment literacy
and understanding of an interest
in health maybe one directional,
which was the first time
that was even postulated.
Yes, low educational attainment was
associated with low adult literacy
and less understanding
of health and interest
in health information seeking.
Yes, higher health education--
educational attainment was
associated with higher literacy.
However, and here's the key point,
higher educational attainment
and higher adult literacy were
not consistently associated
with more understanding in
health and more interest
in health informations seeking.
And that was jarring to
this day, OK, hypothesis.
The confound.
Why are the associations
not bidirectional.
This troubled the Doaks at first.
For years they try to explain it.
And then they began to
notice that it helped explain
that this information
and this information
about vaccines, for example.
This is one example among
very well-educated Americans.
That's the only way you
could possibly explain.
Then they begin to-- say, the
confound also provided insights
such as why English is second
language adult learners often are
helped by using health materials.
While other adult learners,
people who speak English
well are not helped
by using health materials.
Again, they couldn't explain
that until they begin to realize
that the-- what they assumed
all along wasn't not necessarily
the case.
Soon, OK, the Doaks started to
use the term health literacy
to describe the underlying
dynamics they were experiencing.
In the 1990s, the Doaks argued
as a dynamic of personal learning
and constructive interventions.
Adult health literacy might be
independent of adult literacy.
They began to argue for
the first time that we need
to assess health literacy on
its own merits on its own terms
as an independent research
construct.
And intervene with strategies
to impact literacy as well
as strategies to impact
health literacy.
Not to one or the other but to both.
Twenty-first century research, which
is now abundant, suggests strongly
that the Doaks' observations
are correct.
Health literacy is apparently
an independent dynamic,
at least the evidence
strongly suggests it,
that should be assessed separately
from educational attainment
in adult literacy.
Health literacy is an independent
research construct that's separate
from adult literacy and
educational attainment.
While health literacy
and literacy are similar
and are highly complementary,
there are times when they diverged
from each other and
they can be different.
The National Assessment
of Adult Literacy
and other findings
confirmed about in 2003.
It is important to respect
some inconsistencies and think
in terms of dual strategies.
Work on both literacy and
health literacy simultaneously.
Here are some current health
literacy research issues.
There less about acknowledging
the differences
between literacy and
health literacy.
I think that era is
basically over now.
And most people instead focus on
health literacy and health outcomes.
Health literacy and the utilization
of the health care delivery system.
And briefly, here a few findings
some of clinical benefits
that have been link to health
literacy interventions include
reduce mortality, improved patient
adherence to medical instruction
and overall patient safety.
The health literacy interventions
can therapeutically assist patients
with cancer, diabetes,
asthma, and hypertension
and at least 11 other diseases.
The specific health
administrative benefits link
to health literacy interventions,
again, these were all--
I'm just making it trying to--
a lot of research more than
60 papers in a few moments.
Some of the health
administrative benefits link
to health literacy
interventions include;
improved diabetes patient
self-management skills,
much more use of preventive
services,
as well as a significant
reduction in hospitalization
and rehospitalization rates.
As Dr. Sullivan knows well,
the letter has a direct impact
on the cost of health care.
Here's a glimpse of why it is an
absolutely fastening time to be
in health literacy
research or practice.
Health literacy interests
cover the waterfront.
They include all the various
stakeholders you've seen
on the screen.
The interests is well
outside the United States.
There's very active health
literacy research now
and several other countries here,
four prominent ones on the screen.
Michele and I will be on a
conference call, I think,
it's a week from Tuesday,
where there'd be at least six
or seven other people from around
the world on and it's normal.
Health literacy-- The roundtable
of the National Academies actively
takes a leadership role in this area
and has for now for 11 years.
Here is their website.
Sorry. It's long.
And I'm afraid-- I'm embarrass to
tell you they're about to change it.
>> Steven Rush: They
changed it yesterday.
>> Roger Logan: Thank you Steve.
You can follow the field's
progress, of course,
in PubMed or medlineplus.gov.
Here are three resources
to cover the field.
The first is how you cover the
PubMed with the special curated area
that does nothing but
provide articles-- excuse me--
referee journal publications
about health literacy.
Here's MedlinePlus' health literacy
page, which for those of you
who are not a health care
practitioner, I encourage you to go.
They'll make much more sense to you.
And finally, there's an excellent
resource which we have nothing to do
with in Harvard University
about resources.
And the reason I put that one on
the screen among many is that--
this particular one specializes in
health literacy and adult education.
I went through my references
really fast, but that in--
that I certainly have them and
I thank you for your touch.
[ Applause ]
Thank you.
>> Steven Rush: Thanks.
>> Robert Logan: Yup.
>> Steven Rush: So, I'm Steve
Rush and I'm the Director
of the Health Literacy Innovations
Program at UnitedHealth Group
and you'd said, "Why is a
health insurer interested
in health literacy?"
And in the next few
minutes I'll let you know.
I don't want to-- out of the bed.
Let me just to ask a question.
How many of you have
been faced with decisions
about buying insurance
or using health care?
How many of you know what your
certificate of coverage says
about getting a ride to the
hospital in an ambulance.
Nope. How many of you truly
understand everything your physician
has told you?
Guess what?
We all have low health literacy.
Low health literacy
we've talked about it
and it is really interesting.
People have talked about
health literacy last night.
Dr. Bailey talked about it.
This morning we've talked about it.
And I wanted to share with you that
health literacy is not a trait.
It's a state.
It changes.
And I'd like to thank the
Library of Congress and Nemours
for inviting me here today
to talk a little about that.
This morning Dr. Needleman
talked about bookkeeping
and basically talked
about downstream costs.
And I'll be addressing
that in a minute.
But what I wanted to tell
you was that Health Literacy
at UnitedHealth Group really
began about seven years ago.
And Dr. Migliori who's shown here
is really a very big proponent
of that at UnitedHealth Group.
We have the "Just Plain
Clear Communications" program
where we're attempting to
create health communications
that are simple, accessible,
understandable, and actionable.
So, why is health literacy
important?
We've talked about it a little bit.
We all know that health
literacy is transient
and people have difficulty
understanding and using health care.
And in today's health
care environment more
and more responsibility
for utilization
of health care is being put
on the consumer, the patient.
And it's difficult.
It's really difficult to
understand all the intricacies.
We've talked a little
bit about people
with low health literacy having a
greater risk of hospitalization.
At the cost of the health
care system using 2005,
2004 data was up to
$238 billion a year.
I think it's more upwards
of $240 billion a year.
And we do know and Rob
just talked about it
that health literacy is related
to medication and treatment errors
and medication adherence and ability
to follow treatment recommendations.
Health literacy by the numbers.
It's a minimum of 77 million
adults in the United States have--
don't have basic literacy skills.
From a payer standpoint the average
medical cost per year of a person
with higher health
literacy is about $3000,
while the average cost
per year of a person
with lower health literacy
is $13,000.
That's a different of about 433%.
We did some research and we
found that taking the look
at people utilizing health care
within a low literacy community
versus the higher health
literacy community,
the difference was amazing in
terms of unavoidable admissions
to the hospital, utilization
of the emergency room,
following treatment recommendations.
The average reading level for a lot
of health insurance documents is--
was at about 10th grade,
10th grade wow.
We have states that are requiring
health information to be written
at the third grade level.
Most state require people to
have written communications
about the sixth grade level.
And realistically not choosing
and using health care is
really very difficult.
The Patient Protection Affordable
Care Act defined health literacy
in the law and it's
been talked about here.
But people in the health
literacy community talked
about that definition is not
being quite enough because--
just because you make a decision
doesn't mean you're actually able
to take that decision
and then actually use it,
take put it into action.
I like the definition that Rima
Rudd, one of our colleagues talks
about and she says that "Health
literacy happens when anyone
on the receiving end of health
communications and anyone
on the giving end of health
communications truly understand
one another."
There's no blame here.
Early health literacy
were blamed the person.
You have low health
literacy, you're dumb,
you don't know what's you're doing.
No; it's an equal bidirectional
responsibility.
So we-- and I did help fill
that health communication
should be simple, accessible,
understandable, and actionable.
So why is there a health
focus on health literacy other
than all the cost while the Patient
Protection Affordable Care Act 2010
defined health literacy in
the law for the 1st time.
And then they're followed
federal rules and guidelines
and now accrediting organization and
quality organization are demanding
that health literacy be a
component of the way people
in the health community do business.
State agencies are mandating that
literacy level to be put into play.
Customers, people who are paying
for health insurance, CMS,
and larger corporations
even the employer--
other employers are saying you got--
give information to our employees
that are simple, accessible,
understandable, and actionable.
And consumers remember
this, say it too.
And there's that gentleman in
the lower right hand corner.
And most of all providing
information that's simple,
accessible, understandable and
actionable is the right thing to do.
So why is there-- what's the linkage
from health literacy
to health outcomes?
You'll notice that
reading isn't there.
But that's something that is--
that I point out because reading is
in fact a very important segments
but so as race and ethnicity, again,
language, and age, vision, hearing,
verbal ability, memory
and reasoning.
And one of the things that I
did when I was talking to one
of our leaders was to say,
"Hey, look at this over here."
And he said, "I didn't know
that vision and hearing
and verbal ability,
reasoning was in there."
"Oh, yeah, it is."
But take a look at how health
literacy impacts how people choosing
to use health care, take a look at
how health literacy is important
for that provider, health care
provider and patient interaction.
And if people can't understand
how is it that they're supposed
to be able to take
care of themselves?
The many, many-- Today's health
care environment really focuses
to a greater extent than in the
past on chronic care conditions,
diabetes, heart, asthma,
other pulmonary problems.
The day-to-day care that needs to
be done for that person is provide
by that person or their personal
caregivers, 95% of all chronic care
on a daily basis is
provided by that person
or their personal caregiver, 95%.
So Kathleen Sebelius at one point
said, "If people can't understand,
they can't decide,
and they can't do."
And that's-- that's what shown here.
There are number of factors
affecting health literacy,
one is the general literacy
level of the people,
experience with the health
care system, physical
and psychological factors,
culture and language, aging,
complexity in information.
And my God, I can tell you that
health insurance information
and health care information
is so complex.
I wish I could say
that I had a full head
of brown hair before I started
working in the insurance company.
But I can't do that.
Learning style is really important
and how information is communicated.
So reading is really important
so as listening and math,
math is really becoming a very
important factor, speaking,
writhing, thinking, health care
problem solving, health literacy,
think health care problem
solving and remembering.
And if these skills doesn't need to
be put into consideration to think
about what member does,
or a patient does
and then the health care system.
So here's some startling facts.
$240 billion a year in
medical cost are associated
with low health literacy.
Recent research showed that 4
in 10 uninsured don't know
basic health insurance terms.
Wow. Yet these people are going to
be responsible for the medical spend
and fewer than 4 in 10 understand
complex coverage concepts.
This is an amazing fact.
Millennial may have--
maybe the best educated.
But they have huge
gaps in their care.
And choosing and using health
insurance creates cognitive burden.
But the other piece
to that is many people
over estimate their
knowledge of health insurance.
Three out four people
say, "Hey, I can do this.
I know this stuff."
But when push came to shove,
only one in five really
demonstrated the capability.
So what does that mean
in terms of literacy?
So Jeff talked about PIAA that
was the International Program the
Assessment of Adult Literacy.
Three components to it,
understanding written communication,
working with numbers,
and then using computers
for health problem solving.
Take a look at where the US is
relative to 24 or 20 countries.
What does that mean for literacy?
US is tied for 7th
lowest of 24 countries.
We're 3rd from the bottom in math
skills and we're 3rd from the bottom
in 20 countries when it
come to using computers
for problem solving,
very interesting stuff.
What's the implication?
Health communications
and learning style.
We did some research and we found
that in a general population of 18
to 49-- to 64 years old,
60% were visual learners--
60% were visual learners, 15% were
auditory learners, and 25% mixed.
Take a look at what
happens when people aged.
It's really different.
So that's-- I'd like you
think about cognitive burden.
Cognitive burden has two parts.
One is the burden of illness.
Boy there's a lot stuff
that you have
to remember when you're a diabetic.
And it changes the way
you live your life.
And then there is the
burden of treatment.
When I wok with our telephonic
pharmacist training them
to communicate in simple
understandable and actionable ways.
I say, "To what extent are you
adding to the burden of treatment
when you use terms like"--
you-- there's a medic--
we have a medical class
or a medication class
called angio tension,
beta blah, blah, blah, blah.
And they go.
I was just put on the medication
and than I could barely say it.
So health literacy another look,
I really like this cognitive
burden piece on the left hand side.
Basically it says, "When you load
my brain up with confusing choices,
ambiguous phrases,
unparasable sentences,
you impose a cognitive burden.
You make me think, and
not about your subject.
You are making me translate,
transform, interpret what you say.
And this distracts
me from your point."
And then there's always George
Bernard Shaw with his statement
about the illusion that
communication has taken place.
I want to share with you a
resource that we've created.
It's free.
It's done as a social responsibility
and that's the just plain
clear English-Spanish glossary.
No one will call up and say,
"Hey, you use our glossary.
You want to buy our insurance?"
No-- That's not what it is.
What we've done is taken over
3400 complex health insurance,
healthcare terms and other
terms, and put them more simpler,
understandable language and we
cross walk that with complex banish
and complex and more
understandable Spanish.
And we're going through a redesign
right now where we're going to hook
up into images and
to movies and PDFs.
The just plain clear
www.justplainclear.com,
we've use this with
English as a second language
with adult basic education
programs and because it's
on our responsive platform
you can open it up.
And when you're seeing the patient
and you can't remember the English
or Spanish term you can look
it up and it really does work.
Thank you.
I appreciate your time.
[ Applause ]
>>Michele Erikson: So--
Good afternoon.
My name is Michele Erikson.
I have been involved in adult
literacy for quite a while,
longer than I'd like to admit.
But about 30 years now.
I started in adult literacy
just of out of college.
I got a call from the Boyd Public
Library asking me for money.
And I said I have two college loans.
I have no money.
But I probably could help someone.
I've been in the library
and saw advertisement
to become a literacy tutor.
I thought I might be
able to do that.
And so I went to the training
and met my first student, Bill.
Bill was a 39-year-old
father of a 9-year-old.
And Bill did not know
that names of the letters
or the sounds that they made.
And he just got-- he just been
laid off from his job as a welder.
And we started-- We are going
to meet at the public library
and he told me we could
sit outside in the bench
but he would not go in the library.
There are far too many books for him
to feel comfortable in a library.
So we sit outside in the bench
and we talked awhile and started
to meet at his kitchen table.
Not long after we were meeting
and some trust was built he shared
with me a letter that he had in a
drawer for about two and half years.
It was from the DMV and the letter
told him what he needed to do
to get his drivers license back.
It had been revoked.
And neither he nor his wife could
read the letter nor did they want
anyone else to know they
couldn't read the letters.
So there it sat.
I was thinking about that.
I'm really glad it wasn't a letter
from a doctor telling him what
he needed to do to take care
of his health or his
family's health.
So we started working toward
getting Bill his driver's license
and moved on from there.
But that's how I got
involved in this.
And it just stuck with
me ever since.
I did not realize as a college
student there were adults
that didn't read and write.
It just never ever occurred to me.
So I find myself at
Wisconsin Literacy.
I started there in 2005 and been
working a lot and health literacy.
We're a coalition, a statewide
coalition of 78 agencies
that provide direct
support for adult learners.
And we-- what we do is provide
the capacity building and training
for those agencies, to help them
train more volunteer tutors.
We work also as an advocacy agency.
We worked around workforce
development.
So we're helping our agencies
prepare their adult learners
for the workforce and
job readiness skills.
And then our biggest division is--
area we're working is called
Wisconsin Health Literacy.
It's a division of itself under
our Wisconsin Literacy, Inc.
umbrella and it has its own
website and has really been working
in this field since about 2003.
A lot of growth since 2003.
We have services that we provide.
We do a summit every other year.
We have one coming up in April 17.
And these have become larger
and more comprehensive.
Now, there are national summits
and we've had international
guests as well.
And it's a wonderful opportunity to
bring health and education together
under one roof and we spend
about two and a half days
and we learned a lot about
the things that are going
on in our country and
in other countries
as well around health literacy.
We do a lot of awareness building.
We started out just educating our
state about what health literacy was
and it's impacts and implications,
we do a lot of community
health projects
where we go into community agencies.
Primarily, we started with
our literacy agencies.
But now we've now we've branched out
to a lot of social service agencies
that are serving vulnerable
populations
and do community health projects.
And then on the other side of this,
we worked with providers and a lot
of education and training,
how to speak plain language.
As you-- the definition that Rob
provide in the Calgary charter talks
about the communication
piece of health literacy
and it really is a two-way street.
It's really important that when
providers are communicating
that they understand how to
communicate in health literate ways.
And so we work on training
along those lines.
So, again, you get to learn
this over and over when--
it's a repetition this
morning is one way to.
So you've seen this but 90 million
Americans trouble understanding
and I think that is really
important to remember.
There's just so many areas in this
field from insurance to, you know,
taking your medicine at home that
are impacted by health literacy.
So I wanted to focus, just
on one of our projects.
We do many different
projects out in the community.
But the one I'm going to
talk about today is called
"Let's Talk about Medicines."
It's actually-- We had one--
Before this we worked on called
"Let's Talk about the Flu."
So these are community projects
that are funded by, this one,
by Security Health Plan
and Insurance Company
in our northern part of the state.
And we looked to agencies where we
can go out and provide information
in a health literate manner at a
level that everyone can understand.
These call-- or this project we
started out working with seniors
because seniors are utmost at
risk for health literate behaviors
that can have great consequences.
They take more medicines and
other things that are happening
at that time affect this.
So we've gone from seniors and
I'll talk a little bit later.
We're now working with refugees
with the same project on medic--
Let's Talk about Medicine.
So these are the goals
of the project really understanding
what a medication label looks like,
the dosage, special instructions,
feeling comfortable talking
to your pharmacist, remembering how
to take your medicine
and where to store them.
We usually do this in
open hour workshops
in different community settings.
So we've been everywhere from,
as I said, senior centers.
We've-- We're in Salvation Army.
We're in our literacy agencies.
We're in neighborhood centers
and providing this information.
This particular project
has a pill box incentives
and this is a workbook that
we developed for this project.
There are some on back.
There was the Let's Talk about Flu
and Let's Talk about Medicines.
But basically we developed this.
It's written about a 4th grade
reading level and it goes
through the many project goals that
I had just talked about previously,
lots of pictures, easy
to understand,
writing, lots of white space.
So this is the tool that we
use similar one with the flu.
But we started in 50 workshop
locations across the state
and deliver the workshop.
We've had-- Every time we go they
ask us when we can come back.
We are on working developing
other things with the workbook.
So examples of what that looks
like inside, types of medicines,
prescription medicine and labels,
and the medicine reminders.
Each participant is-- gets
incentivized with the pill box
that they get to take home
as well as we do other things
like we do a preimposed test.
So each participant comes in
with a very simple pre-test
and then this post-tested.
So we can get some
measurement on understanding
and knowledge gain
during the workshop.
We develop some card games that
they do during the workshop as well
that give situations about
medication use and safety.
We've also worked on some videos
that are posted on our website now.
There's three of them.
These two here, "When
to Take Your Medicine"
and "How to Store Your Medicine."
They're just about
a minute and a half,
really short easy to
understand videos.
There's also one about
talking with your pharmacist.
And we promote these
videos during the workshop.
We've done online as
well as a printed quiz,
so that participants can take that
home and use it with their family.
And we're also now training the
trainer on these workshops so that
when the funding runs out that
organizations are equipped to care
on the workshops on their
own with as many resources
that we can make available for
them with very limited cost.
So here are some of
the things we learned
that there's a really big gap.
And in this particular project
with seniors what they really know
and what they think they
know as you had pointed out,
everyone can thought,
"Yeah, I can do this."
And then all of a sudden when
you're asked to demonstrate it,
it becomes a little different.
Medication storage is an issue.
There was just something on
Good Morning America Today
about children accessing pill boxes
and medications and how easy it is
to had all this little kids opening
up a child proof pill boxes and,
you know, very easily like one kid
had it done in nine seconds and--
>> Steven Rush: And
these were child proof?
>> Michele Erikson: These
are child proof, yeah.
So, yeah it was very
really interesting story.
So medication storage
is a really big issue.
The label instructions have
often caused confusion.
Those are the ones on the side
to the special labels
are often a source
of confusions for many people.
And remembering when to take them
and how to take them and reluctance
to ask pharmacist,
we show a lot of--
we show this video a lot from
the AMA where people talked
about their own health literacy
experience and, you know,
knowing when to take your medicine
is not something that's easily
understood on the label.
So take two tablets twice a day.
That doesn't register with everybody
and there's a little video clip
of a woman saying I take, you know,
I have 16 pills a day that I have
to take and I don't want to
forget and I'm not sure exactly
when to take them, so I just
take them all in the morning,
so I make I've got them all in.
And so, you know, this
happens and it's very real.
So these are the results
where again trying to--
measuring health behavior outcomes
and changing health behaviors,
a very difficult thing.
This is just the results from
preimposed test, understanding
or identifying the number of pills,
like I said people think they get it
but when they ask it like put
the number of pills correctly--
the correct number of
pills in their hand
and it becomes a little
bit different.
So 72 were OK in the
pre-test, 85% on the post test.
I should also say that this
similar study done in 2006
with intermediate both
limited literacy intermediate
and proficient literacy
adults was done.
And even the proficient
literacy folks
that were asked two tablets twice
a day, there is consistently one
or two mistakes out
of that group that--
whereas the high literacy group.
So people make mistakes as well.
And then again as I mentioned the
when to take medicine
is a huge issue
with understanding
medication labels.
So these are just a
comment that some
of the difference the
program has made.
Lot of people didn't understand
about not storing your
medication in the bath room.
That's a really convenient
place for most of us to store it
but really not a good place
at all for so many reasons.
We had another story of participant
who just happened to be going
to the-- her doctor and
the pharmacist the next day
after her workshop and felt very
empowered be able to ask questions
and felt in a much
better place in terms
of understanding what she
needed to know in order
to correctly take her medicine.
And then lastly one
of the things about--
as I mentioned we spent a lot of
time on just raising the awareness
in our state about health literacy.
A lot of small implementation
projects like this.
And these projects, have
allowed us to expand.
So we start out with
these pilot projects.
And this medication
one in particular was--
we applied to Wisconsin Medical
Society Foundation and they end
up funding all the counties
that the insurance company
that funded the original
project wasn't able to fund.
They were outside of their
service area and so we're able
to do this project and
get statewide coverage.
The same medical society
asks to apply again
for more funding this
year to continue it
because they were very
happy with the project
and the impact that
they were seeing.
We got funding from our
Department of Health Services then
to expand this medication
workshop to refugee populations,
which is we're learning was
just a whole another challenge
in a different audience in
terms of the language barrier,
in terms of the cultural
barriers and being so new
in understanding our
health care system.
So we're-- in that project right
now, it's a two-year project
and we're about halfway
through our first year
and learning a lot with
the refugee groups.
And then Wisconsin Health Literacy
is also, starting a second phase
of a project where
all this information
on these medication workshops has
helped us to develop a white paper.
And I have some at
the back of the room.
I have another one here,
if you haven't seen it.
But we are trying to adapt an
easy-to-read medication label
in the State of Wisconsin.
And the US Pharmacopeia in
2013 put out new standards
for what a medication
label should look like.
Right now the biggest thing
on that small little piece are
real estate is the pharmacist logo.
And so that's a bit of our
problem as well how the wording
for the label and for the
direction is mentioned.
So we're working on
this project right now.
And the second phase we
have three pharmacy networks
that are actually implementing a
new prototype label we're designing
and we're going to be
able to measure how
through health insurance network,
how these patients do
with the new label.
So exciting work.
I wanted to thank Nemours for
having us here and for the Center
for the Book, for John and Julian
[assumed spelling] all your work,
as well as pro-literacy
for inviting me to speak.
So thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> Jeff Carter: Thank you.
That's a great panel.
And I want to-- you know, John asked
me to trying to keep us on time.
We're little behind starting.
I do want to give you all an
opportunity to ask your question.
I have a few I could ask.
But I feel like this opportunity
for you to get your question.
And so in the few minutes
that we have left,
I throw it up into the floor,
any questions for any
member of our panel?
Yes?
>> I'm [inaudible] with pediatrician
and medical editor at [inaudible].
And we produce thousands of articles
[inaudible] instructions and,
obviously, literacy, they need
to focus for us because all
over [inaudible] the adults.
So I'm wondering how across
the board of a large library
to ensure consistency with literacy.
A lot of the tools [inaudible]
different literacy tools are not
applicable to medical terminology
and have some of the patient.
So I was wondering
how you manage that.
>> Robert Logan: Not
as well as it'd like.
The-- By the way her
question is very good one.
The question was the
diagnostics, OK, that you can use
to help you assess, OK, the
grade level, OK, of various types
of efforts to try to explain
health and medicine to the public.
Most of the diagnostic
tools are not designed
with health and medicine in mind.
So as soon as you have the
word in there like pediatrics.
Immediately-- you're at the college
level, OK, and it completely skews
of all those diagnostic
tools as you know, OK.
And we have never come
up, OK, with a--
what I consider to be
a good substitute, OK.
There is a private firm in this area
that does sell software
that they allege, OK.
It enables you to get a good reading
that is not thrown
off by medical terms.
So I'm giving you technical
answer because unfortunately we--
I don't have a good solution for
you other than the private firm
that sells software, the name
of the company is called,
Health Literacy Innovations.
No, we do not use that in our
own work for variety of reasons.
On the other hand though--
and I'm going to give
you a direct answer, OK.
I distribute Strunk & White,
"The Elements of Style"
that everyone I worked with, OK.
And I make sure that whenever I
edit or whenever anybody else is
in a senior editorial position,
I make absolutely sure that
"The Elements of Style"
is foundational
to what everybody does, OK.
And I'm not going to go in detail.
Those of you who never
seen that book,
that's still the best thing
ever written about how
to write in plain English.
But still we got ways
to go and I think--
I wish we had better
diagnostic tools.
>> Jeff Carter: Yeah Steve.
>> Steve Rush: Yeah, that's really
great question and it's something
that we need to do for
lots of reasons not only
for patient education but there was
a federal district court stipulation
that came out of Louisiana that
said, "If you're going to deny care
to somebody, you have
to do it in ways
that people could understand
it," which is really very good.
One of the things that we have to do
and we've been training our people
to do is that if you're going
to use a term like pediatrician.
Maybe you put in parenthesis
a doctor for children.
And then you could use the
term pediatrician again.
And part of it is to in the
communication is not only
to make people aware of certain
terms because they're going to have
to become aware of it
because it's common usage
within the health care environment.
So with taking pains to not only
use the term or terms and define it
but also to make sure that there's
correct flow of information.
And I'm seeing the, your kids
and teen information website
which I think is absolutely
tremendous and gives the term,
the definition and the usage of it.
But it's very difficult particularly
when states are saying you got
to have a certain reading
grade level
but it doesn't do anything
for comprehension.
>> Robert Logan: It just occurred to
me that there's a part of and answer
that I didn't give that
we should acknowledge, OK.
I'm so impressed by how improved
natural language processing is, OK.
I mean we may be talking about a
none issue in several years, OK.
>> Jeff Carter: Interesting.
>> Robert Logan: Because
natural language processing is--
becomes so sophisticated that
it may very well take care
of this issue by itself, OK.
I certainly hope so that
would be a nice solution
but I can't guarantee that.
>> Jeff Carter: Let's
have one more question
or two really fast questions.
Who else has a question?
Don't be intimidated because
I said the two fast questions.
Just anybody, any other questions?
Yes.
>> Here at library we are
tackling health and literacy here.
Because Dr. Charles's office heath
services, we started a forum here
that is on health and wellness.
And so we've been doing this
for about a year and a half
and the surprising amount of
staff that actually doesn't know
but now knows much more
of because of the programs
that we've been having
here to actually to conquer
that situation about
health literacy.
>> Jeff Carter: Well,
I want to close.
I'm going to just take the
moderator's privilege here to close
with this one thought, which
is that I'm really glad
that we have this panel talking
about both health literacy
and how adult literacy
impacts health.
The reason I think that's
important because it's a--
I think it's a good reminder
that, you know, we're all learners
to one level or another and I think
to the extent that we can identify
with each other as we learn
about our own health care.
You know instead of start
of thinking about our--
the folks we serve in adult literacy
as being these other
group over there.
I think it kind of brings
us all together as learners
so I think that's kind
of how the spirit I'd
like to close out this panel with.
And I'd like to thank the panel.
And I'd like to thank you for your
attention and Center for the Book
and everyone who organize
this thing.
Thank you very much for having me.
It's been a great privilege to be
able to work with this group here
and I look forward to
the rest of discussion.
[ Applause ]
>> John Cole: Well, I'd like to
thank, thank the panel tonight.
We're going to move right into
the next panel discussion of that
as I said the restrooms are outside.
You can come in.
But we're going to keep moving
because our panel members are here
just for limited period of time.
I must say I'm very
pleased that the Library
of Congress health services has
come into this and is joining us.
It's terrific.
And I had with one thing
that I've kind of hope
for but had followed up on.
It was great to see you.
Our next panel is going to be on--
we call it after some discussion,
Business Perspectives
on Literacy and Health.
And our moderator Nancy Fishman
is going to bring her panel
up right now and introduce them.
This is a unique panel
with some people
that we are very pleased have
taken the time to join us.
I'm going to let Nancy Fishman
introduced them or get them started.
Nancy is the deputy
director of ReadyNation.
And I'm also going to have
Nancy tell you about ReadyNation
and it's importance to
what we are doing here.
Let's give Nancy a hand
to get everything started.
[ Applause ]
There you go.
>> Nancy Fishman: Thank
you very much
and thank you so much for having us.
ReadyNation is an organization of
business people across the world
who support investments in quality
early care and education programs
as a way of building their
workforce in the economy.
And we partner with
other business group
and organizations across
the country.
And yes, I said across
the world earlier.
We are doing some work
internationally.
And ReadyNation is very honored
to have had an opportunity
to help put together
this panel today to talk
about business perspectives
in this topic area.
Very honored to have with us
this morning, Mike Edwards,
the retired state supervisor of
banking from Washington State,
that is, who flew across the
country to join us today.
We have Karen Baker, the Director of
Community Affairs from Scholastic.
Next to Karen, we have Dominic
Robinson with CenterState CEO.
Vice President of Economic
Inclusion, Director of Work Train
and the director of
Northside Urban Partnership.
And on the end here we have
Dana Conners the President
of the Main Chamber of Commerce.
So we are from all
over the country today.
We are thrilled to be here.
ReadyNation is part of
Council for Strong America.
That's our umbrella
organization that in addition
to bringing the business
perspective to this issue,
we have a sibling organization
Fight Crime: Invest in Kids
that brings a law enforcement
perspective.
Their members are district attorneys
and sheriffs and police chiefs.
We have Mission Readiness.
A group of 600 retired
admirals and generals
who find this issue important in
military readiness perspective.
Shepherding the Next Generation,
group of the Angelical pastors
who bring families together
to support these efforts.
And we have champs, elite athletes,
and coaches to talk about nutrition
and physical activity and
teamwork as part of these efforts.
We know that high quality early
childhood programs can lead
to a host of better health outcomes.
It's for that reason
that we're here today
to share with you some examples.
Since we know that reading
proficiency is a predictor
of overall health.
We'd like to talk to you how the
business community has gotten
involved in this subject area.
We're going to make ours a
little bit more of a panel.
We're going to address certain
questions to certain panelist,
give them an opportunity.
Since we're crowded up here
they may choose to stay seated
to answer the questions and
we'll leave a few minutes at end
for some questions from all of you.
So we're going to start
at the very beginning.
Mr. Connors, when we spoke earlier,
you mentioned that you had an
"aha moment" that came
when you first learned
about early brain development.
We know that the foundation
of many critical workplace skills
is established in the earliest years
but what's really happening
then and how does
that relate to success in school?
>> Dana Connors: You're
asking me to explain that?
>> Nancy Fishman: I am.
I'm asking you as a
Chamber of President to--
how about why it matters to
you in your role at a Chamber.
>> Dana Connors: I didn't tell
you I have to leave the airport
about five minutes ago just
before you ask that question.
My "aha moment" was not around
explaining brain to you.
But I can tell you
exactly what it was.
It was 2007.
It was a September day it was
about this time in the afternoon
and the-- oh, that would help huh?
And the speaker was a professor
from Harvard who's
name was Dr. Yoshikawa.
And I had-- Well, first of all
let me go back to set it up.
The governor at that time,
Governor Baldacci, asked me to come
to the Blaine House with probably
a dozen other people to talk
about a conference that he was going
to hold at one of our prime location
in the state along the coast.
So I tended because I had
great respect for him,
we had a great relationship
so I went.
The subject was early
childhood development.
And I confess.
You've heard these words and it's
happened to me more than once,
you don't know what you don't know.
Well, I really didn't know what
early childhood development was
and I probably should not admit
that in front of this group,
but in truth before that moment
in 2007 I really didn't know.
I thought it was more like daycare
and medley there's an aspect
to that but it was much.
My understanding was
far, far immature
and not really aware of its value.
So he asked me.
I went there I listed to discussion.
I really could reasonably follow
it but wasn't too tuned in.
Until he said to me, "Dana, I want
you to be the final wrap up speaker
on Friday," to which
my million thought was,
"What the devil am I going to say,"
because I really don't
know the subject matter
but I respect to the
governor I went.
I'll make the story short
because I could move--
I could make it last forever.
So I go and it's not my
habit to attend conferences
that last three or four days.
But in this one I figured I better
go to learn the subject matter
so I can wrap up the session.
So this Thursday afternoon it
started Tuesday night I'm speaking
at Friday noon so far
it hadn't click.
My "aha moment" hadn't
come and I wasn't so sure
that it was going to
come, but it did.
It happened I was sitting
in the conference room,
the professor was speaking and
when he approach the subject
of the early childhood development
and spoke in terms of the formation,
the architecture, the
brain development,
85% occurs in the first three
years, 90% by the fifth year.
And then he went on both in science
in terms of the number of neurons
that a young person at
birth has a hundred million,
a Milky Way as many
stars in the Milky Way,
I can't remember that term.
And then he went on to explain the
synopsis and how important that was,
those connectivities and you
reach the peak of those synopsis
about time of your
85% brain is formed.
He went into more detail because
he knew a heck of a lot more
about the issue than I
just expressed to you
as you could obviously tell.
But I was so struck by it
because he went on to explain
that those three years much
like a house when you build is
that you start with the
foundation, you frame in the house,
you do your electrical system,
the circuit is really
what he was talking about.
He went on to explain it becomes the
foundation for your intellectual,
your moral, your emotional,
your physical,
your health, your psychological.
And I remember saying, out
loud, to the person next
to me heard, oh my God, I get it.
I know exactly what I needed to say.
And the guy next to who was a
Maine senator, not a US senator
but represent us the ledger said
to me, "What'd you say that for?"
So I explained his name was
Richard, "I said Richard,
didn't you just get that?"
And I went on explaining
why I felt that way
and he said, "Dana, you're so wrong.
That's parent's responsibility."
At that moment I realize part of
the debate and as time has gone
on it's-- I've come
to really realize
as I've heard the speaker sand may
I say, very inspirational day today.
I'm grateful that I had the
opportunity to get here early
because it was very heart
warming but also informative.
I've come to know that it's
not about one or the other.
It's clearly about both of us.
It's a community concept
but we ignore it.
We have ignored it for so long
that we start with K to 12
and then expect by the fourth
grade we're going to be
at the national standard
on reading and Math
and you really investing too
little at the early stages
and expecting too much
in such a short time.
So to me it became almost
everything that I do and work
for whether it's growing the economy
whether it's dealing with skill
in the workplace, whether
it's productivity,
whether it's helping a kid, a young
person achieve through aspirations,
through educational
attainment that lowers crime,
it lowers remedial
education, special ed.
Productivity is up, oh my God.
That became the "Aha moment".
And to me it was so significant.
I can-- and later on if I'm
asked the question and even
if I'm not I may go there just as
I did on this one is that to share
with you what happened since.
Because I'm really-- it's a
race that has no finish line
but I'm very encouraged
by what the state is doing
and what the business community
has stepped up to do since 2007.
My final comment in this,
that afternoon when I stood
up I didn't tell you this
or it wasn't mentioned,
there's no reason to.
But previous in the President
State Chamber which I've been
for 20 years I was
Commissioner of Transportation.
Yeah I know I'm only 30 but I--
I was Commissioner for 11
years of Transportation.
And I used to always say,
you know, the foundation
of our economy is our transportation
system moving products,
people safely and efficiently.
And it cost a lot to build and
maintain a good transportation
but it cost a lot more not to.
You've got to maintain it, you've
got to invest in it or it's going
to cost you more when
you try to fix it.
Well that afternoon
that was my message
but it wasn't transportation,
it was early childhood
quality care and education.
It does cost money to do it,
but it cost you a lot more
if you don't invest in it.
That was my message then,
that's my message now.
That's my "aha moment".
>> Nancy Fishman: Thank you.
Mr. Robinson, you've just heard
about how the community can benefit
when we get kids off to
a good start in life.
We know that your work involves
community and economic development.
Can you tell us how you think
businesses can get more involved?
For example, are you just--
are we just talking about
businesses making donations
to worthy programs or is it more?
>> Dominic Robinson: Sure.
Well thank you for the
opportunity to speak here today.
Just a little bit of context
for my position up here,
I'm a Vice President for a
Regional Economic Development Agency
and Chamber of Commerce in Central
Upstate New York based at SYRACUSE.
And for many years the organization
I represent has operated
like a traditional chamber of
commerce representing the interest
of its members and promoting what
was kind of conventionally thought
to be what was in the best
interest of the regional economy.
We have kind of headed
evolution and leadership overtime
which is also included my coming
on board which is really been
about thinking more broadly around
what economic development means.
And in the case of my role,
very specifically trying
to connect the dots
between economic development
and community development
and community investment,
and what I really think about our
work is that we're actually trying
to break apart of a false dichotomy
in our public narrative which is
that the interest of business
or economic interest are at odds
with the community interest.
And I think, you know, much
like what Dana was saying
that there's profound business
case to be made for investing
in communities, investing in
children, investing in education.
And I think that we
need to do a better job
as a business community
of articulating that.
And so it's the work we do is
both kind of advocacy-based
and programming-based
but ultimately is
about leveraging the self-interest
of our businesses and our region
and is also interest of those we're
trying to drive the regional economy
in order to make smarter,
more effective investments
in our community.
The work we do ranges
from programmatically we
do workforce development,
we put together workforce
development programs and initiatives
that connect the needs of
our employers to the un-
and under employed and distant
franchise, members of our community.
We foster entrepreneurship
in low income neighborhoods,
we help spur neighborhood
revitalization
and we ultimately are looking for
ways to advocate and echo policies
that we think align our
community's business
and economic interest
with community impact.
And so, when we think about
the role of business in all
of that there's really a lot of
different ways that that can happen.
But I think what we're ultimately
talking about is a shift away
from what many of us might be all
too familiar with which is kind
of the corporate sponsorship model.
You carve out a little piece of
your budget and you send some
of your employees every
year to some, you know,
really bad convention center dinner.
You get, you know, your
company's name in a program
and you may be even go and send
some of your employees to go clean
up a neighborhood for a day.
I think what we can all
believe in this room is
that those things are
fundamentally paternalistic.
They actually disassociate the
business owner and the workers
and the business with the
community and with the problem.
It creates an otherness.
And I think what we're really
trying to do is create a space
where business owners and
business leaders can come together
and own some of the
challenges in our community.
So that really ranges.
One of the things we're doing
around workforce development is
simply saying to our employer
in our region, you
have hiring challenges.
You have high rates of turnover.
We have the 23rd poor
city in America and some
of the highest concentrations
of poverty among minority
populations in the United States.
There's a supply and
demand challenge here
that we can knit together.
Let's figure out how we meet your
workforce needs and better prepare
and equip a pipeline
of workers who need it.
And, you know, we've had great
success piloting programs
with this philosophy in mind
for the last several years
and I think fundamentally what we're
able to do is get our businesses
to understand that they can
act in their self-interest and
yet contribute to solving
the community's challenges.
So, you know, when we think
about things like early childhood
or we think about literacy
in general,
we are doing all kinds of stuff.
One big effort on behalf of my
organization was contributing
to a campaign among our
local businesses to invest
in something called the SYRACUSE
College Promise which is a program
that allows for any city of
SYRACUSE school district student
who graduates whose parents
make less than $75,000 a year
to attend college for free.
So we've been able to help raise
that money, it's not been--
it's not our program it's not
our effort we have been able
to be an organizing force
for our local businesses
to get them to invest in that.
We also are starting to jump
on board to advocacy efforts
around early childhood education
investment expanding the facilitated
enrollment program in New York State
for middle and low income workers.
And what's really powerful about
that is when we get our businesses
to stand up for that and we get--
and we use our voice for that.
It's a voice that people
aren't expecting.
So our, you know, our Republican
State politicians suddenly
pay attention.
We're also thinking about how
do we get our employers to think
about their workforce and
some of the challenges
that they're facing
at a family level.
So right now we're actually
just yesterday we partnered
on a grant application to the
federal Department of Labor
with out local workforce
development board
for something called the
Strengthening Working Families
Initiative in which we would,
you know, be able to have access
to underwrite workforce
development efforts here
in our community the kind of
building I said we already did
but specifically to underwrite
the workforce training efforts
for parents and children under
the age of 13 who are low income.
And specifically to address
some of the child care
and early childhood education
needs of those individuals.
One thing that we have
written into the grant would be
that we would actually be able
to place and ombudsman of sorts
or navigator in some of our major
employers, you know, who could go in
and actually consult
with lower wage workers
about their child care
options and opportunities
to better facilitate child
care enrollment or utilization
of the child care system
especially if they are trying
to embark upon ongoing
training and education in order
to move their way up a clear ladder.
So, you know, to do that thought
it requires willing participation
from our employer partners, we were
talking to our employers asking
if this is something
that we could do as part
of our an incumbent worker
advancement strategy that, you know,
we've been working out with them
and they were open to
it, receptive to it.
And so I think it's really getting
employers at the end of the day
to become part of the conversation
and see themselves as part
of the solution beyond the
obligatory check writing
and the superficial, you
know kind of engagement.
>> Nancy Fishman: Thank
you very much.
Mr. Edwards, you have an amazing
history with the banking community
so would you talk to
us about some numbers.
What can you tell us about return on
investments made in young children
and how that might
impact our economy?
>> Michael Edwards: Thank you Nancy.
The amazing history
is out there you read
about it everyday in
the banking world.
I retired me for most of that
came around, I'll have you know.
I am one the-- In fact, I am
the only legally declared,
governor declared, SOB in
the United States today.
Each state has one, but in my state
it was a supervisor of banking.
Everywhere else it's bank
commissioner or whatever
and I was appointed
by two governors,
two of the said I was an SOB.
I also found out today
that I'm also learned
that I'm a health care practitioner.
I didn't fully realize
that but listening
to the speakers this morning
on the earlier panel I find
with having six grand
kids I find that I'm--
you know, often in a health
care provider position.
It also gives me the perspective
on what these growing kids need.
The youngest I have is
3 and the oldest is 13,
adorable children of course.
But I find too that in the course
of working with them and caring
with them I find that I'm also--
well, I'm having some literacy
problems because in the course
of things my little 5 year old at
breakfast one morning was just--
we were just finishing
up and I said--
she said, "Well Papa I'll savor
you-- save this for later."
And I said, "Well, you don't
have to save it honey."
I said, you know, "There's
plenty there.
I'll have more for dinner tonight."
And she says, "No Papa
I am savoring my food."
That's a 5 year old.
They're in preschools and I
now watch them very carefully
but it is amazing what
they have, you know,
versus the banking
industry that I came out of.
The literacy there is, my gosh, you
have to be a Philadelphia lawyer
to have open a checking
account nowadays.
And then it doesn't do too much good
and usually it come
out on the short end.
But anyway, I will
share a few things.
I was drafted a couple
times in my life.
Well, I avoided the first draft,
I signed up for the military
rather than getting drafted.
But this program here I was
drafted into after I had--
mostly I had actively retired.
And it was for the advocacy
of these younger kids
that we're talking about.
Anyway, I was brought in by
the law enforcement people.
My brother was the elected
chair for 20 years in our county
and through the fight crime
program for the law and justice folk
that have gone out with early
learning messages they-- we--
in our state we evolve in a
business community having sprung off
of that same concept.
So we now have three-pronged
approach,
we have the retired military
that Nancy talked about earlier,
and we have the business community
and then we have the law enforcement
including the prosecuting attorneys.
All three have already taken off and
done extremely well and the messages
that are able to deliver have been
very well received everywhere we go
as you can imagine.
The problem is most of our-- well,
a lot of our parents aren't aware
of the fact that they need the pre-K
education quality and they have--
that's the first problem.
So we have a message to
deliver to the parents as well
as elsewhere in the legislators.
And it's often the case that our
investments go to the way say side
because we're not in
early enough on our own.
If you don't get these kids early
into the program you're
missing a terrific opportunity
because of that, as
I learned as well
about early brain growth is
something you can't reverse
and come back on.
So it's really important
to get them.
When I'm in the legislative
body asking for some funding
for our state programs we have a
state program called e-cap program,
early education and
assistance program.
And until last year where
it was not very well funded,
our state is having a difficulty
as you can imagine as a lot
of states are on the
K through 12 programs.
In fact, we just had a State
Supreme Court Decisions come
down that said there was an
inequality and funding in our state
because the state was not
meeting its basic obligation
across the board and a
lot of the dependency
for education was following
on local levies.
And so that would take
disadvantaged communities,
lower income communities they were--
they can't just spring forward and,
you know, do the levy action
to bring it up to speed.
So, a long story short we're still
in the legislative sessions trying
to resolve that issue which is about
a $1.2 billion additional burden
for that education
program to bring it
up correctly where it needs to be.
So you can well imagine
is a business community I
and others we brought
in to the program
as we go before the legislator.
You know, we're very well received.
I've been in the legislative
bodies for a long time
and not always well received and
I was an SOB for a good reason
on many of those occasions.
But when I appear up there with
a message for the legislators
on the need to fund this
pre-K and the state program,
I can tell you I'm--
It's a fun thing to do.
You get up there and the legislators
are actually anxious to hear
from you, they're anxious
to hear the message.
It's a bipartisan acceptance and--
not this year's session but the
years before for biannual period.
We were actually in our state able
to get $160 million to the program
that we hadn't really had before.
So that was a major step up
on the part of the legislator.
I'm having a hard time this
year getting them to follow
with that good record
but sooner or later
if we don't get it this
year we'll get it next.
And that's one of the things
that we find too is you have
to be steady in your course.
You have to be steady
in your message
and now fortunately we have some 130
business people throughout our state
that are carrying forth the
message not only in the communities
that they're in but into the
legislature when we call on them.
So it's me and these other
folks, community leaders
that are going before the
legislator and face it.
You know, their business,
their known, they get there,
these people are in office
because somebody supported them
usually it's the ones that we have
in the cavalry of our group.
And so we do get a real good
hearing and get a good reaction.
But I can tell you that it's
very severe and I know it is
in other states as well is to get
the funding for these programs.
And it's just desperate.
But early learning as you've heard
earlier starts at a very early age.
We get a return on investment
when we start them off and that
in our state we've got a pretty
well plan down to 4 to 1 ratio
that we get $4 back for every
dollar that we've invested.
And it keeps from repetitive
needs for going
into additional years of education.
We actually had about 2000 people--
2000 of our little people that had
to go back and to remediation
back in from the kindergarten.
So the kindergarten program is
impacted in our state to have tune
of about 5700 student-- per
student or 10 million in reeducating
and retaking those
people through the--
young people through the course for
another year is a $10 million issue.
So we use that kind of example.
You know, it pay us now, or it
pay us greater amount later.
And so really when I was in
asking for $10 million, you know,
the message I was giving to
the legislators was, you know,
this really isn't new money.
I mean, if we don't come up with the
10 million you're going to spend it
on remediation the next year.
And we know that about 44%
of our little youngsters come
in that haven't had the advantage
of early education aren't really
up to speed by any means to
go on into the K through 12
and they fall behind
and the result are poor.
And I guess we could go on
with the stats for that forever
but we've only got a short
time today but I will tell you
that it's known through studies
so it's valid, it's there
and we bring the message,
the legislators listen.
So we get-- when I come in and ask
for the $10 million even though
I didn't get it this year,
we'll get it next year.
It's really money that it's
going to be spent anyway
and it's a lot smarter
way to spend the money.
And it's just been fun.
It's been a neat experience now as
I've retired from my banking career
to come into this endeavor
especially being the grandfather
of six growing smart kids.
Thank you.
>> Nancy Fishman: Thank
you very much.
Ms. Baicker, Scholastic
is interested
in innovative educational
partnerships with the focus
on corporate social responsibility.
Can you explain how your community
partnerships promote literacy
and health?
>> Karen Baicker: Yes,
thank you Nancy.
It's a pleasure to be here today at
this symposium and on this panel,
so I want to thank the Library of
Congress, the Center for the Book
and ReadyNation for bringing
together this group of partners.
I arrived yesterday and I didn't
know anybody and thanks to the,
you know, good will and relationship
of Scholastic with great partners
like Reach Out and Read and
ReadyNation I piggybacked
on that god will and I've met a lot
of great people and
I've learned a lot.
And a lot of what I've learned in
the past day and a bit is stuff
that I think most of us already
had a pretty good idea about--
I think that very few of us
in the room who didn't know
that literacy has a great impact on
outcomes on health, on economics,
and we could-- we might
argue and research
about whether it's a direct causal
relationship or a marker or,
you know, how those
relationships work.
But what seems new in what I'm
hearing today one I'm excited
about is the increased urgency
across a wide range of specters--
sectors in collaborating
and integrating our efforts
and approaching it in
new and innovative ways.
So that's what I'm
excited about and what I'd
like to tell you a little bit
about is a little bit of background
about Scholastic and our business
model what we're looking to do
and how we're looking to
try to break this cycle
that we've all been describing.
Some of the shifts in our model and
then also a couple promising pilots
that we've been doing, so thank you.
It's interesting and unusual
for me to be on a business panel
because I don't associate Scholastic
very closely with the business.
And-- Yes.
>> Michael Edwards:
Probably a good decision.
>> Karen Baicker: Yes, well I think
that we get reminded
that it is at work.
But the fact is we are very,
very mission driven business
and that mission is literacy.
So there is a high correlation
between the work that we all want
to do here and our business model.
So, you'd like to ask me at lunch
whether we were for profit or not
for profit and I-- it's sort
of a nonprofit and I have been
to be the Director of Community
Affairs which has like privilege
of corporate social
responsibility without the burden
of directly like revenue bearing.
But-- So that's-- I'll
get a little bit more
into my role in community affairs.
But we are business and a successful
business and this is a great time
to be in the literacy business
because of the imperative
that I've just been describing.
Because we have new tools through
data, new research neuroscience,
we have all sorts of new
mechanisms to look at
and education itself
is right for a change
and the educational
publishing business again needs
to be part of it.
So I'm glad to be here
on some business panel.
A little bit of background
about Scholastic,
is everyone here pretty
familiar with Scholastic?
OK. So I won't say much
but, you know, Clifford,
The Magic School Bus, Harry Potter
and we also create
educational curriculum material,
professional training and
other forms of outreach.
But we're the largest
children's book publisher
which Robie spoke to earlier.
So, the mission of
Scholastic-- Scholastic has had,
I don't know if you know this,
they've had only two owners,
Maurice Robinson and his son Dick
Robinson have been the only two
owners in the 90, 95 year
history of Scholastic.
So, that's unusual sort of family
business perspective right there.
And it's been the entire
time based on emission
of teaching all children based
on equity teaching all children
to learn to read and
to love to read.
It's heavily focused
on independent reading,
the joy of reading,
the choice in reading.
So we are not so much
in the educational
publishing space the same
that a BASO program is, but.
We are in schools and in fact we
have an enormous reach wherein 95%
of the schools nationwide
in one form or another.
So that might be our book
fairs that everyone has
and certainly nostalgic memories
of, or the magazines or books.
So having that kind of reach
into the school is also
as I see it an opportunity and
obligation to do something.
You know, we're there in the ground
in a lot of struggling regions.
And we have the opportunity to
try to do something more than just
for books in the hands of kids.
So that's the other
thing I want to speak
about briefly Scholastics reach
in terms of access to books.
So we've long known that this is
critical there're sort of studies
about the number of books in the
home and the correlation to literacy
and we've done an amazing
job at that
from the corporate
social responsibility.
Point of view we've donated more
than 40 million books since 2000
and we have a family and community
engagement department just focused
on getting books into homes and our
partnership with Reach Out and Read.
So that something for Scholastic
and me [inaudible] pretty
feel really good about.
We have a lot of knowledge about
how children best learn to read
and that changes a lot and
we've swung with the pendulum
from whole language to
phonics to, you know,
and just we keep amassing
a body of knowledge
and communicating it
better and better.
And I think we do a pretty good
job in the schools of teaching kids
to read and helping
teachers teach kids to read.
Nonetheless we still have
this interacted problem
that we've all been describing.
We have not seen reading
scores improved.
We haven't seen the achievement gap
close, despite not just Scholastic
but the whole world of education
and education publishing
and all the efforts.
We haven't moved the needle much.
And so the question is with like
the power of our trusted brand
of Scholastic and Clifford and
the platform that we have and all
of the schools whether
we're going to do about it,
you know what's our contribution,
that's part of what I seeing.
You talked a little bit about not
just writing a check and I feel
that way also about donating books,
like I'm very pleased
that we donate books.
I want us to continue to do that
but it's has to be beyond that.
So in a minute that's going to bring
me to role in community affairs
and how I'm hoping to
help drive that to be.
But, first, I just want to
mention a few of the shifts.
Am I OK, 10 min?
>> Nancy Fishman: You
can have 30 more seconds.
>> Karen Baicker: OK.
OK. All right.
Well, the shifts I'm seeing in
the education space at Scholastic
and in publishing are towards
more towards early childhood
and by early we mean, early, we
mean from birth and the importance
of talking too and singing too and
playing with your child [inaudible].
The importance of out to
reach outside the school kids.
A school age kid is only in
school 20% of the hours that he
or she is awake over
the course of the year.
And so what are we doing
in these other channels
and times toward personalized
towards personalized instruction
instead of, you know,
someone made the analogy
that if we treated kids-- or we're
treating kids if someone came
to the hospital or a doctor and
we treated all of those patients
by saying, "OK, you're all getting
this treatment and you're going to--
it's going to go on
for this amount of time
and then we're going
to discharge you.
That's kind of what we're
doing in the education system.
We're giving everybody the same.
So there needs to be a trend towards
customization of individuals.
So I'll stop with the--
>> Nancy Fishman: Sorry.
>> Karen Baicker: I'll
stop with the trends.
You can ask me more about
translator if you'd like to.
And I'll just really quickly
just describe the pilots
and that we have going.
So I guess I'll just talk about
our most exciting pilot to me
which is called Discover Together.
And it's a partnership we started
in conjunction with Linda Mayes,
Dr. Linda Mayes of the Yale Child
Study Center to test the hypothesis
that we can use literature and
literacy to build resilience
in struggling communities.
So we joined forces in rural
Appalachia and piloted a program
that we've been doing for
the last several years
that I think has very
exciting potential.
And what we are doing there
is we're pairing literature
with very place-based experiences.
Field trips to sources of local
pride like a worm farm or bakery
or the railroad or a nature trail.
Pairing those with literature
and field trips and activities
and helping the community
come together
to celebrate their own stories
around the idea of literacy
and the power of narrative and
what we notice in Grande County is
that that wasn't the only
thing that they wanted.
It was helpful.
But we just began a long process
of listening to the community.
And so now that program consist of
a family coop, early childhood coop
from zero to five where we bring
pants and use the same of curriculum
in model reading and work with
the multigenerational approach
and it just keeps expanding.
And so that's the other trend I
would highlight is customizing
to the communities we're serving.
>> Nancy Fishman: Thank you.
I apologies for rushing you.
I wish we had about
three more hours up here.
Now I'm going to address
one question to all of you.
Particularly just tell us how
businesses, business leaders,
and business groups can
more actively collaborate
to help more young people
have access to the programs
that we're talking about.
And Dana, I know your flight
is first this afternoon.
So why don't you start?
You each have about two minutes
and we'll just work our
way down the line here.
>> Dana Connors: Just about it gives
me time to get to the plane at 4:30.
So I appreciate.
I'm very grateful and
please forgive for having
to rush of the platform here.
That's why they put me to the side.
Hopefully I just push me off here.
The business communities
like I mentioned it earlier,
I mean I have found in my 20 years
to get the business community
involved particularly in something
that begins as a social issue
which most business see this as.
Is you build awareness
as to what it does
or why it relates then
in the economy.
You got to give them some action.
We can't just talk it to death,
which is characteristic
of a lot of issues.
And thirdly, there has
to be accountability.
And when I can put those
three things together,
I've got a secret formula.
And once they started to become
aware and how we became aware is
that we're very involve
in ReadyNation.
ReadyNation is a tremendous
resource.
A lot of our business signed up,
our law enforcement investing kids,
fight crime, mission readiness
for our military people,
they're all very engaged.
That in itself is a community
because there are so many of them
and we have a very passionate person
that represents all three in Maine.
So she's fantastic.
We have a group of business
leaders that took upon themselves--
we did this research
project right here.
It's called Make a Name Work:
Critical Investments
for the Main Economy.
A partnership to the research
empathy very well respected
research entity.
We put this together it tells-- it's
all about early childhood the facts,
the facts drive the
solution in instance
because it's more than emotion.
It's more than feel
good as much as it is.
The facts help drive this success.
That helped bring the
awareness to the forefront.
This group a business leaders call
themselves main early learning
investment group mainly
have raise over $10 million.
That's the check book
that's putting money there.
But it's not sponsorships.
They take that and they've
worked with EduCare which most
of you are familiar with.
We have one in our state.
They designate a community.
They are committing, I think, it's
$4 million to address a number
of kids with the community
with family.
The boots are on the ground.
They're very involved.
I can't ask for more
than that on any issue.
And here's an issue that
at first blush they saw
as social and not economic.
Now they see as economic
more than social.
Our challenge is what Mike said
is that we don't have enough money
for K to 12 and higher ed, and we've
got some to the state government
but it's a race that
has on finish line.
It is sunk.
You got to be constantly
persistent about
and you got to stay on message.
That's my story and I'm sticking
to it and I appreciate it.
And if sneak out it's only because I
have to make a plane because I have
to speak at a funeral
tomorrow morning
and I can't afford to miss it.
So thank you very much
and thank you.
>> Dominic Robinson: Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Karen Baiker: It's OK.
>> Dominic Robinson: Well, I
think my job got a little easier
because he stole half the things
I'm about to say, which is great.
So I guess I would
echo a lot of that.
I think that one thing I like
to reinforce, repetition,
is I think for business owners
in particular business leaders,
engagement in a partnership
that kind of takes them outside
of their kind of core
mission or core focus.
In an ideal scenario you
ground that in some form
of self-interest for them.
But I don't think that that
is ultimately critical.
What I do think is critical
is that whatever it is
that they are being asked to do
is able to result in an outcome.
I think business leaders are much
more prone to be thinking about kind
of I do this and this happens.
They want to see you know
kind of cause and effect.
And I think that too often in
the world of nonprofit in policy
and in the worlds that most
of us probably operate in,
we do perhaps get a
little bit too comfortable
in the conceptual, in the ethereal.
And I think business leaders
they want to see something.
There's an instant
gratification that they're seeking.
The other thing that I
would just kind of bring up
and I think it's really important
and it certainly speaks to the work
that I'm doing with my team
is playing the role of broker.
I think that you-- in order to
build unconventional partnerships
that are advancing mission around
outcomes relative to early childhood
or health or literacy
and you're trying
to bring these desperate
partners together.
You have to recognize the
very different languages
that a community college will speak
compared to a business compared
to a social service agency compared
to a governmental organization.
They have different outcomes.
They have, in some cases,
very different motivations.
And they by all means use
different terminology.
And it's very difficult to put
them in a room and expect them
to kind of make magic happen.
So whether that's through some
form of formal facilitation
or it's just identifying people
in coalition who have that kind
of translator capacity
or capability.
I think it's really
insuring that there is kind
of that brokerage rule embedded
in those types of partnership.
So I think that that's
really important
because too often you bring
those different types of partners
in a room and they're
conceptually on board
but they really don't have any
way of finding a common language
or create in commons base.
>> Nancy Fishman: OK.
Go ahead.
>> Karen Baicker: OK.
I think in terms of getting
businesses more involved
in the issues of literacy and
health, one of the first things
that we need to do
is listen to needs
of a particular community,
look at the data.
And before we ask a
business to get involve
to know exactly what will be most
helpful because they agree with you
that they are not necessarily
looking
at ROI in the traditional way.
They do want to be helpful
and we need to use--
show them that we're going to use
their resources most effectively.
I've found in the work that
I'm doing for the research
and development lab
that the combination
of having a research institution
like and academic or university,
a business, and schools, and CBOs
all involve together is the most
powerful way to have a common
purpose and affect change.
>> Michael Edwards:
I just add to that.
Thank you.
That, you know, really we're in-- I
know this is an energy in the room
because you brought me into more
literacy, hopefully, in your program
and in your talks earlier today.
But, you know, health is an
important thing and we view
at ReadyNation with our
activities of how important it is.
And we include that in our programs,
we make sure the kids get the
meals the parents understand the
importance of, and they can't learn
if they're hungry and they can't
if they don't get that
early development.
You'll lose them in
the succeeding years
as they into their K through 12.
So health is a definite play in this
and I think you could be and I'd
like to solicit your support
going forward and keeping
in your mind the benefits of
what we hopefully help shed
on with light the for
you today is the benefits
of bringing those kids early on,
getting the parents to understand.
If you think-- If-- You know, if
they're in your office and they're
in for a medical reason
and they're in discussing--
just if you can get any kind of
direct or indirect message to them.
The importance of those kids getting
in to an early education program,
I'll bet you many of our
states I haven't research
that have an early
education program.
And if they don't you have
many community members
that do have an education program.
And often the church or
a paternal organization
or somebody that's recognized
it in your community.
If you can get together with them
and cause us an energy between you
to go forward for better
health and for early education.
You know, our research
shows that this is going
to be one of the-- [inaudible].
One on the first generations lived
shorter lives than their parent.
Well, these ones are coming up.
And a lot of it has to do with
health and a lot of the ability
to reach good health care
which is very expensive depends
on good business and early
education of these kids
and putting them in the workforce.
We in the business side are looking
for growing our future employees.
We have a lot of problems.
I've noticed this in the
industry we have people
that can't basically
count back cash.
They can't convey in a comprehensive
way their ideas bringing forward.
You may have people that are
quite bright and do what they do
but they can't convey their ideas
and their smartness, if you will,
on because they can't
converse and they're not--
they're literacy is lacking.
Starts with education
and good health.
So being Nancy is up here going
to be evil eye on me pretty soon.
I'm going to seal it off at that.
But I would like to recruit each
of you in your own communities,
in your own way to
impose on the parents
and your community how early this
early education program business is.
Thanks pretty much.
>>Nancy Fishman: Thank you.
I love being the bouncer.
So a couple ways that you
can get involved and get some
of these information go to
our website, Readynation.org.
Sign up to get our
resources and information.
There's no cost, we
won't sell your name.
We're not going to have
you come to meetings.
There's no obligation.
One of the resources that we have
available on our website is a brief
that we did for businesses talking
to them about how they can talk
to their employees and
support their employees
in high quality really
education opportunities.
That brief along with
lots of other information
and resources are available there or
just seek Kali-- Kali are yo here?
Kali or I after the event
today and we can connect you
with this valuable resources.
We wanted to leave a minute
and half for questions.
So if a couple of you have a
quick question about the rules?
Two fast questions I
believe are allowed.
>> It's a challenge.
>> Nancy Fishman: It is a challenge.
In the back.
>> For the first time you just
mentioned quality and I think
that was missing from
the discussion earlier.
And I would argue or want you to
give thought to how it's not--
you talk about how parents want
what best for their children,
but the data shows that parents want
accessible, affordable quality--
not quality-- accessible and
affordable care for their children
and so then it's, I think, our
job to bring in the quality
and make sure that that's a part
of everything that's
available [inaudible].
>>Nancy Fishman: And you're right.
And much of our research
does cite the quality.
They are familiar with the
quality aspect of what has to be.
And we did not highlight that today.
It's an important distinction.
Different states define
quality different ways.
Some states don't even
define quality.
All the research shows that the
benefits are greatest for those
who participate in equality
or high quality program.
And it's those high quality programs
where parent engagement is an
inherent part of the program
that we also have an opportunity to
affect two different generations.
Thank you so much.
We should have called that earlier.
I appreciate bringing
that to our attention.
And do you have a quick
question, sir?
>> Well, I try to make it quick.
First of all, excellent
panel, I agree.
I appreciate this every encouraging.
One of the things that I
found in trying to work
to support various educational
programs at least dealing
with governmental bodies.
The state legislators are concerned
that if they invest in education.
They say that we don't know
that these young people will
be here 10 years from now.
Why should we be training young
people who will end up in California
or in New Jersey et cetera?
So my question is have you come in
contact with that kind of sentiment
and how do you counter it and
part of my question also is
with the Chamber of Commerce do you
interact with the National Chamber
of Commerce so they could
really help get that message
to our members of congress as well?
>> Michael Edwards: Now let me just
share with you quickly the message
that I try to give
to our legislators.
If we don't educate the kids
and start them off early,
we're going to be lacking
in our workforce.
And we're already lacking
Seattle as you know is
a high tech community.
We got Microsoft, Amazon,
Expedia, you name it.
But the fastest answer to that
question when I get to ask is
if we don't educate them and give
them an early opportunity we will
continue to import people from
outside of the United States
to fill those critical positions.
And it isn't only the
real high tech community.
It's other things of
manufacturing just
like we had the solar power became
an issue in our state where--
in our nation where we
need to have an increased.
And a lot of our linemen, and
power people that are out there
in our infrastructure
getting the retirement age,
we can't even find people
that are trained well enough,
for school well enough coming
out of our school system
to put those people into those
programs to make it happen.
So, if you want to retain
your intellectual power
and your brain powers and your
resources start them early.
It's like growing a garden.
You put the seed in the
ground and you culture it
and take care of it all the way.
And if you don't some-- yeah,
in some ways it's a long range
program that you're looking at.
But if you don't do
it, you'll end up short
and you'll have to import them.
>> Nancy Fishman: You want
to close us out here Dominic?
>> Dominic Robinson: Sure
just one quick into that
and then I also put the chamber.
I would say that the other
argument relative to, you know,
why would we invest in these folks
when we don't know we're
going to able retain them.
Statistically speaking, you
know, yes, there's always kind
of churn in the population.
But the majority of the
population is raised
in a geography does
in fact stay there.
So I think you can also
just point to the statistics
that in fact more often
than not that's a good bet.
And I would agree with
everything you else--
you said that, I think that your
question around, for example,
our relationship to the
US Chamber of Commerce
or other national chamber
type organizations.
It's an important question because
we often associate chamber voice,
especially nationally, with a
voice that isn't always hospitable
to these types of conversations.
I think that it's a
slowly changing dynamic.
But I do think that there's
at least a greater awareness
that these things cannot
be disconnected forever.
I was invited to, but was not able
to attend an event here in DC.
I think in the fall that
was a co-sponsored event
between the US chamber and NAACP,
I believed, kind of talking
about where their organizational
interest might align.
And I thought that was a
really encouraging sign.
So I think that the reality is
that we often feel like outliers
within a broader kind
of chamber conversation
that only underscores our need
to kind of continue to kind
of use our platform as best we can.
>> Nancy Fishman: Thank you
all so much for having us.
We appreciate your interest.
>> Karen Baicker: Thank you.
>> Michael Edwards: Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> John Cole: Well, that was
a wonderful different kind
of insight for all of us.
And I want to thank ReadyNation
and thank our panel so much.
Our final panel is also going
to be different and interesting,
Technology and Other
Innovative Solutions.
As Tony brings his panel members
up, let's take a brief three
or four minute break as they get
settled up here and we will conclude
with Technology and Other
Innovative Solutions.
Thank you again.
It's my pleasure to-- one of the
ways that we put this together is
through partnerships that already
exist and through new partnerships
and I want to thank Laura Nemours
for getting the last
panel helping us so much
which I think will
be a new partnership
for the Center for the Book.
But we also are making use of
some of our own board members,
Laura is one and Tony Bloome who is
chairing this panel on technology
and literacy is also part of
our literacy advisory board.
He works for aids and has a
wonderful project that is going
to be described as
part of the program.
I'll turn it over to Tony.
Tony? Let's give him a little
applause to get him going.
>> Anthony Bloome: All right.
I haven't really done anything
yet but I appreciate it, so.
All right.
So it's the last panel of the day
and so you guys have been faithful
to sit through a bunch of
interesting conversations.
But there's probably somebody
in the room that you don't know.
So I'd like to use five minute
of our presentation time for you
to introduce you somebody in
the room that you don't know
and tell them about a favorite
book that read recently.
You have five minutes please begin.
So great. I wanted to start with
that because obviously being able
to meet somebody new be able
to share your experiences
about the book that you've read and
how important obviously the theme
of today is about literacy
and how important it is
that we can extend the opportunities
for individuals around the world
to have acces to literacy.
I'm excited to have the three
representatives of the organizations
that will be speaking with us
today to talk about various uses
of technology that we
can make access to health
and the general literacy
available to a variety of learners
and using some creative
technology options as well.
So typical with the other format.
We'll start with a few comments
from our individual panelists.
But then I would really like
to open it up into a dialogue
for organizations here to be able
to share their own experiences
around a specific concept of how
can we use technology cost effective
and sustainably to
reach this audience
to promote and accelerate literacy.
And so can learn as much from you
about the work you're
doing as you can from us.
So I'm delighted to welcome
to my immediate left,
Judy Dixon who's a Consumer
Relations Officer right here
at the Library of Congress.
Judith did I see you that you've
been working here for 35 years?
That's enormously exciting.
Who you can't see is her
friend Potter who's I guess
on the other-- oh, you can see that.
So we're going to have
you invent a story
about what the tale came
from, but you can-- so.
And Judith will be talking
to us about the services
that her office provides including
for braille and talking books.
And then has brought some toys, some
devices that she'll show us as well.
So Judith in just a moment welcome
you to walk us through that.
And then next to Judith is
Linda Harris who's Director
of Health Communications
and eHealth,
the Office of Disease
Prevention and Health Promotion
at the US Department of
Health and Human Services.
And Linda I know you'll be
talking about designing access
to information for individuals
with limited literacy,
in particular in terms
of health literacy.
And then finally to my far left is
a good friend and colleague of mine,
Rebecca Leege who's
the project director
of an initiative called the All
Children Reading Grand Challenge
for development4, which specifically
is looking at the use of technology
to advance early grade reading
in developing countries
around the world.
And Rebecca I know you've been at
organizations like World Vision
but also World Relief in
a variety of capacities,
exploring how to bring education
to marginalized populations
around the world.
So without further ado, Judith
can I turn it over to you just
to walkthrough, tell us about
some of the toys that you have.
>> Judith Dixon: Down here?
>> Linda Harris: It's-- you
got it on the front-- yes.
>> Judith Dixon: Oh, there, OK.
Thank you very much.
Good afternoon everyone.
I am from the National Library
Service as Tony indicated,
at a National Service for the
Blind and Physically Handicapped.
We're part of the Library
of Congress.
We've been in existence since 1931.
And our role is to create
talking books and braille books.
What we do is select them and
produce them and then we give them
out to libraries around the country
who actually circulate
them to individuals.
So the idea here is people
who don't read print either
because of a visual or a physical
disability are literate, yes, no.
We have this debate all
the time in my office.
If somebody doesn't read print
but they access information
by listening, are they literate?
I would say yes.
There are people who
actually would say no.
But literacy is a challenge
because the world is
designed for print readers.
So this is health literacy
in a different way.
It's not just people
who can't communicate,
most blind people can
communicate just fine.
It's a matter of not being
access-- able to access print.
So we do braille and talking books.
And we do have books about health.
As a matter of fact, I
did a search this morning.
And in our national collection
we have 1168 audio books
and 381 braille books
specifically the topic of health.
We have player, our
talking books are--
I'm going to hold this up and
they are recorded on a cartridge
which that actually is
just a USB flash drive.
Most of them have labels.
This one isn't because I
created it this morning.
>> Player on.
Health and Nutrition Newsletters.
February 2016.
Current position, jogging and
health, easier than you may think.
Jogging and health,
easier than you may think.
>> Judith Dixon: Now,
we can actually--
>> Reading time six minutes.
>> Judith Dixon: We
can skip through.
>> Second opinion.
Special report, supplement
to Mayo Clinic health letter.
Vision. Article jump.
I health section.
Jump. Phrase.
Bookmark. Jump.
Unit. Jump.
As-- End of book.
Within. Mayo Clinic health letter.
Scientific American health after 50.
>> Judith Dixon: So what this
is is a monthly compilation
of health newsletters.
One of the reasons we don't have
more health books than we do is
because health topics come and go.
And our library and
they're very concerned
about the books being up-to-date
and accurate and current.
So magazines and current health
newsletter type items are a good way
to do that to give people
up to date information.
So that's one way that a
blind person can access print.
Another way-- There
are many other ways.
There are actually lots of ways.
And it's a matter of what is
this information available in.
So people can use computers to
access material that's online.
Smartphones, we actually have an app
for our talking books
called BARD mobile.
And people can download our books
also through a service called BARD.
And I normally make this
presentation in about two hours.
So I'm trying to summarize that
I can tell you so much more
about anyone of these things.
But I did bring some handouts.
There are fact sheets about our
program, application for service
and things like that back
on your handout table.
So the program, there's lots of ways
that have blind person
can access information.
Now, what you may not know is this
is an iPhone, a regular old iPhone
that you get at the Apple store.
And every single iPhone has on it
a screen reader called VoiceOver.
And every iPhone can talk.
>> Messages, contacts.
>> Judy Dixon: Fortunately
I hope I don't--
>> Double tap to open, messages,
double tap to open, app switcher,
blind fold solid, messages,
act digitize, mail,
active, igloo, WebMD, active.
>> Judy Dixon: So--
>> Medicine button,
WebMD, icon nav, button.
>> Judy Dixon: I know
you can't see the screen
of this iPhone so you
can just listen.
This is probably a little fast.
Actually let me--
>> Language.
>> Judy Dixon: I can
even scroll it down.
>> Headings, audio ducking, volume,
speech rate, words, speech 51-- 46%.
>> Judy Dixon: There.
That might--
>> Icon nav, button search
WebM-- symptoms checker, button,
medication reminders, button,
conditions, button, medicine,
button, refill and
transfer prescriptions by--
first aid information, button.
>> Judy Dixon: So this is WebMD,
a regulator mainstream
off the shelf app.
>> ETN back arrow.
>> Judy Dixon: I can
double tap on it.
>> First aid, button, search
first aid, table index,
adjust abdominal pain in adults,
abdominal pain in children,
acetaminophen, Tylenol,
poisoning, alcohol intoxication,
allergic reaction,
amputation, accidental.
>> Judy Dixon: I was
reading this this morning
and said amputation,
accidental, oh my.
That's sounds rather
major, you know.
>> ETN back arrow.
>> Judy Dixon: I'm
going to go to my iPhone
if I'm accidentally
amputated something.
You know. So--
>> 41%. Walk-- have the
injured person lie down.
If possible don't reposition the
person if you suspect the head,
neck, back or leg injury.
>> Judy Dixon: If I
haven't fallen down.
Yes. So-- But that's
an incredible tool
for accessibility of information.
Finding-- It can do tons
of other things, too.
But just a mainstream app like WebMD
that has good health information.
Hush now, you're done.
So that's another.
Accessing printed material
is one thing.
But another major issue for people
who don't see is identification
of things, labels all
this print, its--
everything is labeled in print.
One way to identify kind
of mainstream items.
This--
[ Music and Machine Talking ]
This is a barcode reader.
But it's special barcode reader.
So I have this box.
What is this box?
Who knows?
I just damn no idea it's just a box.
And so I can-- I'll try to do this.
[ Machine Talking ]
I should be able to
hear what it says.
[ Machine Talking ]
Now that speech might be
slightly off putting for people
who don't listen to
synthetic speech all the time.
But for someone who does it's
actually pretty understandable.
There's a lot of information
in a barcode.
[ Machine Talking ]
So it tells you how to take it,
how often all the things about it.
And this-- you're done, too.
These things don't
know when to shut up.
There are barcodes
on tons of things.
I mean, I actually take this a
little device to the grocery store
and use it on items and just
regular items in the grocery store.
And there's also apps on my
iPhone that can do the same thing.
They're a little bit
more difficult to use
because they're little bit more
difficult to find the barcode.
But the process is the same.
So now we have-- this is
device called the ScriptTalk.
Coincidentally made
by the same company
that the barcode reader was
made by En-Vision America
but this is a device for reading
the labels on prescription bottles.
It has to be created
every Rite Aid Pharmacy
in the United States
can now provide this
to their subscribers or customers.
And the way this works
is with RFID tags.
>> ScripTalk Station ready.
>> Judith Dixon: Right.
So all I have to do is put
the bottle on the device.
>> Patient, John Jay
Smith medication.
Amoxicillin 250 milligram capsule.
Instructions; take one
capsule three times daily--
>> Judith Dixon: And again
you can skip through.
>> Prescription date.
Use by March first 2017.
Refills remaining, prescriber,
ScriptAbility pharmacy.
To reorder this prescription,
prescription number, warning,
important, finish of
this medication.
>> Judith Dixon: So they
also have other kinds
of pill bottles with large print.
This bottle has a large
print and a brand label.
Brand label only says
the name of the person.
I hope they actually
put more on it than that
because the person
probably knows who they are.
It's the name of the
medication that would be useful.
But these Rite Aids now can do
either large print brand labels
or use-- provide the
person with a ScriptTalk.
And the last items-- there are
lots of talking devices these days.
There are talking glucose monitors.
There are talking thermometers,
talking scales,
talking everything under the sun.
This happens to be--
>> Low.
>> Judith Dixon: -- talking.
>> Your body temperature
is 98.1 degrees Fahrenheit.
>> Judith Dixon: It's close enough.
Again, the speech-- where the
speaker in this foolish thing.
Looks like I'm going to do it again.
Come on you can do it.
>> Your body temperature
is 90 degrees Fahrenheit.
But if you use it right
it probably will work.
So this is just-- again there is
talking blood pressure monitors
and talking, you name it,
there's talking almost everything.
A lot of this stuff-- one of
the challenges is for people
who are deaf-blind because there
is a bazillion things that talk.
But it's a lot harder for
people who also don't hear.
So there are devices like
that have-- that are--
this is refreshable braille display.
And the pins raise and lower
depending on what's on the screen.
And the downside of these
they are very, very expensive.
But it is device that's
really useful
and can be paired via
Bluetooth with a smartphone
or with some of these other devices.
Not our talking book
machine the best example
of the things I have here is that
it can be paired with smartphone
and anything that's
displayed on the smart phone
or anything that's displayed
on a computer screen can
also be read in braille.
So this is a way that people
who are deaf-blind have
of accessing information
that's typically in print.
OK.
>> Anthony Boome: Great.
Well, thank you so much Judith
for brining a bunch of toys
to share with us important.
And I wonder if you ever
in your office do they start
having an exchange with each other?
>> Judith Dixon: No
but they do at home.
>> Anthony Bloome: You have
to tell them to all be quite.
And so we will have an opportunity
for questions and answers
afterwards.
So with a hope that you
would have some specific
for Judy I know I have
several as well.
Judy thanks for kicking us off
with really important discussion
about range of technologies that
can make a literacy materials more
accessible by variety of learners.
Linda, can I turn it over to you?
I know you have some slides as
well to talk to us about access
to health literacy
and other resources.
>> Linda Harris: Yeah,
I think I can--
I will see if I can see the screen.
Is that the title of
my presentation?
OK, good. I'm going to talk about
what we can learn from people
with limited literacy about
designing the interface
for the technologies that we use
to access health information.
And it turns out we can learn a lot.
I'm the Office of Disease
Prevention and Health Promotion.
And so the consumer is really
an important part of being able
to prevent disease and
promote their own health.
So that's why we pay a lot
of attention to the consumer.
And so what I'm going to talk with
you about real quickly is that some
of the research that we've done
on people with limited literacy
and limited health literacy,
so the first thing I thought
I would just kind of share
with you is the difference.
You'll see that-- You've
probably heard
that half the population
struggle with reading.
But-- oops.
I'm sorry I can't see
what I'm showing you.
[ Inaudible Discussion ]
Can you -- hold on.
OK. So this is the slide--
oh, great thank you.
Yeah. So this is half the
population struggles with reading.
But 90% of the population struggles
with health literacy that is
that only about 90% of us.
90% of us struggle
at sometime, 10%--
about 10 to 12% of us
are always proficient
and understanding the
complexity of health information.
And so we have a lot to work
with because of this challenge
that almost all of us have.
Health information is a little
bit different from other kinds
of information is that
it's inherently complex.
It comes from the medical
kind of language.
And it's also inherently stressful.
So when we're trying to
understand health information we--
even if we have-- those of us who
have advance degrees and we think
that we're really very literate when
the time comes to get that diagnosis
and it's really personal and
eventful for us then our ability
to process information
kind of goes up the window.
So we designed for everybody
and what I'm going to talk
about with you about is how we--
how our understanding of
people with limited literacy
and limited health literacy
is helping us create that sort
of that cyber curve
cut for all of us.
I'm going to show just a
couple of screen shots.
This is in our research,
our usability research.
And this is a picture,
a graph of what it looks
like when you're tracking--
doing eye tracking of just a
regular person who's fully literate.
So you can see how they're
moving their eyes along the page.
And now I'm going to show
you eye tracking of somebody
who is challenged with reading.
So you see how inefficient they
are, how they're struggling
to try to find the point.
And so this is accompanied with
usually with limited memory.
And so what am I reading and how
am I to understand this information
and then once I think I've got it
how do I remember what I've read.
This is a question that lots
of people with limited literacy
and limited health literacy are
asking themselves all the time.
So, we know that we have an enormous
challenge to work with people
with limited to provide
meaningful access
to health information among those
who are limited in their reading
and limited in their
health literacy.
But we've learned some really
interesting things about those folks
because we've really started
paying a lot of attention to them.
We have been interviewing
and working one to one
with over 800 folks most
of them have either limited health
literacy or limited literacy.
And so here are some a few
things that we've learned.
People with limited literacy
are willing to use the web
and it's important to them to use
the web for health information.
They're able to accomplished tasks
when the websites are design
well and this is really key.
We can make this accessible to
people if we really make the effort.
And then the third thing that
I'm drill down on a little bit is
that people with literacy
seem to prefer mobile.
So I'm going to just go
into that a little bit more
and I tell little bit
why we think that's true.
People with limited literacy
usually prefer mobile.
It seems that the reading
is easier for them.
We think that may be because
the sentences are short.
And there is some evidence that
the tactile experience also helps
process that information when you're
using a mobile app or a phone.
So I'm going to quickly share with
you what we think is the definition
of health literacy
once-- now that I've kind
of told you what we are learning
about people with limited literacy
and limited health literacy.
We do not think that it is all that
useful to defined health literacy
as a deficit that those of us who
are struggling have with reading
or with health information.
We prefer, we at HHSS, and that
includes Rob and Logan and those
of us who are in the Department
of Health and Human Services.
We prefer to think of health
literacy as defined as that match
between what the health
organization or the publisher,
or the source of health information
provides and the way they provide it
and our ability to find, understand,
and use that information.
So, what's that means for us is that
the responsibly is really on those
of us who published
information to design it well.
And that's why we have started
with people with limited literacy
and limited health
literacy to define--
to develop a guide we call
it Health Literacy Online:
A Guide for Simplifying
the User Experience.
And that's where we brought these
800 folks together-- not together--
but individually these
are not surveys.
These are actually working
with people watching
them use the technology
and the interfaces for websites.
And this guide is--
was just published
in October the second version of it.
And it offers those folks
who are developing any
interface whether it's a web
or a mobile app ways that we can
design that interface in ways
that almost everybody who
can read, who can understand,
who can process information
at a simple level can
find meaningful access
to the information
on that technology.
So, it we-- it comes with
a checklist that I have--
I brought the checklist with
so want to take a look at it.
I'm not going to go
into that right now.
But you'll see that's it's base--
it's an evidence-based guide
based not only on the folks
that we've been telling you--
that I've been telling about.
But also on the literature that
we've been referred to people
with limited literacy,
people with disabilities,
and people with limited
health literacy.
So I'm going to just finally
close with giving you an example
of the kind of interface that we're
working and Judy we should talk
because we'd love to have this
at the Library of Congress.
Our-- As I mentioned to
you we're in the Office
of Disease Prevention
Health Promotion.
One of the websites we have for the
public is called healthfinder.gov.
And so we've used these
guides, these criteria
to develop health literacy
of healthfinder.gov.
That website is really the
department faced to the public
for the preventive services that
we all need are covered by ACA.
So, it's really important
that we get that right and so
that everybody needs to
have the preventive services
and because they're free.
It's really important for us to
make it so easy to use that anyone
who can use the web or can use
an app will find this very easy
to access.
So as I will close by saying,
there's a lot more work to do,
we would love to work with the
disability community as well,
work with the children
who are actually helping
us understand about design.
Because what we really believe
is that if you design with--
forget about grade level, you really
design by engaging people who have--
who are challenged with reading
and with health literacy,
ask them to help you
design the interface.
That's really the most
important thing you can do.
So all of those of you who
are working with people
with limited literacy, with
limited health literacy,
and with disabilities, we hope that
you'll encourage them to be a part
of the design process
and the information
or health information
that's important to them.
>> Anthony Bloome: Thank you Linda.
And then a really nice segue
from talking about devices
that can make information accessible
that Judy was talking about to those
who are creating the content, Linda,
to make sure that it's
also accessible.
So obviously the connection
as you've mentioned in terms
of the types of audiences.
So Rebecca, let's just-- let's go
overseas and talk about sort of some
of the challenges we face as part
of the All Children Reading Grand
Challenge and our literacy efforts
that are involving technology
for all the grade learners.
>> Rebecca Chandler Leege: Great.
I'm going to take a pulse
check, who has worked
in an office overseas in the room?
One person?
Great. Have anybody
visited programs overseas
that work on literacy projects?
OK. Thank you.
So as Tony mentioned, I'm Rebecca
Leege, worked with World Vision.
For those that may not be
familiar with World Vision,
we are an international relief and
development organization and focused
on multi-sectors, education
being a key component of ours.
We join the All Children Reading
Grand Challenge five years ago
at the partnership
between USAID, World Vision
and the Australian government.
And it was really premised on
the notion of, can we use science
and technology to offer
and breakthrough
for early grade reading
in developing countries?
We as three agencies with very
similar strategies weren't cracking
the code.
There were still 250 million
children as we know without reading.
There are one in-- or 80% of
children with disabilities are
in developing countries, 3% of
those have access to school.
So many opportunities
for trying to make break
through advancements in that space.
So as I just mentioned, we've
been around for five years
and we have started to see some
very interesting application
of technologies in various sectors
and I just though I
highlight three of those.
The three areas that we wanted
to focus on to help improve
because we know as listening even
to the business panel and apologize
that I cannot be here all day.
But it is about parent
and community engagement.
It's about having the right quality
materials and it's also ensuring
that we have inclusion
of all children
in that process that
no one is excluded.
And we all know it's our
human right to have literacy.
We also know it unlocks
our potential.
And listening to the business,
we're constantly trained to make
that case overseas as well to those
companies in developing countries
that say we don't have the workforce
talent and we say to ministries
but you're also not investing
in the education system
to build that next generation.
So these are three focus areas.
For those of you who have grown up
in the states, we've quite familiar
with Sesame Street, right?
And they have done a great job
in helping educate many
children in this country.
They have taken their model in many
countries but primarily in India
where they have developed
recognizing one their population
need to improve reading in
that country, they have taken
and developed and contextualized the
whole Sesame Street messaging called
Galli Galli Sim Sim.
It rolls off the tongue
very nicely, too.
They have done everything
from creating e-reader,
I mean e-publish books for
e-readers to just simple games.
We had asked for their high
tech version of a phone,
one of those [inaudible]
and they sent us PVC piping.
And I thought, oh, this was not
what I was expecting to see.
But how clever, something
that is very low tech,
affordable that can be
sourced in the community
so that children can start to hear
themselves, practice their reading.
They're currently working on
a mobile app which is designed
to be utilized at the home,
they're working self-help groups
primarily women that are focused
on health issues or
livelihood issues
and introducing it their
engagement in the reading process
with their child and then giving
them tools through an application
on a very low-end smart phone
to begin practice their reading.
We're really excited to
see how that will roll out.
With any of these projects, one
thing that is lacking at least
in the developing countries
is research.
Research to say, does this
app really make any difference
or is it-- I mean we know it's
great, the kids like to play
on games and that has value.
But can it demonstrate
any improvement
in their reading outcomes.
And so we are tagging all
of our grant programing
to some robust research on that.
And we hope the findings
are positive.
But, you know, it's a good thing
to at least start to define what
that process is, the
contextualization
of the assessment process,
and so forth.
The second one I wanted
to highlight is related
to our children with disabilities.
This is a group IDRT, Institute for
Disabilities Research and Training.
They're based out of
in Wheaton, Maryland.
It's women owned business
that has worked
with the National Science
Foundation and others.
But they have partnered
with a group in Morocco.
And they feel very passionate
that there's software application
that was really trying to articulate
a way to document sign language
of a language to be utilized
to create materials for deaf
and low hearing in
various countries.
So they're partnering with
the Institute of Morocco.
The next slide kind of
shows you what it will be.
So you get an idea of just defining
what it is, how it can be used
in the market place and then
they actually have a video
of someone signing it.
And then their training teachers
and the deaf associations on how
to create their own stories and
began to allow material for deaf.
It's also a way for them to
teach many parents sign language
because many of them don't
actually know sign and even how
to teach their children, right.
So it serves multiple purposes.
USAID Morocco is highly
engaged in this in funding
and it's been really supported by
the Ministry of Education there
as they're seeing it as
a potential model to roll
out throughout the whole country.
We also see it as an
opportunity to replicate
because it's also based off
of modern standard Arabic
which is used throughout the whole
North Africa and Middle East World.
My last example is really on how
to use source a new technology
and I really appreciate
Linda's focus and attention
on user experience and
simplifying tools for those
that have low literacy levels.
We put a challenge out 18 months
ago, almost two years ago to say,
can someone source an authoring
tool that could be used
in developing countries by
individuals with 20 hours
of training but embedded in
that technology is the decoding
and leveling framework of books.
There are lot of authoring tools
out there, some are very fancy,
but when you're in the
middle of South Sudan working
with an elementary school teacher,
it's unlikely that she's going
to navigate a device that requires
connectivity as well as something
that is highly-- I'm going to say
fancy, right, it has all the bells
and whistles and it's
almost overwhelming.
So we put this challenge out.
We had nine different teams
around the globe that competed.
And we ended up-- we have
a demonstration to hand.
Thank you.
We'll do that in a second.
We awarded it to a
group called SILV.
For those that may be familiar
with SILV are a linguist
organization that's been
around over 60 years.
They're probably are the ones that
have documented the most languages.
They have also worked at
that very grassroots level
to know what could be
achievable in a software system.
And so what we do like about it,
though it looks kind of low tech
in some ways is that it is easy to
adopt-- I mean it's easy to learn.
We run our first training on it
in Ethiopia at the end of January
and we did a usability study
and assessment process.
And it scored quite high
because they said it's simple,
we can master it, we understand
what we're supposed to do
and it already identifies
the decoding
and leveled elements for us.
So we're not questioning, is this
book appropriate for grade one
or grade three, it's
defined in that space.
So we're very excited
about this tool
for beginning to roll out process.
We think it has multiple
usages, one even here in DC.
We know that there's like--
if we look at Diaspora here
in DC we can envision engaged
in the Ethiopian community to
contribute back reading materials.
Basically, as we look
at the vast materials
and I don't Scholastic still in the
room but great to hear it from Nancy
that I know they do a lot
of work overseas and partner
with many of us as organizations.
But even with large publishing
firms, there are no resources
and enough or little resources
in local languages are we need
to ensure that children actually
have something that they can hold
and read and practice in a
language that they understand.
I think that's it.
Tony has a thumb drive here and
we've been passing these out
and I didn't think to bring,
so if anybody wants it.
The software is free.
If anybody wants to-- online
let me see if I put it in here.
I didn't put it in
here, sorry, bloom--
I can give it to you but it's,
you know, if you're interested
in downloading it it's
very simple to open
and start to create your own book.
It might be kind of fun to do with
any children that you might have
or some youth that you
want to give them a task
to write a book for a child.
Thank you.
>> Anthony Bloome: Thank you Rebecca
and maybe just a round of applause
for the three presenters.
[ Applause ]
So I'm going to put
the honors on you guys.
We've heard about some
really interesting examples
of assistive technologies,
designing content
that it could be accessible
particularly
for a low literacy audiences
and international projects
that are looking at
the use of technology
to accelerate early grade reading.
Do you have any questions
for our panelist in regards
to what you've just heard?
>> Yes.
>> Anthony Bloome: And if you
could please introduce yourself
and your organization again for
our benefit that'd be terrific.
>> Thank you those were all really,
really informative and great.
I'm Laura Bailey I direct in
a Morse BrightStar program.
I'm also on the Literacy
Awards with Tony and, you know,
the winner of the Rubinstein Prize
in our second year was Room to Read.
And I don't know if your
organization works with Room to Read
and all that I know one component
of their program is they train--
they work in Third World Countries,
mainly Southeast Asia I think,
and they train local people
to write children's books
in the mother tongue, it
seems like there might--
and they're pretty tech
shabby too, so I didn't--
that's just a connection
point so I don't know
if you guys are working together--
>> Rebecca Chandler Leege:
We do connect with them
and we do greatly value
their expertise
in what they're producing, yes.
>> Oh, good.
That's great to hear.
>> Rebecca Chandler Leege:
They'll be working with us
on a writer's workshop
this summer in Cambodia.
>> And then I just had a question
that it's kind of been percolating
through several of the sessions the
woman who spoke about the response
to the Ebola crisis
earlier today and maybe some
of you may not have been
here for that, but she talked
about the importance of public
messaging through radio.
And, you know, that audio for people
with visual impairment
or low literacy.
Audio I think is such a great and
readily available way to message
to large numbers of people but
I don't know that we're using
that in the US very much anymore,
it seems like everything has gone
to texting and visual on
devices so I don't know if anyone
in the audience has a
perspective on the value of audio
for public health kinds of things
or other international
examples of that.
>> Anthony Bloome: Boy that's
terrific and just noting relations
and partners the importance and
then maybe Judy a question for you
in regards to audio as well
as others in the audience.
Let's take a few questions and
then ask the panelist it looked
like there is somebody
else who had--
if you could introduce
yourself that'd be terrific.
>> Sure. Actually it was
a comment and invitation.
I'm Dr. Sandra Charles,
physician here at the Library
of Congress running the occupation
and health services office
and that we each may have a wellness
fair in which we invite a number
of different organizations,
vendors to partner with us
and have an exposition where
they off-show their services.
And I'm thinking also disease
prevention would be an excellent
partner in helping people
and spreading the word
about what's available for people
to use in terms of literacy
and health literacy in particular
because that's one of our main
for us wellness and health promotion
and we are constantly
promoting health literacy.
And in fact in addition to
that wellness fair in August
with your family health and wellness
day where we ask employees to bring
in their family members
to also be exposed
to the different things available
in terms of health and I think both
of those would be excellent
for expounding
in health literacy and improving it.
And we certainly would like to
have Judy bring over so the rest
of the Library because
we know she exist.
We go out there to the National
Library but I really think the rest
of the Library ought to be aware
of those things too, so thank you.
>> Anthony Bloome:
Thank you Dr. Charles.
Great.
>> Rob Logan, National
Library of Medicine.
I think this one is more for
Linda but anybody can answer it.
One of the challenges that I think
that we have when we do MedlinePlus
and I think it's similar
to what challenge you have
in Healthfinder is it would
be a much better website
if we knew the role in which
people were using it were in.
Are you here as a caregiver
for example, OK?
Are you here as a patient, OK?
Are you here as a parent, OK?
And I believe if we could provide
a totally different website
with different orientation
based on the role
and the reason why people were
there in the first place, OK?
I believe our materials
would even be better utilized
than they are now.
I think that's beyond our techno
capacity at the time but it occurs
to me that I still haven't seen
anyone, you know, take advantage
of the fact that our needs
with health information
or requirements differed
depending on the role
that we're in when we're seeking.
>> Anthony Bloome: Thank you Rob.
OK, so I heard a few-- first
of all a great recommendations
in and suggestions.
Thank you.
So I heard three questions
maybe I'll address
to each of the panelist.
Linda, clearly in terms of the
role of the audience that's coming
to the websites, Judy if
you wanted to elaborate
on perhaps some other radio or
audio laced related technologies.
I heard you mentioned
was it BARD Mobile,
so that'd be interesting maybe to
mention a little bit more about.
And then Rebecca just on the subject
of partnerships, we heard an example
of a partner but what role
partnerships have in regards
to the activity of
all children reading.
So maybe let's start with Judy.
>> Judy Dixon: Yes thank you.
Audio is certainly an
important way to communicate
to everyone including people
with visual impairment.
You're right in that
radio as certainly
in commercial radio is not
used as much as it once was.
I don't think people listen to
radio as much as they once did.
But there is also a network of radio
reading services throughout the
United States that is used
to communicate various things
to the visual impaired audience
but these are primarily people
who are long time well-established
visually impaired people not
so much reaching people who just
have a little difficulty seeing.
That's the population that's
very difficult to reach
and that's a population that really
needs that kind of information.
>> Anthony Bloome: I
would also give you--
>> Judy Dixon: Oh, BARD Mobile, yes.
It's a mobile app and I'm
wondering I had a question
for Linda as far as mobile apps.
There are mobile apps that are not
possible for me to use on my iPhone
so I'm hoping that
when you provide advice
about developing mobile apps
you also make sure to point
out that they need to be made
accessible with voiceover
because not all apps are.
So that's an important thing.
But we have an app for playing
our talking books and real books
on smartphones and all of our audio
books and real books can be played
on that so that's possible.
We have the iOS version of that
it's been out for about two years
and we just released
an Android version.
>> Anthony Bloome: Thank you Judy.
Linda?
>> Linda M. Harris: Yeah I would
just-- to Judy's point, you know,
we are really committed to complying
with the 508 kind of regulations
and rules and so that
is a part of everything
that we design and recommend.
And I only wish that
everybody was willing to step
up to those kinds of standards.
To Rob, to your question,
actually Rob
and I together I guess represent
two of the library sources,
sources of information
to the public.
Our Healthfinder is
really about prevention
and of course the MedlinePlus at
the Library of Medicine is for kind
of managing chronic conditions
and understanding how the
rest of the health span.
So, we are often in conversations
about how do we do better
at understanding our audience.
And I think what we've kind of come
to the conclusion we and our part
of the department is that
that is you really want
to have a trusting relationship
between the source and the audience.
And that's probably
not the best role
for the government
to try to fulfill.
And so as a result we have really
been focusing on partnering
with others who have
websites and we have content--
we've indicated our content
so that other websites can
take it into their websites.
They are the ones who
are on the ground.
have customers,
constituents who already trust them.
And so I'm, you know, we're
kind of thinking If you can--
we, the government with the, you
know, the NIH of the department
who have the science backing that
information can make it available
and it's indicated to those folks
who have the personal relationship
with those folks then that smart
interface could really be useful
so that you get to know the
people that you're talking with.
We do that in partnership
with CVS for example if you go
to the MinuteClinic
you'll see my Healthfinder
on the MinuteClinic
you will, you know,
it'll be easy to use
there as it is here.
So I appreciate your question Rob,
I think it's a really important path
to go down but we've chosen to
take that partnership path rather
than trying to do the whole--
create those trusting relationships
between the federal
government and the individual.
>> Rebecca Chandler Leege: And
partnership, partnership is key
and it's kind of the premise
of a grand challenge is
that we much work together
collaboratively we must seek new
problem solvers.
We've used prize competitions really
because it attracts the private
sector, attracts entrepreneurs,
attracts those not typically in the
space to help us create a solution
and I really appreciate
recommendations that's part
of our goal as an entity as
an initiative is really just
to start creating the voice
and starting to understand
where we can be at a catalyst for
new partnerships in collaboration
as well as start to replicate and
adopt promising practices here
in the US or in other places
that can be replicated
in developing countries.
>> Anthony Bloome:
Thank you Rebecca.
So I wanted to ask a question
of each of the panelist as well.
We're in this center of
knowledge, the Library of Congress.
We've just created a Library of
Congress Magic Wand, right, John,
just being a question
of another prize.
So what would you like to see as a
breakthrough activity or innovation
in your respective areas that
could help you accelerate your
own initiatives?
I know I had asked
them this every time
and it'd be interesting
what they come up with.
But what would you like
to see just as something--
>> Rebecca Chandler
Leege: If I do let's start.
>> Anthony Bloome: --
yeah, something transformative
maybe it's a technology,
maybe it's a user Linda or--
and Rebecca maybe it's a new
partner just what is an example
of something you'd like to see
once we've made wave the Magic Wand
for Library of Congress.
Linda you got something?
>> Judy Dixon: I'll go first.
>> Anthony Bloome: Judy.
>> Judy Dixon: I think--
Just we were just talking about
accessibility and Linda mentions
that they use 508 but the current
508 guidelines were developed
in 1998 and they have been working
on a refresh for the last 18 years
and they're supposedly
close but who knows.
Accessibility is a very complex is
very complex and very thorny issue
and extremely frustrating.
It's frequent that I can go
to websites that I can't use.
It's frequent that I can download
a mobile app that I can't use.
So, if I was going to wave a
Magic Wand I would just get rid
of all the accessibility barriers,
get rid of Flash and get rid of Java
and all these other
technological barriers that are used
to make websites always banging,
pretty and exciting and fun
and our-- for the most part
barriers to blind people.
>> Anthony Bloome:
Great, thank you Judy.
Linda?
>> Linda M. Harris: Well I think
that the reach of the Library
of Congress is just remarkable
and I've been trying to think
about how could we better
make our information available
through the Library of Congress?
I mean, we have the websites and
the sources of health information
in the department, is
really precious I think.
It's updated constantly.
It's the best of the science
that we have translating
that into understandable
and actionable information
is what we try to do.
But our real limitation is
really reaching people who are,
you know, where they live.
And if I had a Magic Wand I
would distribute the Library
of Congress' reach, I mean,
facilities and capabilities
for making that information more
accessible to people where they are
in their homes not
just here or not just
in their library but in their homes.
>> Anthony Bloome:
Great, thank you Linda.
>> Rebecca Chandler Leege:
Maybe a little bit on that line
of accessibility just for your
say Linda is I think I would love
for there to be some approach or
breakthrough for urgencies creating
that urgency that we need
to be educating our next
generation in a way.
And I struggle with
trying to articulate
that message we know reading is
a long process it doesn't happen,
you know, take a pill
and we all read.
I wish it were that simple.
But really creating that sense
of urgency for our future
because of the trend is that
we have more and more countries
with children that cannot
read our world is not going
to become a more stable place and
we need to figure out ways fast
in which we can make that
breakthrough and really start
to change generations that are good
to move forward and be our leaders.
>> Is it OK to have an audience
member to answer that question?
>> Anthony Bloome: Oh yeah.
>> OK. Because I got a totally
[inaudible], right, medicine,
totally different answer, OK,
and I think there is something
that could be done that would
be I think transformative.
One of the most impressive health
care organizations in the US
in my opinion is the Southcentral
Foundation in Anchorage, Alaska.
And I won't go into detail to
why they are impressive but one
of the things that they do is
they serve a medically underserved
population mostly Native Alaskans
and what they gone out to do
in order to improve health care
there is to first give the people
who live there a sense
of pride in who they are
and their own heritage,
their own background.
They have begun to realize that
a sense of pride in who you are,
a sense of your own history,
a sense of your own community,
a sense of what their
challenges are and I'm not going
to go more detail about it.
It's fundamental to giving people
interest in their own health,
taking care of themselves,
taking care of their families.
You can't put the cart before
the horse is what they've argued
for years.
Now translate that into
something that the Library
of Congress could uniquely do.
Why should you be proud if you're
from a low income area
in Philadelphia?
Why should you be proud
if you're in to it?
Why should you be proud if
you're this providing a place
where people could go?
The story of various different
demographic wake grounds
and groups people in this country,
something they could look at
and really develop some pride,
some ownership in, some interest,
tell people how to-- where they
can go from there to learn more.
I'm not going to go in
more detail about it
but I don't know what
resource like anywhere.
I don't know any organization
in this country or frankly
for the Ed Med or any country
that has the kind of resources
that this place had that
could do something like that.
>> Anthony Bloome:
Well thank you Rob.
So John, all these people
are waving their Magic Wands.
Our session is done but I would
say in this period of partnership,
you know, we found particularly
with the [inaudible]
grand challenge model.
If you have a problem there's good
will and there's people out there
that are probably have some ideas
to help you achieve a solution.
So I want to thank once again and
ask you to please join me in a round
of applause for our three panelists.
[ Applause ]
And invite John to come back up.
Thank you.
>> John Cole: Well first a
couple of thank yous to everybody
for sticking it out with us.
Gosh, we've had quite a day.
It's been a wonderful day.
I am going to respond but first I'd
like Dr. Sullivan said he has been
with us all day and I'm looking
around and I wanted to ask him
if he's willing to make some
comments on what he's heard
and maybe present another challenge
for the Library of Congress
to which I will attempt to respond.
Would you mind?
Would you like-- Yes,
let's get a microphone.
>> Well, let me say again for me
this has been a very exciting,
very rewarding day and I
think I've learned a lot
from all of the presenters here.
I was thinking it was back
in 1979 that Joyous Richmond
when he was surgeon general
and assistant secretary
of health issued a report
called Healthy People.
That was a prescription for indeed
people taking responsibility
for their own health in
setting goals for them
and it's been my pleasure
and opportunity as secretary
to issue an update
Healthy People 2000
which we issues in
September of 1990.
It had grown then.
We had some 298 objectives for
people really taking responsibility
for their health and showing
people the power that they had
to indeed protect their health
and project their health forward.
That has really now it its
current iteration is now Healthy
People 2020.
So this has been a growing effort.
It has become much-- The public
has become much more aware of this,
individual citizens, companies
promoting health behavior
in their employees
and the recognition
of the business community
that a healthy work
for us is a positive for them.
I was pleased to see the business
representation here today.
So, I think that with the growing
interest and focus on this as well
as the fact that with the Affordable
Care Act we've now provided added
resources for this.
This is a great opportunity so
I think we have a lot yet to do,
a lot of challenges but I think the
environment is much more positive.
Twenty or 30 years ago much of
what today's discussion was about,
people would have interpreted as
well kind of feel good activity,
something that makes you feel better
but we don't really
know whether it works.
But then now have been
enough studies showing
that physical activity reduces
death rates, reduces heart disease,
diabetes make slow the progression
of development of Alzheimer's.
So, I think we have enough now
that the kinds of activities
that have been described
today really should go forward
and as we heard from our
business colleagues return
on investment is now
very much documented.
So I think this for me has
been a very enlightening day,
a very encouraging day and I
certainly think the Library
of Congress is a great place
to really help get this movement
further around the country
so those are my comments, thank you.
>> John Cole: Well,
thank you very much.
And thank you for joining us
today it's really been a joy
and you've made a major
contribution.
I see a couple of other people
before I present we're not going
on much longer it's
been a wonderful day
but Laura Bailey has
been with me for this.
We have done the planning with
help from many others for this.
I'm wondering if you might want
to say a few things about today
and Robi would you like to say a few
things in a minute and then I'll try
to rewind this up and get us out of
here with promises for the future
that I hope we can follow up on?
>> Well, I would also
to thank John and all
of his helpers at Library
of Congress.
I was kind of saying to John and
others at a meeting in February here
that I don't think you always
realize the power of your brand
and the Library of Congress
is a brand like no other.
And I think when you put your name
behind the cause really great things
can happen and I so appreciate
everyone who's been here all day,
all the speakers, all the planning
that went in to your comments
and I hope it was a
good for everyone.
I certainly learned a lot.
I do think that the theme of urgency
came up a couple of times Jeff
and I talked about that at lunch
and then Rebecca mentioned
the urgency is her Magic Wand,
how do we keep this issue present
and have that sense of urgency.
We really do know enough
to certainly make things
much better than they are.
And so, where do we find that
urgency and will to work together
in some new ways to get
this done, so thank you
and I'll pass it to Robbie.
>> John Cole: Thank you very much.
>> Robbie Harris: It's a privilege
right now to say a few words,
just a few, at the end to be here.
I'm just sitting thinking
about the fact that as authors
and illustrators as I
mentioned this morning we're
on our own room working a way
and then with our publishers
and editors and wonderful people.
But we're not out there doing the
work that all of you are doing
so what I hope and what I learned
from today is that I want to go back
to my friends and colleagues
and everybody in the field
of children's books
and all even apps,
people are creating apps what's
going online and say, you know,
there's something about health
out there that all of those can do
and continue to do if we
really, really care deeply
about the children in
out family and certainly,
thank you all who've talked about
our most vulnerable families
and ways that hopefully one can help
those families move out of poverty.
And I think this is
certainly that's the record--
that struck a chord in me, so many
people talked about it so thank you
for all that all of you do.
>> John Cole: And finally-- Jeff
would you like to say something
at the end today and this
will be the last person call--
>> Oh that's pressure John.
>> John Cole: No, no.
I'm putting the pressure
on myself Jeff.
I just want you folks to get
a chance to say something.
>> Well I just want to thank again
everybody for participating today
and as I've said to several
people during the day.
This is really one of the few
opportunities, unfortunately one
of the few opportunities we
have for so many people who look
at this problem from so many
different place whether it's working
with adults as I do, whether
it's working with government,
private sector, business,
children's literacy and in health
and it doesn't happen often
enough and I think, you know,
when we saw the connections being
made and the recommendations
that you're talking about Tony,
you can see how much value
these kind of discussions have.
And I guess I would just end
with, you know, I hope we live
with that spirit that this
is a collective issue.
There's a lot of energy and
it's incredibly important,
we talked a lot about early
childhood and how crucial that is.
But it goes beyond.
It goes also to older children,
teenagers and of course adults
and we've got to look
at this problem
from all those perspectives I think
for us to make significant progress.
So again thank you to everyone
who put this day together it
was wonderful and thank you John
and I look forward to
your closing remarks.
>> John Cole: I'm going to promise
things right that, who knows.
Also however Tony thank
you, I mean we've--
it's been a wonderful experience
inside the library to do this
and I'll just share
that with you a little.
First we have three or four board
members from the literacy board
which is I'm going to say a little
bit about the literacy project
and how we might with
literacy awards program
and how we might carry forward.
But even within the Library of
Congress today and I was so pleased
that we had our own,
Dr. Charles was here,
the people from health
services I learned a lot
about what the Library of Congress.
We are a big organization,
3800 people spread all
over this area and in other places.
And I was so pleased in their
interest in this and I learned
and that's another example of, you
know, we need to get to talk more
and learn about our own
organizations and see
which way they're headed.
Now the library of congress has--
is an exciting part of our history
right now because the new Librarian
of Congress has been nominated.
We are hoping that there will be
hearings soon and I was so pleased
that the department of education
had a hearing on a new leader
and nobody stop that
and it sailed through
and we are hoping for
new leadership.
It also has to be confirmed
by the senate
which is I'm pausing a little
bit here but we have great hopes.
So here are some of
the opportunities
and I appreciate what people said.
I see them through my job, my
two fold job for which I'm paid
and my other job for which I'm
not paid which is as a historian
of the Library of Congress.
I can see an opportunity coming
historically for this institution
with new leadership because a lot
has happened in terms of outreach
and those of you who were able to
join us last night met the person
who introduced Dr. Bailey, Jane
who is the new director of national
and international outreach.
And this is the new department
comes out of a larger department
but it indicates a new interest in
outreach for the Library of Congress
that is above board, it's the name
of the organization is outreach.
And the Library of Congress has
had a lot of outreach going on
but it's been segmented and it's
not really been up front in the way
that it needs to be now
because as an institution
as we've developed
we had 5200 employees
in the Library of Congress in 1992.
We now have 3800.
We have not given up
a single function.
We still have strong prestige.
We still have dedicated people who
were working on each of these areas.
One of the reasons that numbers gone
down is a good reason it's
cataloging it's been centralized
they are-- automation has helped us
but we're also doing
a lot of outsourcing.
So we haven't lost any functions and
in the mean time outreach has grown.
And part of it is our
presence on the website.
When we first develop the
national digital library of
and then eventually the
worldwide web came along,
the Library of Congress did some
testing for the digitalization
that we've been doing and had
struck a bargain with congress
about funding yet another new office
and the bargain that was struck was
if we paid with private money
with a Madison council group
that supports us to get started
with the national digital library
and then did some testing about
who is using our digitize product
which turned to be American history
American memory would congress go
along and help fund the development
of this national digital library?
Well, we succeeded in that but
guess what the new survey did
after two years.
It showed us we had a whole
new class of users, students
and teachers were using
American memory and some
of our digitized products.
And one of the results
was the creation
of something called
educational outreach.
So for the first time we have a
major outreach function funded
by congress to reach out
to teachers and students.
And they bring students here to
learn how to use online resources.
I'm going towards this idea of
reaching out internationally
because our international
role has grown
since World War II the
same time the worldwide web
and this new educational
outreach has started.
And our new emphasis has got to be
and I'm sure the new librarian will
recognize this on the education side
and in the areas-- so this is
actually impart why the center
for the book was created with
Dr. Boorstin [assumed spelling]
where he looking ahead
we were reaching
out to promote books in reading.
And one of the answer actually when
I'm thinking of Rob in a way is
that we have established centers
every state, we don't pay for them,
they are partnership
organizations that have the job
of promoting locally books, reading,
literacy and libraries in that area
and that's closely
associated with state pride.
And each state wants to have and
keep a state center but they have
to do something and they have
to really reevaluate
after every three years.
And as the installation of the pride
in the state and put it together
in our country but it's
the state pride issue
which we also are capitalizing
on in such a way that we have
in Alaska center for the book.
They tell you what work they do,
they promote reading and literacy
in Alaska but they use it with the
state library and they do data basis
about Alaska writers each state.
And we have helped develop
through our national book
festival a whole system of state
and regional book festivals.
We don't run them they're
locally done.
But it's a long this idea of rebirth
at the state level of activities
that are related to
education, books,
reading, literacy and libraries.
And I think that if I have, you
know, I have much to say about it
and I'm working hard at it is the
area with this where we are headed.
David Rubenstein has
helped us immensely.
He the benefactor I talked about
earlier today by doing the funding
for the national book festival, I
mean, for the Library of Congress
to have a national book festival
free that celebrates readers
and writers and now has moved
to the conventions center.
And last year the convention
center put out a news release,
we moved from the mall on
to the convention center.
It said that one day crowd was
the largest crowd in the history
of the Washington Convention Center.
They estimated 125 to 150,000
people came to that program
which now Mr. Rubenstein with the
development of the program part
of today also is helping with the
literacy corner at the book festival
and with the outreach
that we are doing
with the literacy awards program
is being tied in institutionally
in ways that I think give
me hope for just some
of the suggestions that were here.
I didn't mention Judy is
still here but I mention--
should have answered with
having NLS as part of this along
with health services
the center for the book.
We are able to pull the library
together in this area of reading
and literacy promotion in
ways that we've not done.
Now, this isn't a complete answer
but it is an answer I think
to the hopefulness of carrying
on with some of the ideas
that we've talked about today
because Mr. Rubinstein
is quite interested
in helping support this kind
of activity and with the help
from our partners and our advisory
board members who are here today,
we continue to stretch literacy and
the Library of Congress in new ways.
Last year's symposium was literacy
in poetry, this year it's poetry,
it's literacy and health and we've
made new friends and new partners.
There'll be another one next year,
two people and are meeting on,
the day before yesterday, they
say it's got to be on literacy
and technology and we'll
have another board member
who really thinks it should be on
literacy and indigenous cultures
which would bring us into
a whole another range
of partners plus we have picked up
partners along the way, Reach Out
and Read was here today and, you
know, the fact that it not only,
you know, was-- it isn't
here because it was a winner
of the Rubinstein Award,
it's here because its work is
so important to what we're doing.
And so we're going to be using the
literacy awards program also funded
by Mr. Rubinstein as part
of this outreach effort.
. And I explained, I-- well,
other some of people weren't here
and I'll slow down in a second, but
we're expanding the number of awards
that are organizations that are
recognized through their work
in literacy in this program,
I talked about that a
little bit last night.
And we would be able to expand
and to include the range
of organizations that are here.
And we also want to look back
to past winners, if you are part
of the network now and
even though Reach Out
and Read has always been a reading
and literacy promotion partner
to help with this new outreach.
So I end up, I'm sorry I'm going
on a bit but I'm optimistic
and this kind of meeting
has teach me optimistic
because I can see partners and
interest and I also as a historian
of the Library of the Congress
know its potential in terms
of international outreach.
I know its potential in terms of
technology and part of this is--
and I also know the potential
of having new leadership
in an organization like this.
Library of Congress was created
in 1800, we've had 13 librarians
of congress, it's a long term
of offices especially who one
of them only lasted a year
and a half, he died in office.
So you're talking about,
now there's a limitation
which I think is a good thing
on the term of the library
and of the congress
to a total of 20 years
with 10 year and a 10 year renewal.
But it is a period historically
that is will be a revitalization
for the library and your presence
in the planning that's been done
in bringing us all together, I
consider to be an important part
of it and I would challenge myself
and I challenge the rest of you
to keep us on the track
that you've helped us step
on today and move ahead.
So I'm going to end, thank you
all for participating especially
to Laura and board members,
the NEMOURS was we couldn't
have done this without NEMOURS
and we're just very pleased
with everything that's going on
and I think we have a number
of our participants here
and let's give them a hand and thank
you very much for being with us.
We'll be back in touch but let's--
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.